WELCOME TO
PUBLIC SAFETY SIX THIS
REPUBLICAN- WELCOME TO THE
PUBLIC SIX. BANGING THE LOUD
NOISE OF AN PUBLIX CAN- WE WILL
BEGIN. BY READING MY NORMAL
STATEMENT- FOR THE PUBLIC WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
HEARING BY VISITING THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AT- H. T. T.
P. S- A. P. S. F. DOT ASSEMBLY
DOT CA DOT GOV PLEASE NOTE THAT
ANY WRITTEN TESTIMONY SUBMITTED
COMMITTEE CONSIDER PUBLIC
COMMENT AND MAYBE READ INTO THE
RECORD OR REPRINTED ALL ARE
ENCOURAGED TO WATCH THE HEARING
FROM ITS LIVESTREAM ON THE
ASSEMBLY WEBSITE AT W. W. DOT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV.
BACKSLASH TODAY'S EVENTS. THE
HEARING ROOM WILL BE OPEN FOR
ATTENDANCE FOR THIS HEARING. ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC ATTENDING A
HEARING IS ENCOURAGED TO WEAR A
MASK AT ALL TIMES WHILE IN THE
BUILDING THE PROGRAM MAY ALSO
PARTICIPATE IN HIS HEARING BY
TELEPHONE WE ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO MONITOR THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE FOR UPDATES.
IN ORDER TO FACILITATE THE GOAL
OF HEARING AS MUCH FROM THE
PUBLIC WITHIN THE LIMITS OF OUR
TIME. WE WILL NOT PERMIT CONTACT
THAT DISRUPTS. DISTURBS PER
OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF LEGISLATIVE
PROCEEDINGS. PLEASE BE AWARE
THAT VIOLATIONS OF THESE RULES
MAY SUBJECT YOU TO REMOVAL OR
OTHER ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. UP
OUR GOAL IS TO GO THROUGH THE
AGENDA EMPOWER WAS STANDING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. PRESENTING
THEIR BILLS TOWARDS THE END OF
THE HEARING. THAT WOULD BE US
HERE AT THE DICE. THIS BEGIN
WITH SOME HOUSEKEEPING- OFF
CALENDAR- I HAVE TWO BILLS- THAT
WILL PULL BY THE AUTHOR. ITEM
NUMBER SIX A. B. TWO ONE THREE
EIGHT MERIT SU CHI PO BY AUTHOR
. ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWO THREE
SIX SIX PATTERSON POLL BY AUTHOR. WE WILL NOW WILL ESTABLISH
IMPORTANT TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL JONES SAWYER HERE LACKEY
YOUR- YEAH BONTA. BRIAN WORK
YOUR SANTIAGO THEY ARE TO CORN
IS PRESENT AND CREDIT- WE HAVE
THE FOLLOWING ITEMS SIX ITEMS
THAT ARE ON CONSENT- ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB SIXTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
COOPER CARRILLO PROF THEY
TEARING AS A TORTURE
UNEMPLOYMENT AND DISABILITY
INSURANCE FRAUD WITH AN URGENCY
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY SEVEN
OH SIX THE BEING IN THE SENSE
COMMISSION PILOT PROGRAMS ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN A. B. TWO ZERO SIX
SEVEN SALAS LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT HIRING GRANTS ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN. A. B. NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN LACKEY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE DATA COLLECTION ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY FOUR LACKEY GABRIEL'S LAW
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY NINE CORK COMMISSION
ON PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING ASSESSMENT UP TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS. WE GET A MOTION.
BENCIC CALL THE ROLL. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR JOHNSON HI
JONES SAWYER HI LACKEY LACKEY HI
BONTA ON TAP HI BRIAN. WORK HIGH
WORK I SANTIAGO THEY ARE TO SEE
OUR TÔI. CONSENT CALENDAR THE
DOCTOR AT FIRST UP ON THE AGENDA
IS ITEM NUMBER ONE AB TWO TWO
EIGHT SEVEN POWER QUE CON K. ED-
HATE CRIME SYMBOLS. YOU HAVE-
YOU WITNESSES WE HAVE WITNESSES
. OKAY WHENEVER YOU'RE READY TO
BEGIN MISTER CHERUB FACED WITH
ALL OF YOU THIS. SO FIRST I WANT
TO START BY THINKING THE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH US ON THIS BILL
AND GETTING US TO. A GOOD PLACE-
WHERE WE CAN MOVE IT FORWARD AND
TO ADD A HAPPY TO TAKE THAT
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
TODAY. CAME HERE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY TO A BILL THAT
WOULD EQUALIZE PENALTIES ON
THREE PROMINENT SYMBOLS OF
TERROR THE NEWS THE ****
SWASTIKA AND A BURNING CROSS. IN
JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY OF BLACK
DAHLE WAS FOUND HANGING FOR A
POWER LINE IN SOUTH LAKE TAHOE
WITH A NOOSE AROUND ITS NECK. IN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY. THE
MAN WALKED ACROSS THE TOWN OF
FAIRFAX PLACING SWASTIKAS ON THE
TELEPHONE POLES. IN MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE NINETEEN YEAR
OLD AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN IN A
ROW GRANDIER GRANDET NEAR SAN
LUIS OBISPO. AWOKE TO SEE AN
ELEVEN FOOT TALL CROSS OF
LEASING IN AN ADJACENT LOT
DIRECTED TOWARDS HER HOME. THIS
ALL OCCURRED IN JUST THE LAST
FEW YEARS THE SYMBOLS OF TERROR
CONTINUE TO PLAGUE OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND LET'S BE CLEAR
THE INTENT OF THESE INCIDENTS IS
OFTEN TO TERRORIZE THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY ARE. F.
CRIME STATISTICS REPORT THE HATE
CRIME SURGE THE HIGHEST LEVEL IN
TWELVE YEARS IN TWENTY TWENTY.
WITH CRIMES MOTIVATED BY RACE
ALMOST DOUBLING. STATISTICS SHOW
THAT 56% OF ALL HATE CRIMES IN
AMERICA ARE MOTIVATED BY ANTI
BLACK SENTIMENT. RANG THE
PANDEMIC HATE CRIMES AGAINST
ASIAN AMERICANS WERE AT AN ALL
TIME HIGH FUEL BY CLAIMS OF
BLAME FOR THE PANDEMIC. DESPITE
CAMPAIGNS TO COMBAT THESE TRENDS
SYMBOLS OF HATE CONTINUE TO
APPEAR ALL OVER CALIFORNIA WITH
THE GOAL OF TERRORIZING AND
INTIMIDATING MINORITIES. ARE
LAWS ON THE SYMBOLS OF TERROR
HAVE BEEN PIECEMEAL TOGETHER
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS AND ARE
WOEFULLY INCONSISTENT. FOR
EXAMPLE ANYONE CAUGHT HANGING A
NOOSE CAN ONLY BE CHARGED WITH A
MISDEMEANOR REGARDLESS OF THE
NUMBER OF OFFENSES. ANYONE
CAUGHT HOSTING A SWASTIKA UNDER
CURRENT LAW CAN BE CHARGED WITH
A MISDEMEANOR ON THE FIRST OF.
AND SUBSEQUENT OFFENSE CAN BE
CHARGED AS A WOBBLER. HE'S THE
LOCATIONS FOR WHICH THESE
SYMBOLS MAY BE PLACED ALSO
DIFFERS ACROSS THE CODE WHEN.
EARNING CROSS MORE THAN A
SWASTIKA AND A NOOSE LESS THAN A
SWASTIKA WE ARE NEGATING THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL IMPACT OF PHYSICAL
THREAT TO A TARGETED GROUP. WITH
HATE CRIMES INCREASING ACROSS
THE STATE IT'S CRITICAL TO
RECOGNIZE THE POWER AND
DESTRUCTIVENESS OF THE SYMBOLS.
AND RESTRICT THEIR USE
ACCORDINGLY AND CONSISTENTLY AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY TWO WILL
EQUALIZE THE PENALTIES FOR ALL
THREE OF THE STATE THESE TERROR
SYMBOLS BY MAKING THEM OFF THE
FIRST TIME WOBBLER THE BILL ALSO
EQUALIZE THE LOCATIONS FOR WHICH
THE SYMBOLS CAN BE CHARGED.
WE'VE HAD NUMEROUS DISCUSSIONS
REGARDING CONCERNS ABOUT THE
EXPANSION INCLUDING A PUBLIC
LOCATIONS AND A POTENTIAL
VIOLATIONS TO THE FIRST
AMENDMENT BUT I WANT TO SAY IT
AS I'VE SAID IN THIS COMMITTEE
BEFORE. CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
COMMUTE ON AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
CALIFORNIANS IS CRITICAL TO ME
AND WE WORKED HARD TO LIMIT THE
LAW TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
PROTECTING CALIFORNIANS RIGHT TO
EXPRESS THEMSELVES FOR THE FIRST
AMENDMENT WHILE ALSO
UNDERSTANDING THE LIMITATIONS
PLACED ON THAT SPEECH BY THE
COURTS. WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS KIND
OF CLOSE AYE DIRECTOR OF POLICY
WITH THE ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE
MARC LEVINE WITH THE NAME
OPPOSING ABOLISHED OF MORAN AND
THEY'RE BOTH ON THE PHONE. MOVE
THE BILL. IS PROMOTED SICK WILL
NOT FROM. WITNESSES BY TELEPHONE
. MARK WITH THE K. I. KNOW IT'S
CONFUSING THIS. YOU MAY BEGIN MR
LEVINE. EIGHTEEN UP EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR KILLER FIRST WITNESS
AND- ONE MOMENT. IT WILL BE IN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU MIGHT
HAVE YOUR ME BUT NONE. GOOD
MORNING THE POWER BEHIND MR
JONES SAWYER AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BY MARC LEVINE FROM NOW
ON MARN WHICH STANDS FOR NAME
OPPOSE IN ABOLISHED EIGHT. MY
FAMILY HISTORY IN THE OF
HOLOCAUST VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS.%
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY A
YOUNG NAY OR NOT HE TRAVELED
SIXTY EIGHT MILES TO THE SMALL
TOWN OF FAIRFAX. IN MARIN COUNTY
AND POSTED PICTURES WITH
SWASTIKAS AND THE SLOGAN WE ARE
EVERYWHERE. IT DID NOT SEEM HE
WAS TARGETING A JEWISH
POPULATION. IS ONLY MATHIS WHAT
TO INSPIRE FEAR ACROSS THE
ENTIRE SPECTRUM OF THE
COMMUNITY. THE YOUNG FAIRFAX
RESIDENT CONFRONTED HIM AND THE
POLICE WERE ALERTED. BADLY THE
DA COULD NOT PROSECUTE HIM
BECAUSE OF GAPS IN PENAL CODE
ONE ONE FOUR ONE ONE. IT'S
HEINOUS ACT AND THE FAILURE OF
LAW BECAME A PEBBLE THAT BECAUSE
NOT RIPPLES. BUT WAVES OF
OUTRAGE IN OUR COUNTY. AT THESE
EVENTS WERE HARDLY ISOLATED THE
MARIN COUNTY. NO MARIN AND A TWO
TO A TWO. PATTERSON FILLING.
MAKE LARA THE HEY NUMBER OF THE
NEWS WHAT THE- AND BURNING CROSS
AS UNIFORM AND YOU'VE- AS PART.
A UNIFORM APPROACH FOR TEXAS
ALL. FROM THE SENATE THERE
STRATEGY PURVEYORS OF HATE USE
THE MANIPULATE THE ASSEMBLED.
OFTEN ASSOCIATED. WITH WHITE
SUPREMACY. WHAT BECAUSE THE
BURNING CAR. OPEN DOT DOOR MORE
PARA THE- IS UNDER TRUE INCREASE
QUE. A TWO TWO EIGHT WILL TO PAY
THIS. THANK TO THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE TO THE FAMILY MEMBERS
POWER BEHIND AND LEVINE FOR A
WONDERFUL EXAMPLE OF LEGISLATURE
AND COMMUNITY COLLABORATION.
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK AND THAT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KIND OF
COINCIDE AND I AM DIRECTOR OF
POLICY FOR THE ANTI DEFAMATION
LEAGUE'S WESTERN DIVISION I'D
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BIERBAUER CAN PREDICT AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR INVITING US TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB CUTE
YOU'RE- YEAR. STARTED IN
NINETEEN THIRTEEN IN RESPONSE TO
AN ESCALATING CLIMATE OF ANTI
SEMITISM AND BIGOTRY EIGHTY L.
NOW HAS BECOME A LEADING ANTI
HATE ORGANIZATIONS WITH TWENTY
FOUR REGIONAL OFFICES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. LET'S MAKE NO MISTAKE
THE NEWS BURNING ACROSS
ANTARCTICA ARE SYMBOLS OF HATE
THAT ARE DELIBERATELY USED TO
TERRORIZE RACIAL ETHNIC AND
RELIGIOUS MINORITY NEARLY EVERY
DAY AND EIGHTY ALL WE RECEIVE
REPORTS FROM TERRIFIED COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AT THE SYMBOLS OF
TERROR- IN THEIR COMMUNITIES ARE
AFFECTING THEIR EVERYDAY LIVES
THIS IS A REAL PROBLEM. AB TWO
THREE TWO SIX ALIGN THE
PENALTIES FOR USING A SIMPLE
REPAIR TECH THE TERRORISTS IT'S
EXPAND THE LOCATION WHERE SUCH
ACTS ARE ILLEGAL WE MUST RESPOND
TO THE RECENT RISE AND ANTI
SEMITIC EXTREMISTS AND HATE.
FIELD INCIDENT. A. B. COMMUNITY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. FOR THE
COMMUNITY IN PART. SO OFTEN ARE
HURTFUL THE MEMBER OF THEM THAN
SIX MILLION JEWS. AND MILLIONS
OF OTHER WHO ARE SYSTEMATICALLY
MURDERED BY THE REGIME. INDEED A
SWASTIKA CONTINUES TO SERVE AS
OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT AND
ACCORDING AMBLED EIGHT IF THEY
SENATORS. AND WHITE SUPREMACY
TODAY. IT IS VITAL THAT WE
STRIKE BACK BEGINS ACT THAT
INTIMIDATION WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL OF THE FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHT TO FREE SPEECH AND
EXPRESSION. WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO DO JUST
THAT. WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB
TEACHER A TEAR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NOW BRING IT INTO THE ROOM
ARE. THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. OF AB TWO EIGHTY TO
NAME AN ORGANIZATION PLACE. GREG
HERE THE ARK AND UNITED CEREBRAL
PALSY CALIFORNIA COVERAGE AND WE
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN WAS
CORY CELLS- ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINES ARE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY TWO- AT&T
OPERATOR COULD YOU OPEN A BLIND
. Q- NINE THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU
CLOSE BERGEN BEHALF OF THE SIMON
WIESENTHAL CENTER IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU. N. LINE
THIRTY SIX YOUR OPEN. THANK YOU
CAN I DON'T I DON'T ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. YOU HAVE BOB
PERSON WITH AN OPERATOR ONE
MOMENT. THE NEXT MINUS THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF ANY
MARK HUGHES ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT. THE NEXT CALLER IS LINE TWENTY
EIGHT. HELLO GOOD MORNING THIS
IS MORGAN BLOM SCHNEIDER
STRONGLY SUPPORT I REPRESENT THE
HOLOCAUST CENTER OF JEWISH
FAMILY AND CHILDREN'S SERVICES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND THE
NEXT OUR QUESTION IS. LINE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD AND-
HELLO MY NAME IS MARK GOLDBERG
I'M IN A LOT OF COUNCIL MEMBER
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
PASSAGE OF AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LINE NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING STEPHANIE
HOW MANY LAYERS FACT BACK BACK
ON BEHALF OF THE CONTACT BACK
WITH STRONG WITH THE COURT AB
TWENTY TWO A DETAIL THANK YOU.
YOU IN LINE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS CONSTANCE
CARROLL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BACCALAUREATE ASSOCIATION-
PROBABLY SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LINE THIRTEEN. MY
NAME IS DAVID CUTLER GOD HELP
LEVEL THE JEWISH CONGREGATION OF
CENTRAL VALLEY WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT PASSAGE OF AB TWO TWO
EIGHT TWO. THANK YOU LINE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THANK
YOU DEBORAH CHOI TURNED MEMBER
OF MARIN COUNTY JEWISH COMMUNITY
AND JEWISH EDUCATOR IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO TWO EIGHT TWO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND LINE THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I LIKE THE-FINE MEN MAYOR OF SAN ANSELMO
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWO TWO EIGHT TWO. THANK YOU SO
MUCH JAN THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH. THIS IS STANDING
FROM NOVA MARIN NAME OPPOSE IN A
HATE IN STE SUPPORTER A. TWO TWO
EIGHT TWO. THE BOARD THANK YOU
ANALYZE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS RACHEL CURRENT-
COUNCILMEMBER FOR CENTER WELL-
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THE AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY TWO. AT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH IN LINE
TWENTY FIVE. YEAH THIS IS BRIAN
COLE BEAR. MAYOR OF ST THOMAS I
STRONGLY SHOULD START THIS IS
RANKED OVER COUNCIL MEMBER SENT
SOME- I STRONGLY SUPPORT WELL.
FIVE THANK YOU AND THERE ARE NO
FURTHER. HE POINTED OUT THE
MANAGER. YOU KNOW WHAT MORAN
NAMED. DAWLISH HATE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF. EIGHT EIGHT TWO TWO
TWO. OR THANK YOU M. LINE TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THAT IT OPERATOR. THERE'S NO ONE
I THINK YOU. THANK YOU WE'RE NOW
BRINGING IN- ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY TWO. YOU HAVE FIVE
MINUTES. TOTAL BETWEEN THE TWO
OF YOU. I BELIEVE WE HAVE MARGO
GEORGE AND FRED WILLIAMS ACLU
AND CPT A. GOOD MORNING CHEN
MEMBERS FRED WILLIAMS ACLU CAL
ACTION AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY TWO FIRST
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR STAFF
BEING OPEN TO WORKING WITH US.
AND YOU KNOW ENGAGE WITH THE
SUBS TO GO ON THE BILL BY THE
ACLU CERTAINLY RESPECT THE AIM
OF THIS BILL WE HAVE THREE
OUTSTANDING CONCERNS THAT WILL
LIKELY ALSO TO ADDRESS IF THE
BILL WERE TO MOVE FORWARD HERE
TODAY. FIRST AND THIRD AND
SUBDIVISION EIGHT RELATED TO NEW
SYSTEM REQUIREMENTTHAT THE
OFFENDER KNOWS IT TO BE A SYMBOL
REPRESENTING THREAT TO LIFE AND
SUBDIVISION C. RELATING-
INCIDENTS EITHER REQUIREMENT.
THAT THE OFFENDER IT KNOWS THE
SYMBOL ALSO BE RELIGIOUS SYMBOL
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS
LANGUAGE ADAM SUBDIVISION BE
THAT MIRRORS THE OTHER SECTION
KNOWLEDGE REQUIREMENT TO ALSO
HELP WITH THE AIM OF BREVITY AND
CLARITY. WE ALSO HOPE THE AUTHOR
WILL PROVIDE SOME CLARITY AROUND
WHAT IT MEANS FOR PERSON TO BE
ASSOCIATED WITH A COLLEGE CAMPUS
PUBLIC PARK FACILITY PUBLIC
SPACE. PLACE OF WORSHIP SEMATECH
CENTER AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN THE
LANGUAGE IS A BIT BAY CAN WE
STILL BE INTERPRETED IN OVER THE
BROADBAND. FINALLY WE ACTUALLY
ARE THE TO REMOVE THE INCREASING
PENALTIES PROVIDED IN THE BILL
IT'S BEEN PROVEN IN NUMEROUS
STUDIES THAT INCREASE PENALTIES
ARE NOT EFFECTIVE DETERRENT TO
CRIME WE WOULD ASK THAT THE GOAL
THE PENALTY ALIGNMENT THAT IS
ACCOMPLISHED WITHOUT RAISING THE
PENALTIES IN THE BILL. AGAIN
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
ENGAGING ON THE ISSUE BUT YOU
DOCTOR ON THE LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL WE MUST RESPECT THE ACTING
OF A AT THIS. TIME THANK YOU
THANK YOU MCGEORGE. GOOD MORNING
. I'M THE DAUGHTER AND
GRANDDAUGHTER OF SURVIVORS OF
ANTI SEMITIC VIOLENCE MY
GRANDPARENTS FLED RUSSIA TWO
WEEKS GAVE THE ORGANIZED
MASSACRES KNOWN AS PROGRAMS THAT
THE SAR LAUNCHED AGAINST JEWS MY
FATHER CHANGED HIS NAME FROM
GOLDSTINE TO GEORGE WHEN HE WENT
SOUTH TO ORGANIZED LABOR UNIONS
TO AVOID GETTING KILLED. I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE WITH THE
SENTIMENT THAT WAS EXPRESSED BY
THE SUPPORTERS LETTER THAT THE
RISE IN WHITE SUPREMACY AND
EXTREMISM IS CONNECTED TO
INCREASES IN ANTI DEMOCRATIC
BEHAVIOR IN OUR STATE AND
REFLECTED IN THE INCREASED
APPEARANCE OF THE SYMBOLS. I
AGREE WITH THE ACLU AND WOULD
ECHO THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT THE
LACK OF A KNOWLEDGE REQUIREMENT
. AND ALSO ABOUT THE VAGUENESS
ABOUT THE- IT'S NOT JUST THE
**** SYMBOL BUT SYMBOL SIGN MARK
SYMBOL EMBLEM OR OTHER PHYSICAL
IMPRESSION IS OUTLAWED BY THIS
PROPOSED STATUTE. AND MY LETTER-
I TALKED ABOUT THAT Q. ANON
MEMBERS MIGHT BE TERRORIZED BY
LBGTQ MEMBER PEOPLE WALKING DOWN
THE STREET WITH THE K. FLAG
BECAUSE THEY WOULD SEE THAT AS A
SYMBOL OF PEDOPHILE YOU. IN
GENERAL I ALSO AGREE WITH WHAT
THE A SO YOU SAID ABOUT THE
HARMS OF CREATING NEW WALL BLURS
. ACCORDING TO THE BRENNAN
CENTER ONLY THREE OTHER STATES
HAVE FELONY STATUES WERE
SWASTIKAS. NEW YORK VIRGINIA AND
WASHINGTON. AND EACH ONE OF
THOSE STATES SAYS IT IS EITHER
FOR A DAMAGING INDIVIDUAL
PROPERTY. ARE DRAWING IT OR
PUTTING IT ON THE PREMISES THAT
ARE USED PRIMARILY FOR RELIGIOUS
PURPOSES OUR ON SOMEONE'S
PROPERTY. THEY'RE NOT JUST
APPLIED TO PUBLIC PLACES. THIS
WILL NOT TOUCH STEM THE TIDE OF
WHITE SUPREMACY AND EXTREMISM OR
ACTUALLY MAKE THE COMMUNITY
SAFER THIS IS A WORLDWIDE
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE FACING NOW IS
YOU KNOW PHOBIA AND WHITE
EXTREMISM AND AS A DONE A FIGHT
BY THE DURBAN SOUTH AFRICA
DECLARATION AND PROGRAMME OF
ACTION. AND WE APPLAUD NO- MO
HAN. THE YOUNG RAPPER IN FAIRFAX
WHO TOLD THE NINETEEN YEAR OLD
KID WHO WAS POSTING THIS HUASTEC
GOES. ON STICKERS TO TAKE HIS
FLYERS AND GET OUT OF TOWN. NO
WHAT DID HIS PART. AND
POLITICIANS AND EDUCATORS AND
EVERYONE ELSE MUST DO THEIR PART
AND CALL OUT AND REFUSED TO
ACCEPT WHITE SUPREMACIST IN
THEIR MIDST WE'RE THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THEIR AMENDMENTS BUT
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE ON AB TWO TWO EIGHT TWO.
CRIMINALIZING BEHAVIOR WILL NOT
STOP AT. THANK YOU THANK YOU GOD
IF ANY WITNESSES IN THE HEARING
ROOM IN OPPOSITION. SHE NINE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES INTO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY TWO OPEN UP
PHONE LINES- EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR. Q. AND IF THERE ARE
ANY WITNESSES PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE PERSON
THAT CUED UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
AND NINE FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO I WAS NOT ALLOWED TO
SPEAK PRIOR TO THIS I FULLY
SUPPORT AB TWO TWO EIGHT TWO MY
NAME IS JEFF LERNER I SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME THERE'S
NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU WE NOW
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. MISTER ISAAC. I JUST
WANT THINK THE OFFERING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND THE OPPOSITION
FOR SPEAKING SO ELOQUENTLY I
KNOW THE AUTHOR'S INTENTION-
BEHIND THIS BILL AND I TRUST
THAT THE OPPOSITION'S COMMENTS
HAVE BEEN WELL FOUNDED IN WELL
HEARD AND I TRUST THAT THE
AUTHOR WILL WORK ON THIS GOING
FORWARD AND SO. I'LL BE VOTING
IS TODAY. YES RESPOND TO.
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR- WE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT THIS
WHEN YOU WERE CONSIDERING
CARRYING IT AND- I RECOGNIZE THE
ULTIMATE INTENT WAS TO INSURE-
IN YOUR VIEW THAT WE ACTUALLY
BROUGHT EQUITY INTO THE WAY THAT
WE WERE ACTUALLY- MEETING OUT.
CONSEQUENCES FOR HATE- THE
REALITY WAS THAT PRIOR TO THIS
LEGISLATION. AT THE DISPLAYING
OF A NOOSE WAS TREATED
DIFFERENTLY. THAN IT WAS B. WHAT
IS A FOR- DISPLAYS OF THAT.
REALLY JUST A SYMBOL- AT
RELIGIOUS SYMBOLS OR OR
SWASTIKAS AND- AND IT'S SUCH A
PROFOUND. EXAMPLE OF THE WAY IN
WHICH- THE LEGACY OF SLAVERY AND
THE LEGACY OF THE TREATMENT OF.
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS AND BLACK
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY STILL TO
THIS DAY AND TO BEING SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO ENSURE. THAT WE
ADDRESS IT SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND I ALSO KNOW
THAT YOU WILL TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION. AT THE
COMMONSENSE DID THE ISSUES
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION SO I'LL
BE VOTING YES AS WELL. IN THE
OTHER. YOU MAY CLOSE- I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
COMMENTS AND RESPOND TAX FOR HER
AND- HER EXPLAINING REALLY WHEN
I CAME TO HER WHEN I WAS
THINKING ABOUT DOING THIS WHEN
WE DISCOVERED THIS IN THE CODE-
IT WAS JARRING TO ME AND YET
ALSO NOT SURPRISING. THAT WE
FIND THESE VESTIGES OF AN WHAT
HAS BEEN A LONG HISTORY OF
RACISM IN OUR CODE AND IT IS
INCUMBENT UPON US TO FIX THAT
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HERE TO DO
TODAY- I ABSOLUTELY WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION SOME OF WHAT WAS
MENTIONED I'M IS CURRENT CODE.
SO WORKING THROUGH THE ISSUES
AROUND WHAT IS VAGUE IN THE
CURRENT CODE BUT WE WANTED TO BE
CLEAR AS WE MENTIONED WE WERE
VERY CLEAR. I WAS VERY CLEAR TO
ENSURE THAT IT FOLLOWS THE
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW REQUIRES AN
INTENT TO TERRORIZE BUT IT'S NOT
ABOUT WALKING DOWN THE STREET
SHOWING YOUR PRIDE FOR A GAY
PRIDE FLAG WHICH IS CLEARLY NOT
INTENDED TO TERRORIZE ANYBODY AT
ANY MOMENTS BUT INSTEAD SHOW
YOUR IMPROPER. BILL IS LIMITED
TO THOSE THAT GOING OUT AND
USING THE SYMBOLS TO TERRORIZE
COMMUNITIES. AND CREATE FEAR.
AND COMMIT CRIMES AND AGAIN IT
IS ALREADY CRIMINAL IN OUR CODE
WE ARE DRESSED. AB MEETING IT
OUT TO JUSTLY AND EQUALLY AS IT
SHOULD BE AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I BET.
YOU THINK YEAH AND I ALSO
BELIEVE THAT YOU WILL WORK. AS
YOU WORK WITH THIS COMMITTEE- TO
MAKING CHANGES SO THAT- IT
COMPORTS WITH. OBVIOUS
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES AND- AND
ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED. BY BY
BOTH A- OPPOSITION. AND- AND
JUST IN GENERAL I KNOW- THE
REASON THE CLAN IS IT AS
POWERFUL AS BECAUSE LAWSUIT.
RECENTLY ALMOST BANKRUPTED AND
HOBBLED AND SO FINANCIAL
PENALTIES ON ORGANIZATIONS FROM
THAT STANDPOINT CAN BE CRIPPLING
SO- THIS IS IN SOME WAYS A
LITTLE BIT OF AN EXPERIMENT SO-
I THINK THE COMMITTEES WILLING
TO MOVE FORWARD I WANT TO MAKE
SURE YOU DO ADDRESS. THE WHAT
THE OPPOSITION BROUGHT UP THE
CHAIRS RECOMMEND AND I. THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
ON AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY TWO BY
SOME MEMBER OF OUR K. HAVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
JONES SAWYER. JONES SAWYER I
LACKEY. LACKEY I BONTA. BONTA HI
BRIAN. BRIAN I WORK HARD WORK I
SANTIAGO. SEYARTO THEY ARE TOO
HIGH. THE MEASURE PASSES THANK
YOU THANK YOU EVERYONE. BYE
DON'T SEE MISTER FLOOR BY DO
SEEM. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEAGUE. AB
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY FIVE. I DON'T
KNOW BEFORE- JURY INSTRUCTION
LESSER RELATED OFFENSES.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY TO BEGIN
GOOD MORNING SHARON MEMBERS- I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB TWO
FOUR THREE FIVE THIS BILL
RESTORES A SOUND LEGAL PRACTICE
THAT WAS IN PLACE FROM NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR TO NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT IN CALIFORNIA CRIMINAL
COURTS WHEN X. KEY ACCUSED
PERSON IS CHARGED WITH A
CRIMINAL OFFENSE IT IS
REASONABLE TO EXPECT THAT
CHARGES FILED THAT REFLECT ALL
EVIDENCE OF THE CASE THAT WAS
THE CASE IN CALIFORNIA FOR
FOURTEEN YEARS IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR CALIFORNIA APPELLATE
COURT RULED THAT A DEFENDANT IN
A CRIMINAL CASE WAS ENTITLED TO
ALSO PRESENT THE JURY WITH A
LESSER. RELATED EFFECTS CRIMES
THAT MAY NOT SHARE ALL THE
ELEMENTS THAT WOULD BE SUPPORTED
BY THE FACTS OF THE CASE THEN IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT DURING THE
HEIGHT OF THE SO CALLED TOUGH ON
CRIME ERA A CALIFORNIA APPELLATE
COURT OVERTURNED THIS RULING
PEOPLE THE BERKS THE BERKS COURT
CONCLUDED THAT CRIMINAL
DEFENDANTSARE NOT ENTITLED TO A
JURY INSTRUCTION ON WESTERLY
DEFENSES AND ALAS THE
LEGISLATURE MAKES THE CHANGE. AS
A RESULT FOR THE PAST TWENTY
FOUR YEARS DEFENDANTS IN A
CRIMINAL CASES HAVE BEEN UNABLE
TO ARGUE FOR CONVICTION OF
LESSER OFFENSES CURRENTLY A
DISTRICT ATTORNEY MAY FILE
CHARGES AGAINST A DEFENDANT THAT
INCLUDE A PRIMARY LEDGER FENCE
AND A LESSER INCLUDED OFFENSE
BUT DEFENDANTS ARE NOT PERMITTED
TO ASK FOR JURY INSTRUCTIONS
THAT SUPPORT AYE LESSER RELATED
OFFENSE ONE THAT IS CLOSELY
RELATED TO THE CHARGED OFFENSE
THAT HAS CREDIBLE FACTUAL BASIS
A LESSER INCLUDED OFFENSES ONE
THAT OVERLAPS OR SHARES LEGAL
ELEMENTS WITH THE CHARGED
OFFENSE. THAT IS YOU CANNOT
COMMIT THE PRIMARY FENCE WITHOUT
COMMITTING THE LESSER INCLUDED
OFFENSE THE CURRENT PRACTICE IN
CALIFORNIA CRIMINAL COURTS
PREVENTS A DEFENDANT FROM
SUBMITTING EVIDENCE THAT WOULD
ALLOW THE JURY TO CONSIDER
LESSER RELATED OFFENSE WHICH
DENIES DEFENDANTS CONSTITUTIONAL
DUE PROCESS AND A FAIR TRIAL.
RESTORING THIS PRACTICE IS NOT
ABOUT AVOIDING JUSTICE IS A
PROVIDING MORE CONVICTION
OPTIONS TO A JURY WHEN THEY ARE
SUPPORTED. BY CREDIBLE EVIDENCE
. AB TWO FOUR THREE FIVE WILL.
SOME CUTS TO BASED FAIRNESS AND
DUE PROCESS IN OUR CRIMINAL
LEGAL SYSTEM. BY PERMITTING
DEFENDANTS PRESENT TO THE JURY A
LESSER RELATED OFFENSE AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO THE PRIMARY
UNDERLYING CHARGES. I WOULD THAT
I LIKE SO LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY
TO IN THIS IS IN SUPPORT BRIAN
GARLITS FROM C. A. C. G. C. A.
C. J. AND NEXT DOOR- TEN FROM
THE L. A. COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER
WILL BE ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THE BILL. YOU MAY
BEGIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS BRIAN
GORDON I'M TESTIFYING ON BEHALF
OF C. A. C. J. THE COUNTRY'S
LARGEST STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE CRIMINAL
DEFENSE LAWYERS BRONER FOR THIS
BILL THE BOSTON GRATEFUL AUTISM
MEMBER WE ROBBERY. CORRECT
CRIMINAL LAW FOR THE PAST FOUR
SEVEN YEARS AND I'M SURE BY THE
CAL. STATE PARKS FROM THE LOS
ANGELES. IN ADDITION TO FILLING
CASES JUDGE. OF ALSO ARE DOES OF
. CASES FOR EXAMPLE FOR
INCLUDING SUPREME. YEAH I THE
IMPACT OF OUR STAY LAW UNLESS
YOU'RE OFFENSES. FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE BOTH PROSECUTORS
DEFENSE LAWYER. I WAS ADEPT D.
A. R. K. FOR THE FOR HALF MY
CAREER. IN A BEEN A PRIVATE FOR
THE HALF. WHEN I WAS A D. I
TRAINED CROSS. STAY ISSUES- ON
THE ISSUE OF JURIES. AND LESSER
INCLUDED OFFENSES SPECIFICALLY.
RESTORING THE RIGHT TO LEFT
RELATED OFFENSES WHEN THE
EVIDENCE WARRANTS IT WOULD
IMPROVE THE ACCURACY OF JURY
VERDICTS. IT WOULD LESSEN THE
NUMBER OF DEFENDANTS WERE
CONVICTED OF CRIMES THAT ARE
MORE SERIOUS THAN THE OFFENSE
THEY TRULY COMMITTED. AND IT
WOULD LESSEN THE NUMBER OF
DEFENDANTS TO AVOID CRIMINAL
LIABILITY ENTIRELY BECAUSE THE
JURY THAT ACQUITTED THEM A
BECAUSE OF A JURY THAT ACQUITTED
THEM OF THE CRIME THAT WAS
CHARGED HAD NO ABILITY TO
CONVICT THEM OF A LESSER OFFENSE
THAT WAS APPROVED. I SUSPECT THE
OVERWHELMING NUMBER OF OUR STATE
CITIZENS ACROSS THE IDEOLOGICAL
SPECTRUM WOULD WANT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE INSTRUCTED ON
LESSER RELATED OFFENSES AND HAVE
THE POWER. TO CONVICT A
DEFENDANT ON SUCH AN OFFENSE IF
THE EVIDENCE WARRANTS AT. OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM ALLOWS LESSER
RELATED OFFENSE INSTRUCTIONS
BASED SOLELY. ON THE
PROSECUTOR'S TACTICAL DECISION
AND INMY EXPERIENCE IT IS
EXTREMELY RARE FOR PROSECUTORS
TO CONSENT TO IT CALIFORNIA LAW
SHOULD BE RESTORED TO WHAT IT
WAS FROM NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR
THROUGH NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
ONE FINAL COMMENT IF I MAY
BEFORE I CLOSE. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO REALIZE THAT UNDER CURRENT
LAW NOT ONLY ARE JURORS NOT
GIVEN THE OPTION OF CONVICTING.
ON A LESSER RELATED OFFENSE BUT
THEY AREN'T EVEN INSTRUCTED ON
THE DEFINITION OF SUCH CRIMES.
SO TAKE FOR EXAMPLE. A SITUATION
WHERE YOU HAVE A MENTALLY ILL
DEFENDANT WHO'S ARRESTED INSIDE.
A BUSINESS AT NIGHT- AND THERE'S
A REAL ISSUE ON WHETHER SHE HAD
THE INTENT TO STEAL OR IS GUILTY
OF ONLY A TRESS PASSIN THE NEXT
WITNESS WILL TALK ABOUT THIS
EXAMPLE. NOT ONLY IS THE JURY IN
THAT CASE UNABLE. TO CONVICT ON
TRUST PASTOR NOT GIVEN THAT
OPTION BUT THE DEFINITION OF
TRESPASS ISN'T EVEN GIVEN TO THE
JURY. THIS ELIMINATES DEFENSE
COUNSEL'S OPPORTUNITY IN CLOSING
ARGUMENT TO EXPLAIN AND IT WOULD
BE A POWERFUL EXPLANATION WHY
THE EVIDENCE PROVES THE ELEMENTS
OF TRESPASS. CLEARLY BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT. AND THEN
COMPARE AND CONTRAST THAT. TO
THE- OVERWHELMING. THAT COMPARE
AND CONTRAST OVERWHELMING PROOF
ON THE TRESPASS. TO WHAT'S
LACKING ON THE BURGLARY AND SHOW
WHY THAT CLIENT SHOULD BE
ACQUITTED OF BURGLARY. AB TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY FIVE- RETURNED TO
POWER IN JURY TRIALS TO EXACTLY
WHERE IT SHOULD BE NON
PROFESSIONAL JURORS THAT OUR
CONSTITUTION ENTRUSTS TO BE THE
SOLE FACT FINDERS IN CRIMINAL
TRIALS. THANK YOU THANK YOU. IN
ORDER BY PHONE. NICK STEWART
OATEN PROCESSES COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER. NICK IS HAVE TECHNICAL
ISSUES A PHONE SO MARKET WAS
GONNA SOAK OKAY RECENTLY THANK
YOU THIS. GOOD TO HAVE A
DESIGNATED HITTER AND AROUND. I
AM AT- SO I'M TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF NICK STEWART OATEN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IS ONE OF THE PROUD
CO SPONSORS OF THIS BILL. AND IF
NICK WERE ABLE TO TESTIFY IS
HAVING TECHNICAL ISSUES- I'M
JUST GONNA READ HIS TESTIMONY HE
HAS BEEN A LOS ANGELES COUNTY
PUBLIC DEFENDER FOR NEARLY
FIFTEEN YEARS ANY SPEAKING TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION.
ONE OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEMS WITH CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
IS THAT PROSECUTORS CAN
UNILATERALLY PREVENT JURIES FROM
DECIDING WHETHER THE DEFENDANT
IS GUILTY OF AN OFFENCE OTHER
THAN THAT CHARGED BY THE
PROSECUTOR. EVEN WHEN THE
EVIDENCE ESTABLISHES THAT THE
DEFENDANT COMMITTED ONLY THAT
LESSER OFFENSE. A PROSECUTOR MAY
FOR EXAMPLE CHARGING MENTALLY
ILL DEFENDANTS WHO WANDERED INTO
SOMEONE'S HOUSE WITH BURGLARY.
BUT REFUSED TO ALLOW THE JURY TO
DECIDE WHETHER THEY'RE ONLY
GUILTY OF TRESPASSING. NICK HAD
THIS EXACT ISSUE WITH THE SIXTY
YEAR OLD WOMAN WAS SCHIZOPHRENIC
. WHO WAS PLACED ON A SEVENTY
TWO HOUR MENTAL HEALTH HOLD
FIFTY ONE FIFTY BECAUSE SHE BEEN
WANDERING INTO PEOPLE'S HOUSES
AND TAKING NAPS WHEN SHE WAS
RELEASED FROM THE WHOLE SHE
WANDERED DOWN THE STREET AND
ENTERED ANOTHER HOUSE. WHERE SHE
PROMPTLY TOOK ANOTHER NAP THE
PROSECUTOR CHARGED WITH
RESIDENTIAL BURGLARY A FELONY
STRIKE OFFENSE THAT CARRIES A
SENTENCE OF SIX YEARS IN STATE
PRISON BECAUSE UNDER CURRENT LAW
A JURY IS PERMITTED ONLY TO
DECIDE WHETHER THE DEFENDANT IS
GUILTY OF THE OFFENSES APPROVED
BY THE PROSECUTOR THE
PROSECUTOR'S REFUSAL TO CHARGE
TRESPASSING MEANT THAT THE JURY
WAS NOT EVEN PERMITTED TO
CONSIDER THAT CHARGE. WITH THE
CURRENT SYSTEM JURORS ARE
THEREFORE LEFT IN AN ALL OR
NOTHING SITUATION FORCED TO
DECIDE BETWEEN RELEASING A
PERSON WHO HAS CLEARLY DONE
SOMETHING WRONG OR CONVICTING
THEM OF AN OFFENSE THAT'S NOT AN
ACCURATE REFLECTION OF WHAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENED. PROSECUTORS
CAN THEREFORE OVER CHARGES
DEFENDANT WITH AN OFFENSE MORE
SERIOUS THAN MAP WARRANTED BY
THE EVIDENCE IN ORDER TO COURSE
A PLEA. CONFIDENT THAT A JURY
WILL NEVER BE ALLOWED TO DECIDE
FOR THEMSELVES WHETHER A LESS
SERIOUS OFFENSE IS APPROPRIATE.
BY ENSURE THAT JURORS NOT
PROSECUTORS OR DEFENSE ATTORNEYS
GET TO DECIDE WHAT OFFENSIVE
FINNEY IS ESTABLISHED BY THE
AVAILABLE EVIDENCE THIS MIL BILL
PROMOTES THE FAIRNESS AND A
RETURN TO JURY AND POWER MET
THAT HAS BEEN LACKING FOR THE
PAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS. FOR
THOSE REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN
AND OUT ALL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE ROOM. NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS ANTHONY DIMARTINO ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING GOING
BACK AS FOR THE ELEVATOR CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SHINO MORE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT IN ROME WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR COULD YOU OPEN UP THE
LINE FOR AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
FIVE LEE. IN SUPPORT. NAME AN
ORGANIZATION YOUR- THANK YOU AND
IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO AND WE DO
HAVE- LINE THIRTY TWO. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING JIM LINDBERG
ON BEHALF OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION- OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ONLY HAVE A
COUPLE WITH APPARATUS ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. THE NEXT THE NEXT LINE
IS FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CHEERING COMMITTEE
THIS IS GREGORY SET OUT ON
BEHALF OF INITIATE JUSTICE
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND LINE FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. REPUBLICAN REP AT THE
JESSICA AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AND THERE'S NO ONE ELSE THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU. NOW
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. SOON.
NINE IN THE ROOM- DIM WILL
AGAIN- EARLY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION. KAMOGAWA TO THE FIVE
YES OF. I'M SORRY ROBERT MASS
MAN ON THE PHONE OR THE PHONE GO
AHEAD I DO WE HAVE TO. I AM NOT
ASSISTANT DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN
ORANGE COUNTY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION- I PREVIOUSLY WORKED
WITH SUPPORT WITH THIS BRIAN
GIRL WITSEN I REMEMBER HIM
ARGUING AGAINST LESS RELATED
OFFENSES BUT I GUESS TIMES HAVE
CHANGED- AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
FIVE WE TAKE CALIFORNIA CRIMINAL
COURTS BACK DECADES TO AN
OUTDATED AND UNWORKABLE RULE.
REQUIRING COURTS TO INSTRUCT
JURIES ON LESSER RELATED
OFFENSES. OUR SUPREME COURT
STATED CALIFORNIA LAWS LONG
PROVIDED THAT EVEN ABSENT A
REQUEST AND OVER ANY PARTIES
OBJECTION TRIAL COURTS MUST
INSTRUCT ON LESSER INCLUDED
OFFENSES THESE ARE LESSER
OFFENSES NECESSARILY INCLUDED IN
SPARKS OFFENSES THIS RULES FAIR
TO BOTH SIDES AND AFFORDS EQUAL
PROTECTION TO ALL PARTIES.
LESSER RELATED OFFENSES ARE
DIFFERENT THESE ARE LESSER
OFFENSES THAT ARE NOT
NECESSARILY INCLUDED IN THE
CHARGED OFFENSE. BUT ONLY BEAR
SOME CONCEPTUAL OR EVIDENTIARY
RELATIONSHIP TO CHARGE DEFENSE
INCLUDE THE ACCUSATORY PLEADING
GIVES NO NOTICE TO SUCH NON
INCLUDED OFFENSES. HI THIS BILL
WILL TAKE US BACK TO THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES AND NINETIES.
IN AT THE TIME OF THE ROSE-
JUSTICE ROSE BIRD ERA IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT OUR
SUPREME COURT SPECIFICALLY RULED
THAT COURTS SHOULD NOT REPEAT
NOT INSTRUCT ON LESSER RELATED
OFFENSES AND THIS IS BEEN THE
LAW OF THE LAND CALIFORNIA FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS. PROBABLY THE
BEST ARGUMENT AGAINST THIS BILL.
IS FROM THE SUPREME COURT'S OWN
WORDS IN THE OPINION OF BERKS
FROM NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THE
SUPREME COURT SAID THE RATIONALE
FOR LESSER RELATED OFFENSES HAS
SINCE BEEN EXPRESSLY REPUDIATED.
FOR FEDERAL PURPOSES BY THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT AND
CONTINUES TO FIND LITTLE SUPPORT
IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS THE OLD
RULE CAN BE UNFAIR TO THE
PROSECUTION AND ACTUALLY PROMOTE
INACCURATE FACT FINDING BECAUSE
IT GIVES THE DEFENDANT A
SUPERIOR TRIAL RIGHT TO SEEK AND
OBTAIN CONVICTION FOR A LESSER-
CHARGE DEFENSE. WHOSE ELEMENTS
THE PER ROSS IS EITHER. OR
SOUGHT TO PROVE MOREOVER. REYES
QUESTIONS OR WITH THE PRIORY
ASCENTIAL BASED ON THE DO
PROCESS CLAUSE OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION CAN BE RECONCILE
WITH OTHER PROVISIONS OF THE
SAME CHARTER BY ACCORDING THE
DEFENDED THE POWER TO INSIST
OVER THE PROSECUTION'S OBJECTION
THAT ON CHRGE NOT INCLUDED
OFFENSES BE PLACED BEFORE THE
JURY THIS OLD RULE MAY YOUR SERP
THE PROSECUTION'S EXCLUSIVE
CHARGING DECISION AND MAY
THEREFORE VIOLATE THE
CONSTITUTION'S SEPARATION OF
POWERS. THIS PRIOR RULING.
ALLOWING FOR LESSER RELATED
OFFENSES IN THE- GEIGER CASE
FROM THE ROSE JUSTICE- JUSTICE
ROSE BIRD ERROR WAS QUOTE
WRONGLY DECIDED. THE SUPREME
COURT STATED THE LEGAL ANALYSIS
AND GEYER WAS QUOTE
FUNDAMENTALLY WRONG ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY UNSOUND ON QUOTE
ON WORKABLE VAGUE BROAD AND
IMPRECISE AND QUOTE UNQUOTE
FLAWED. FOR ALL THESE REASONS
CDA URGES OPPOSITION AND A NO
VOTE TO AB. TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. I
WILL GO TO THE INTO RUMORED ANY
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION. TO THE
BILL. NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINES
ARE ANY. AB EIGHTEEN OPERATOR
OPEN US OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY FIVE. YOU AND IF
YOUR POST PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. AND THERE'S NO ONE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR MISTER BRYANT. THEY
I WANT TO THANK GOD FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL I DO HAVE A QUICK
QUESTION THIS IS THAT A
DEFENDANT'S REQUEST TO INCLUDE
THE LESSER RELATED IS THAT
CORRECT. YEAH I APPRECIATE THAT
BECAUSE MY INITIAL CONCERN. WITH
THE LESS IS THAT IT GOES FROM AN
ALL OR NONE SITUATION TO JUSTIN
ALWAYS CONVICTION. RIGHT BUT IF
IT IS AT THE DEFENDANT'S REQUEST
IN THAT. CHECK ON OVER CHARGING
WHERE YOU. DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
TO PROVE THE CASE YOU MAY NOT
YOU COULD STILL CHOOSE NOT TO
CALL FOR THE LESSER IS IF YOU
HAVE AN OVERZEALOUS PROSECUTOR
WHO'S COMPLETELY- OVERSHOT THE
MARK- THIS IS A THOUGHTFUL BILL.
IT'S A GREAT BALANCE BILL I'M
REALLY PROUD OF- YES ON IT.
THANK YOU IT WILL. I'M OF THE
BILL THAT IN THE EVENT. YOU MAY
CLOSE HELLO THANK- MY COLLEAGUES
LOS ANGELES VERY STRONG SUPPORT
AND ALSO- MARGOT FOR SERVING IN
TODAY THANK YOU FOR- SUPPORT I
THINK THIS BILL SUPPORT BECAUSE
IT IT RESTORES A PRACTICE THAT
THAT FACTOR IN THE NUANCES THAT
ARE CASE BY HAVING LESS RELATED
OFFENSES CONSIDERED AND REQUEST
PRESS ABOUT THE DEFENDANT WE CAN
HAVE A BETTER- JUDICIAL PROCESS
ACTION OF BETTER UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT THE RIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
IS FOR THE RIGHT KIND OF OFFENSE
SERVICE WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU I
THANK YOU BRINGING THIS. I YOU
FOR EVERYONE COMMENTING EVEN IN
THE WITNESSES OPERA. I HEARD A
ROSE BIRD COMPARISON SINCE I
WISH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEASE H. A
TO LONGER. AND SO. AND PROBABLY
THE TREES IN A THINGS THAT WE
RIGHT NOW SO JURORS RECOMMEND
AND I. YES CALDERON. I'M AB
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY FIVE FIVE BY
THE MEMBER LEAD THE MOTION IS TO
PASS JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER
HI LACKEY LACKEY NO BONTA. BONTA
HI BRIAN BRIAN I WORK. THANK YOU
. SANTIAGO I SEYARTO THE TEN NO
. MEASURES ARE CALLED NEEDS ONE
MORE THANK YOU. AND NOW WE HAVE
MISTER FLORA I BELIEVE. AND THAT
IS- AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES. THE
FOURTEENTH. THE AMENDMENT ARE
USED. NUMBER ONE THREE CRAFTING. ARE YOU SURE OKAY ALL RIGHT.
EVERY YEAR READY MR FLOOR. ARE
YOU TRYING TO INFLUENCE THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER RIGHT NOW SURE.
AT THE- REQUEST THANK YOU CHAIR
I WAS CALLING THAT BRIEF THERE
AND I JUST WANNA START WAS
THINKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF-
THIS BILL HAD A LITTLE WORK AND
ANDREW- THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THIS BILL BY STAFF ON THIS IT
MEANS THE WORLD TO US TO. REJECT
THAT VERY VERY MUCH SO THANK YOU
TO THE CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF. I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY SIX WHICH WILL PROVIDERELIEF TO FAMILIES WHO ARE
FACING THE DEVASTATING LOSS OF A
LOVED ONE PROFESSIONAL POISONING
. THE STATE DOES OF INDIVIDUALS
WERE POISONED BY FENTANYL
ARISING IN MANY OF THESE DEATHS
COULD HAVE BEEN PREVENTED AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX WILL
CREATED BUT NO VICTIMS.
COMPENSATION FUND WHERE LOVED
ONES OF THE FENNEL POISONING
VICTIM CAN APPLY. FOR
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR FUNERAL
BURIAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND EXPENSES. LOVED
ONES OF THESE VICTIMS. AS OUR
LOVED ONES. OF THESE CRIMES
DESERVE TO BE RECOGNIZED AND
SUPPORTED DURING THEIR TIME OF A
LOSS. AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX
WILL ENSURE THESE FAMILIES WILL
RECEIVE THE SUPPORT THAT THEY
NEED. FOR THE LEGISLATURE
CONTINUES TO WORK ON BY A
SOLUTION TO THIS- AGREE JUST
PROBLEM. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. AND DO
YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES. OKAY ANY
ANY WITNESSES SUPPORT ENTERING
THE ROOM. OKAY GOOD OUT HERE
FROM. ON THE TELEPHONE LINE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THE REPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO. OR AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. AND AT THIS TIE
THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. THEY WILL
ASK FOR ANY WITNESSES IN A ROOM
IN OPPOSITION. I SEE PEOPLE
GETTING UP AND ARE NOT THEY'RE
COMING. TO THE TABLE. IT'S JUST
IT'S GONNA USED A TWEENER MIKE
I'M A TWEENER YES MARCO GEORGE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION- WE
WROTE A LETTER IN OPPOSITION I'M
I'M A LITTLE UNCLEAR WITH THE
AMENDMENTS ON THE WHETHER OR NOT
THIS IMPOSES IT APPEARS TO
OPPOSE A WITH EVEN WITH THE
AMENDMENT- A TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR FINE UP TO A TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE. ONE
VIOLATIONS OF THE SECTION ELEVEN
THREE FIFTY WHICH ARE A IS A
MISDEMEANOR AT THIS POINT AND
I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT AND ALSO JUST THE FINES- IN
GENERAL- JUST IMPOVERISHED
PEOPLE AND MAKE IT UNABLE FOR
THEM TO REGAIN THEIR OWN
LIVELIHOODS AND TAP FIND STABLE
HOUSING. AND GET ON WITH THEIR
LIVES AND REINTEGRATE INTO
SOCIETY SO- I WE NEED TO A
LITTLE MORE AT THIS AND IF IN
FACT THIS IS THE AMENDMENT.
AMENDED VERSION WE WOULD ASK
THAT THIS BE- AMENDED FURTHER
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN THE MORNING
GOING BACK AS FOR THE ELEVATOR
CENTER FRIEDMAN RIGHT TO OPPOSE
THE BILL AND PRINT HAVEN'T SEEN
THE AMENDMENTS WILL CONSIDER THE
AMENDMENTS BUT ADDING FINE TO
TRY AND FIND ANYTHING GOOD IS
NOT AN APPROPRIATE WAY TO FIND
SOMETHING IS IMPORTANT TO HELP
FAMILIES WHO'VE LOST A LOVED ONE
WITH YOU TRY EXTRACTING MONEY
FROM HE POOREST PEOPLE IN THE
STATE YOU HAVE AN UNSTABLE
FUNDING SOURCE. NOT TO MENTION
I'M JUST FUNDING SOURCE BECAUSE
IT'LL FALL ON THE POOREST. ONE
STATE. THANK YOU. IT IT IT IT IT
IT IT IT HI A SAID CAL ACCESS-
LIGHT OF THE WILL BE REVIEWING A
PER THANK YOU FOR THE COMMITTEE
WORK ON THE- THANK YOU. POLICE
IN LEWIS ON BEHALF DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE AND WE NEED TO ITS
MATTER OPPOSITION LETTER BUT WE
ARE REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO HAVING
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS ON THE
ISSUE. THANK YOU. RIGHT ANY
OTHER WITNESSES ON THE PHONE
LINE IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE IN
A POSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND AT THIS TIME NO ONE
ASKED YOU TO. WE'LL BRING BACK
TO COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
MISTER BRIAN. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS IS NOT
NEW FINDS THIS IS YOUR MARKING
IN EXISTING FINE THE CORRECT
VERSION OF THE- EXISTING FINES
WILL BE MOVED INTO THE
CONVERSATION FOR BACK CAN'T
PROMISE YOU THAT MYSELF OR
OTHERS WILL LOOK AT WHETHER THAT
FIND BELONGS ON THE BOOKS BUT I
THINK THE- THE IDEA THAT THIS IS
NOT A NEW FIVE BUT INSTEAD
EARMARKING EXISTING FINE TO DEAL
WITH- AN ISSUE. THAT IS.
PREVALENT IN OUR COMMUNITIES IS
IT SOMETHING THAT I CAN SUPPORT
TODAY- MY LITTLE BROTHER.
SUFFERS FROM SUBSTANCE ABUSE
OVERDOSE TWO THANKSGIVINGS AGO.
ALAN SOMETHING LACED WITH
FENTANYL- IT'S A CONVERSATION
THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE WHAT WE
HAVE TO HAVE IT INTO. A PUBLIC
HEALTH CENTERED APPROACH AND NOT
A CRIMINAL LEGAL APPROACH BUT
GIVEN AGAIN THAT YOU'RE NOT
ADDING ANY NEW FINES OR
PENALTIES JUST YOU'RE MARKING
EXISTING FINES. IT'S SOMETHING
THAT I CAN SUPPORT OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND I TRUST THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO WORK THIS ALL THE
WAY THROUGH. IN ERA. ONE
REQUIREMENT I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU. FOR THE BILL AND ALSO-
MAKING THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN
AN OVERDOSE AND POISONING. AND
WHEN YOU TAKE ONE PILL THAT'S
ANOTHER OVERDOSE THAT'S
POISONING- BECAUSE YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S IN THERE AND THE
PERSON THAT PUT IT IN THERE
DOES. AND THEY KNOW WHAT IT'S
CAPABLE OF DOING SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE YOU MAY
CLOSE. AS WELL SAY THANK YOU
AGAIN TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
WE WORK FOR SOME OF THOSE FINES.
OKAY TO CARE OF THAT SO THANK
YOU ANDREW FOR BEING WILL BE
PROACTIVE THAT. END- AND TO AYE-
TO CHIEF THAT'S YOUR POINT WHEN
WE FIRST INTRODUCED THIS BILL-
ONE OF THE LADIES THAT I KNOW
VERY WELL- IN MY HOMETOWN. LOS A
SON. AND ORIGINALLY WAS CALLED
IT AN OVERDOSE. AND SHE CALLED
ME SO YOU JUST WANNA GIVE YOU
HEADS UP FOR THE VICTIMS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. WE CONSIDER THIS
A POISONING AND I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WAS VERY VERY
INTERESTING IT WASN'T SOMETHING
THAT I PICKED UP ON SOMETHING WE
LEARNED THROUGH THE PROCESS SO I
JUST THINK THE CHAIR. YOUR STAFF
FOR THIS BILL AND WHERE IT'S OUT
TODAY AND I RESPECT WEST RIVAL.
YES ACT AND I HOPE WITH THE
AMENDMENT AND WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO. PROVIDE CLARITY
AS IF MISTER BRYANT POINTED OUT
THAT WE'RE NOT ESTABLISHING ANY.
THING NEW- IF WE NEED TO ADD
ADDITIONAL BOARDING AND CLARITY.
ADDITIONALLY WORK WITH OUR STAFF
AND THEN AS IT MOVES FORWARD. TO
MAKE SURE WE GET THAT IN HERE
BECAUSE- AGAIN TODAY WE DON'T
WANT TO BURDEN. ON PEOPLE
ALREADY POOR AND DISADVANTAGED
WITH IT IT DOES. OR FIND AND
PENALTIES. AND AGAIN SINCE
PROBABLY DIS THESE ARE MEMBERS
CAME FROM US WE REALLY DO WANT
TO MAKE SURE. WE GET IT RIGHT SO
NOW WHAT THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS. JURORS RECOMMEND
I. THEIR MOTION. SO SAID SECOND
. AN EIGHTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
SIX BY SEVEN MEMBER FLOOR THE
MOTION IS IT DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER I LACKEY LACKEY HI BONTA
BONTA HI BRIAN BRIAN HI CORK
SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO I SEYARTO
THEY ARE TOO HIGH. THE MEASURE
PASSES YOU. RIGHT LEAVE. MISS
MIRANDA'S NEXT. AB. NINETEEN
FIFTY FIVE. AND CRIMES
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES I REMEMBER. HI WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THIS
I KNOW IT'S THERE MAY A
COMFORTABLE FOR REASON- GET MORE
AND THANK YOU MISTER. OF A
COMMITTEE TODAY I PRESENT MY
BILL AB NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE
DIRECT RESPONSE TO THE FEDERAL
CRISIS THAT IS GOING TO LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS OF ALL AGES AND
WALKS OF LIFE AND IMPACT OUR
NATIONAL HEALTH AND WELL BEING.
BEFORE THE COVER NINETEEN
CONDEMNING IMPOSED LOCKDOWNS
FENNO USE OR CONSUMPTION AMONG
CALIFORNIANS WAS ALREADY
APPROACHING ALARMING RATES.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR DID FOR DRUG ABUSE THE
CYSTIC. VANNO WAS RESPONSIBLE
OVER FORTY TWO THOUSAND OVERDOSE
DEATHS. IN THE NECK IN THE
TWELVE MONTHS LEADING UP TO
MARCH I'M MAY TWENTY TWENTY.
SINCE THEN NATION WHY DEBTS FOR
FENNO SKYROCK. SKYROCKETED WHAT
COUNTS RANGING FROM TEN TO
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS DATAS FROM
THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
AND PREVENTION. HAS SADLY SHOWN
THAT SINCE TWENTY TWENTY FENNEL
HAS BEEN THE LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH IN ADULTS EIGHTEEN TO
FORTY FIVE YEARS OLD. THE
LONELINESS AND ISOLATION OF THE
PANDEMIC CREATED A PERFECT STORM
FOR ADDICTIONS AND NEW USERS TO
GET ACCESS TO READILY AVAILABLE
COUNTERFEIT PHARMACEUTICALS. AND
OTHER FEDERAL LACED DRUGS. THE
RISING DOES OFFEND OF THESE MANY
PEOPLE IF OF THE VICTIMS ASKING
SHOULD BE HELD RESPONSIBLE. HOW
SHOULD WE KNOW THAT WE AS A
SOCIETY SOCIETY WOULD NOT
TOLERATE ONE MORE PERSON BEEN
SOLD A CONSUMING FENNEL AND
DYING IN THE STATE. HOW DO WE
SEND THE MESSAGE THAT AS PARENTS
AS FRIENDS AS NEIGHBORS AS
LEADERS THEY WERE NO LONGER
STAND BY. AS THIS CRISIS PROCESS
. AB ONE FIVE FIVE WILL LINE THE
PUNISHMENT THE FOR THE
POSSESSION OF FENTANYL WITH
INTENT TO SELL WITH THE SAME
PUNISHMENT FOR COCAINE AND
HEROIN POSSESSION WITH INTENT TO
SELL. EARLY IF SOMEONE IS IN
POSSESSION ONE KILOGRAM OF
COCAINE OR HEROIN THE MINIMUM
THEY CAN RECEIVE HIS ADDITIONAL
THREE YEAR TERM ON THEIR PRISON
SENTENCES. IF SOMEONE IS FOUND
IN POSSESSION OF EIGHTY
KILOGRAMS OR MORE WITH INTENT TO
SELL THEY CAN RECEIVE AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
THIS BILL DOES NOT TARGET
VICTIMS IT WOULD NOT TARGET
VICTIMS WHO SHOULD SEEK
EMERGENCY MEDICAL TREATMENT IF
THEY ARE SUSPECTED IT AND
EXPERIENCING FEDERAL RELATED
OVERDOSE. THIS BILL IS INTENDED
TO GO DIRECTLY AFTER JUST THE
DEALERS. WHO ARE IN POSSESSION
OF FEDERAL. WITH THE INTENT TO
SELL WITHOUT FEAR OF
CONSEQUENCES WE ARE FACING A
DANGEROUS SITUATION THERE WILL
CONTINUE TO SPIRAL OUT OF
CONTROL AND HE WOULD TAKE A
SERIOUS STAND AGAINST FEDERAL IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR STATE.
WE'RE HERE. WHAT HERE- TODAY- BY
PHONE- TO TESTIFY IS CAPTAIN
BURKE. BART STARR DARNELL OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. CAPTAIN BY NOW THE
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR COULD YOU
LET THE ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IN. GET MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CAN YOU HEAR ME
ALRIGHT YES WE CAN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME TODAY
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
ON THE INSUPPORTABLE AB NINETEEN
FIFTY FIVE YEAH THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. THE DRUG EPIDEMIC
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT LONG TERM
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY CRISIS
OF OUR TIME. FOR THE FIRST TIME
THE TWELVE MONTH PERIOD
NATIONWIDE DRUG RELATED DEATHS
EXCEEDED ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND.
BETWEEN APRIL TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY IT WILL BE ABOUT TWENTY
ONE A TOTAL OF ONE HUNDRED.
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED SIX
AMERICANS LOST THEIR LIVES TO A
DRUG RELATED DEATHS. THE LARGEST
COMPONENT OF THAT NUMBER IS
SYNTHETIC OPIOIDS LIKE FENTANYL
. JUST TO PUT THAT NUMBER
PERSPECTIVE THIS IS EQUAL TO TEN
THE BOEING SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
AIRLINE JETS CRASHING EACH WEEK
FOR AN ENTIRE YEAR STRAIGHT. IF
THAT NEARLY CRASHES OCCURRED WE
WOULD DO SOMETHING IMMEDIATELY
TO FIX THE PROBLEM. AB NINETEEN
FIFTY FIVE IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY
TO PUT IN PLACE AN IMPORTANT
ASPECT OF THE SOLUTION TO THIS
CRISIS. THE BILL ADDRESSES THOSE
ARE TRAFFICKING ALL NOT THOSE
SUFFERING FROM ADDICTION. BY
PLACING FEDERAL PROBABLY IN THE
PENAL CODE THE BILL RECOGNIZES
THE POTENCY OF THIS DEADLY
SUBSTANCE. I WOULD ADVISE YOU
THAT THIS IS A DEADLY SUBSTANCE
THAT CLAIMS MORE MORE LIVES EACH
DAY. IN ORANGE COUNTY THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF FEDERAL DEATHS WAS
THIRTY SEVEN IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN. IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE OUR TOTAL FEDERAL DEBT WAS
SIX HUNDRED NINETY THREE. WITH
SIXTY TWO CASES STILL PENDING.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH STATEWIDE
BUT NO DEATHS INCREASED OVER
22100% IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
IN JUNE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN TO
JUNE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE
NUMBER OF FEDERAL RELATED DEATHS
WAS TWO HUNDRED ONE. FIVE YEARS
LATER THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
STATEWIDE DAMAGE THE. FORTY
SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY SIX. THANK
YOU TO HELP. THE BILL. IT IS
INCREASE IT ALONE WILL NOT SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM WE ALSO NEED TO
EDUCATION CIRCLE RIGHT TO SPEAK
THIS IS RIDICULOUS. IT THE BOOK
OF OUR EFFORTS IN ORANGE COUNTY
. WITH REGARD TO EDUCATION OR
ABOVE THE INFLUENCE DRUG
EDUCATION PROGRAM WAS UNVEILED
THIS YEAR FOR MIDDLE SCHOOLERS
IT CONTEMPORARY IMPACTFUL AND WE
BELIEVE IT'LL BECOME A MODEL FOR
OTHERS. TREATMENT HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANT ASPECT OF WHAT WE DO
AS WELL. R. O. R. ORANGE COUNTY
CARE PROGRAM OF INTEGRATED
SERVICES AND THAT ARE JAIL ARE
WORKING TO HELP ADDICTS MAINTAIN
SOBRIETY. BUT WHILE WE WORK TO
REDUCE THE BANTER EDUCATION
TREATMENT WE ALSO WE MUST ATTACK
THE SUPPLY. THIS IS THAT YOUR
MEANINGFUL CONSEQUENCE FOR DRUG
TRAFFICKERS. BUT NO AS FAR AS
OUR COMMUNITY. IN THE FIRST TWO
MONTHS INTO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO
THE ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF
MCCARTY KING SEES OVER TWO
HUNDRED FIVE POUNDS. FEDERAL AND. ONE HUNDRED FORTY THREE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN PILLS SUSPECTED TO CONTAIN
SOME LEVEL OF FOOTBALL. AS ONE
WITH OVER TWENTY TWO YEARS OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE EXPERIENCE I
KNOW THE LAW WITHOUT CONSEQUENCE
ONLY FOR THE BAD BEHAVIOR. AB
NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE PROVIDE THAT
CAUGHT BUT BY CORRECTED
DESPAIRED IN THE LAW THAT STREET
THE TRAFFIC IT BUT NO AS A
LESSER OFFENSE THE TRACKING
DRUGS LIKE COCAINE AND HEROIN.
THIS FALL THE LAW CREATE
INCENTIVE FOR TRAFFICKING ABOUT
MORE DEADLY SUBSTANCE. IT IS
BURNING CONSEQUENCE FOR HURLING
A CONSEQUENCE FOR IT BUT NO
MAKES THIS CLEAR. TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE DEATHS INCREASED 27% OFF BUT
NO DEATHS INCREASED 41002% THE
LACK OF CONSEQUENCE ALONG WITH
THAT OF MANUFACTURING THIS
DROUGHT CLEARLY INCENTIVIZE THE
TRAFFICKING OF ITS MORE POTENT
SUBSTANCE. FORGET YOUR APARTMENT
AFTER YOU SUPPORT IS NEEDED
SOLUTION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU CAPTAIN
. AND NOW ANY OTHER IN SUPPORT
IN THE ROOM. SENAD WOULD NOW GO
TO THE PHONE PHONE LINES
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATORS SUPPORT OF
AB NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE I DON'T
NUMBER SEVEN SIX. THANK YOU AN
APPEARANCE SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
THE ONE THEN. ZERO AND AT THIS
TIME THERE IS NO ONE QUEUING UP
. THANK YOU IN ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THE MORNING CHAIR NUMBERS ONLY
SEE LEWIS ON BEHALF THE DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE HERE RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO NINETEEN FIFTY
FIVE AND DOING RECOGNIZED I
THINK THE AUTHOR STUFF FOR
TALKING WITH ME ON SHORT NOTICE-
BUT DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IS A
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION THAT IS
ADVOCATING FOR DRUG POLICY IS
GROUNDED IN SCIENCE COMPASSION
HEALTH AND HUMAN RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION UNDERSTANDS THE
IMPACT THAT DRUG USE IS HAVING
ON THE LIVES OF USERS. THEIR
FAMILIES AND THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
WHO'VE LOST A LOVED ONE TO
OVERDOSE SINCE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THE NUMBER OF FATAL DRUG
OVERDOSES HAS RISEN HUNDRED AND
10% IN CALIFORNIA IN TWENTY
TWENTY AT LEAST NINE THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS HAVE DIED FROM DRUG
RELATED OVERDOSES WE KNOW THIS
IMPACT ISRAEL AND IT'S IMPACTING
COMMUNITIES ACROSS OUR STATE.
AND THAT IS WHY DPA STANDS FIRM
AND URGING THE STATE TO
PRIORITIZE INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE APPROACH WITH
LIFESAVING HARM REDUCTION
SERVICES THAT ARE PROVEN TO SAVE
LIVES BY DIRECTLY REACHING
PEOPLE AT HIGHEST RISK FOR
OVERDOSE AND EVIDENCE BASED LOW
BARRIER TREATMENT AND ACCESS FOR
PEOPLE WHO USE DRUGS.
SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE
DEMONSTRATES THAT CRIMINAL
PENALTIES SUCH AS THOSE IN THIS
BILL WILL NOT REDUCE THE ABILITY
AVAILABILITY THE OR THE USE OF
THE FENNEL NOR PREVENT OVERDOSES
. INCREASING FOR FENTANYL
RELATED SUBSTANCES ECHOES THE
FAILED WAR ON DRUGS POLICIES
THAT WERE ENACTED THROUGH THE
EIGHTIES AND NINETIES. THAT WERE
AROUND CRACK COCAINE THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
PEOPLE OF COLOR CROWDED PRISONS
AND COST LIVES. THE US
SENTENCING COMMISSION IN TWENTY
NINETEEN FOUND THAT NEARLY 70%
OF THOSE THAT WERE SENTENCE OR
FENTANYL ANALOGUES WERE BLACK OR
LATINO. THE PRIMARY RISK OF
OVERDOSE OF FENTANYL RESULTS
FROM ITS UNKNOWING INGESTION THE
PROCESS OF ADDING FINAL TO
HEROIN IS USUALLY DONE EARLY IN
THE PRODUCTON PROCESS AND
ACCORDING TO THE DRUG
ENFORCEMENT ADMINISTRATION. BUT
NO IS GENERALLY ADDED TO HEROIN
BEFORE ENTERS THE U. S.
THEREFORE LOW LEVEL SELLERS MAY
NOT KNOW THEY ARE DISTRIBUTING.
THIS BILL WOULD NOT REDUCE THE
INCLUSION OF FENTANYL IN THE
DRUG SUPPLY AS IT TAKES PLACE
HIGHER UP IN THE DISTRIBUTION
CHAIN. WE ARE ALSO CONCERNED
THAT THIS BILL WOULD DISCOURAGE
EFFECTIVE USES OF DEALING WITH
THE OPIOID HEALTH CRISIS.
UNDERMINING CURRENT EFFORTS BY
DRIVING PEOPLE WHO USE DRUGS
AWAY FROM HEALTH SERVICES AND
ENCOURAGING RISKIER DRUG TAKING
ACTIVITY IN ORDER TO AVOID
DETECTION AND PROSECUTION. WELL
YOU WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
INTENT IS NOT TO DISCOURAGE
VICTIMS WE ARE CONCERNED THAT IT
WOULD IMPACT CALIFORNIANS GOOD
SAMARITAN LAW WHICH ENCOURAGES
PEOPLE TO CONTACT EMERGENCY
SERVICES. IN CASE OF AN
OVERDOSE. THE THREAT OF POLICE
INVOLVEMENT IN SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENTS MAY MAKE AN
INDIVIDUAL HESITANT TO CALL-
ANYTIME THAT SOMEONE IS IN AN
EMERGENCY SITUATION OR RUN FROM
THE SCENE RATHER THAN HELP
AFFECT THEM. HELLO VOTERS HAVE
VOTED HAVE SIGNALED AGAIN AND
AGAIN THAT THEIR PREFERENCE FOR
USING A HEALTH APPROACH TO DRUG
OFFENSES AND THEIR DESIRE TO
UNWIND THE FAILED WAR ON DRUGS.
REVERSING COURSE AT THIS TIME
AND GOING BACK TO OVER
CRIMINALIZATION WILL NOT IN. A
DRESSER INC- MARGINALIZATION OR
ADDRESS THE STIGMA THAT OCCURS.
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THIS IS A
HEALTH CRISIS AND WE URGE HERE
NO VOTE. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU. IS THERE ANYBODY IN THE
ROOM LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION. EARNING GOING BACK
AS FOR THE ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS A POST. THANK YOU.
MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION A POST THANK. FRED
WILLIAMS AND WE HAVE ACLU CAL
ACTION IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
AT&T WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE
LINES ANYBODY ON. HOLD IT WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION
TO THIS. THIS BILL AB. NINETEEN
FIFTY FIVE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
POST PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO.
NO OPERATORS YOU HAVE WON WITH
AN OPERATOR. WE HAVE WON WITH AN
OPERATOR ONE MOMENT WE DO HAVE
ONE OKAY WE DO HAVE ONE NOW. AND
THAT'S LINE SIXTY SIX. R. ONE
MOMENT. NINE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
GREGORY FELL ON THE HAPPEN IS
JUST ANDERSON OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THERE'S NO EITHER THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANYBODY THAT WOULD
LIKE TO- TALK TO THE AUTHOR.
MACHAR YOU MAY THANK YOU SO I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING- THIS THIS BILL
FORWARD- TRYING TO ADDRESS- ONE
OF THE ISSUES THAT IS ESCALATING
OUT OF CONTROL. IN CALIFORNIA
AND EVERYWHERE ELSE- YOU KNOW
ONE I THINK ONE OF THE RECURRING
THEMES IS THAT- WILL. THAT THE-
THANK CARCERI XIN ISN'T WORKING
TO SLOW DOWN THE EPIDEMIC. IN
ITS NOT IN AND SOMETIMES
INCARCERATION ISN'T NECESSARILY
ABOUT- AT BEING ABLE TO STOP
THAT BECAUSE FOR EVERY- DRUG
DEALER THAT WE GET OFF THE
STREET SOMEBODY ELSE TAKES THEIR
PLACE- BUT IT'S MORE OF. THAT
THAT RIGHT THERE IT DOES COME A
TIME BECAUSE- WHAT I'VE FAILED
TO HERE IS WHAT DO WE DO WHEN WE
HAVE A DEALER THAT IS. KILLING
PHILIP LITERALLY KILLING. A
BUNCH OF PEOPLE- THEY KNOW WHAT
. FOR PEOPLE TO SAY THAT THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE THEY'RE
GETTING OUT ANYBODY THAT'S DOING
ANY DRUG OR SELLING ANY DRUGS.
NOWADAYS IT DOESN'T UNDERSTAND
THAT WHAT THEY'RE GIVING THEIR
FRIEND- WHAT THEY'RE GIVING-
WHAT THEY'RE SELLING OUT THERE-
ISN'T LACED- AB PSYCH 90% OF ITS
LACED. AND THEY'LL KNOW IT- THE
IDEA IS TO GET PEOPLE HOOKED.
QUICKER ON AN OPIOID SO THAT
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO BUY. AND
THAT'S CALLED CREATING YOUR OWN
MARKET AND YOU KNOW THERE IS A
PUNISHMENT PART OF THAT- TO OUR
INCARCERATION SYSTEM AND THERE
ARE PEOPLE THAT DESERVED IT THAT
THAT THAT WIND UP GETTING
REHABILITATED AND THEN THERE'S
ALSO PEOPLE THAT GET PUNISHED.
AND AND I THINK WHAT YOUR WHAT
YOUR BILL IS TRYING TO DO. IS
JUST TREAT. THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
NOW INVOLVED IN A NEWER DRUG
FENTANYL THE SAME AS THE OTHER
DRUGS THAT ARE- WE HAVE
NOTORIOUSLYBUT NOT. AS MUCH-
CONTRIBUTED TO THE DEATHS OF SO
MANY PEOPLE. WITH SO LITTLE
RECOGNITION THAT WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IS GOING TO KILL THEM ONE
PILL KILLS. AND IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHERE YOU ARE IF YOU IF
YOU OVERDOSE ON FENTANYL YOU'VE
GOT FORTY FIVE MINUTES. FOR
SOMEBODY THAT KNOWS WHAT THEY'RE
DOING TO COME HELP YOU OTHERWISE
YOU ARE DEAD. AND A LOT OF THOSE
DEAD OR KIDS. AND SO WE NEED TO
SEND THAT MESSAGE AND ONE OF
THOSE MESSAGES IS WE WON'T
TOLERATE. DRUG DEALERS WHO BY
THE WAY MAKE MORE MONEY THAN WE
DO. THEY HAVE BETTER HOUSES AND
WE DO AND HAVE BETTER CARS AND
WE DO. AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO
ENTICE THEM WITH A JOB AT
MCDONALD'S. TO GET OUT GET OUT
OF WHAT THEY'RE DOING- WE NEED
TO SEPARATE THEM FROM OUR KIDS
AND ALL THOSE OTHER PEOPLE THAT
ARE BEING KILLED WITH FENNEL. SO
I APPRECIATE YOU TACKLING THIS I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
OPPOSITION TO- BEING ABLE TO DO
SOMETHING WITH THE PEOPLE THERE
ACTUALLY. OUT THERE DOING THE
DAMAGE- BUT DEATH WE GOT TO KEEP
TRYING SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NAY OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. IS ONE A HIGHLIGHT-
AS PART OF THE ANALYSIS THAT WAS
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL FOR ME- I AND
I KNOW THAT WE HAVE AN EPIDEMIC
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED WE
HAVE A COMMITTEE MEMBER WHO
TALKED ABOUT BEING DIRECTLY
IMPACTED. BY THE EXISTENCE OF
FENTON ALL AND WE IN OUR
COMMUNITY ALL HAVE THAT-
INCREDIBLY MOVED BY DATA. AND
RESEARCH THAT SHOWS THAT TO DATE
GENERALLY INDICATES THAT
INCREASES IN THE CERTAINTY OF
PUNISHMENT AS OPPOSED TO THE
SEVERITY OF PUNISHMENT ARE MORE
LIKELY TO PRODUCE DETERRENT
BENEFITS SO AS WE ARE SEEKING
WAYS TO BE ABLE TO PREVENT. AT
THE EXISTENCE OF FENDER VENTS ON
THE USE OF FRENCH IN ALL. IT'S
PRETTY CLEAR THAT ENHANCEMENTS
ARE NOT GOING TO BE THE PATHWAY
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT. AND FOR
THAT REASON I WILL BE VOTING ON
THIS BILL. BURKE THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT APPROACH TO THE
DRUGS HAS OBVIOUSLY FAILED I
PREFERRED THE APPROACH IN
PORTUGAL WHERE DRUG USE IS
DECRIMINALIZED THAT WOULD LEAD
YOU TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THINGS
LIKE SAFE DRUG USE SPACES WHERE
YOU COULD TEST FOR FAT KNOWLEDGE
ETCETERA. THAT'S NOT GONNA
HAPPEN AS LONG AS WE MAKE DRUG
POSSESSION ILLEGAL THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS. JUST WHEN
YOU A CLOSE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- LET ME JUST BE
CLEAR ONCE AGAIN AB ONE NINE
FIVE FIVE IS NOT GIVING
ENHANCEMENT TO THOSE WHO
PROCESSES. BUT NOW IT'S FOR THE
THOSE WHO PROCESS THAT NOW WITH
THE INTENT TO SELL. WE'RE GOING
AFTER THE DEALERS NOT THE
VICTIMS I KNOW THAT A LOT OF
COMMENTS HERE HAS BEEN MADE
STATING THAT YOU KNOW- WE NEED
COMPASSION ABSOLUTELY. THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHO AND WHO AND
SEVEN POSSESSION OF THESE AND
BUYS THEM DOES NOT KNOW ONE PILL
WHAT WILL KILL. IT ONLY TAKES
ONE PILL FENTANYL TO KILL WITHIN
MINUTES. SO THIS IS NOTHING TO
DO WITH THE VICTIMS THOSE WHO
PROCESS THAT NO THIS IS ALL
ABOUT THE DRUG DEALERS WERE
MAKING FAT NO. ADDING THAT INTO
THE SAME CATEGORY AS HEROIN AND
COCAINE. BETWEEN THE YEARS TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN TO TWO THOUSAND
AND TWENTY STATE WIFE FENTANYL
RELATED DEATHS INCREASED OVER
16100% FROM TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
NINE DEATHS 230-008-0050. SEVEN.
ABSOLUTELY I AGREE WITH SOME OF
THE COMMENTS MADE WE NEED MORE
PUBLIC HEALTH WE NEED MORE
AWARENESS WE MEET WE NEED MORE
CAMPAIGNING TO TELL THESE
INDIVIDUAL EXPRESSION DOES THE
AGES OF EIGHTEEN TO FORTY FIVE.
THE DANGER OF THESE FAT NOW THE
DANGER OF TAKING THESE THIS ONE
PILL. ONE PILL. WHAT WILL HAPPEN
TO THEM. I ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH
THAT THIS IS NOT THIS IS NOT
GOING TO FIT THE FULL DEPEND
THAT MAKE EPIDEMIC PROBLEM OF
THIS CRISIS. WE NEED TO START
SOMEWHERE AND THAT IS IN MY
OPINION AND I'M THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY ACROSS THE
STATE. WHO'VE BEEN DOORS AND
SUPPORT THIS BILL. WE NEED TO GO
AFTER THE DEALERS GET THEM OFF
THE STREETS THE LAST THEY'RE
AVAILABLE TO SELL THESE DRUGS
FENNEL. THE BETTER IS EAT LESS
ACCESS FOR OUR CHILDREN OR YOUNG
ADULTS TO GET HAND. TO GET A
HAND ON ONE PILL. AGAIN THE BILL
. IS HOLDING THE DRUG DEALERS
ACCOUNTABLE. AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE STAND BY THE FAMILIES
AND THE VICTIMS. WHO DOES NOT
KNOW THE ONE PILL WILL KILL. I
ASK YOU TO JOIN ME TODAY AND
HELP ME TAKE A STAND AND MAKE
THE THEY PUT THESE DRUG DEALERS
. WHERE THEY BELONG THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND I'M OF THE BILL. A
SECOND. THANK GUESTS WILL CALL
FOR THE QUESTION PLACE. AB
NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE BANKS A
MEMBER WHEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER. LACKEY
LACKEY HI BONTA. BONTA KNOW
BRIAN BRIAN NO QUIRK QUIRK KNOWS
SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO KNOWS THEY
ARE TO YES THEY ARE TO I THAT
MISSION. THE CLOSURE FAILS.
EXPIRATION YEAH. BOB GIPSON. BUT
I AM NOT A MISSED YOUR GROUND
THANK YOU. FIVE WELL. SHE IT'S
NOT SURE WHAT THAT IS. OKAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO. AB.
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY FOUR. GOOD
MORNING. MR TURN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO TWO SEVEN FOUR IN FRONT
OF THE COMMITTEE TEAR HERE TODAY
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
STAKEHOLDERS FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS MEASURE IN BY COMMITTING TO
TAKING A PROPOSED AMENDMENT
WHICH WOULD LIMIT THE FOR YOUR
STATUE OF LIMITATIONS TO ONLY
CASES OF SEVERE NEGLECT. MEMBERS
UNDER CURRENT LAW. MANDATED
REPORTERS ARE REQUIRED TO REPORT
KNOWN OR SUSPECTED CHILD. ABUSE
AND NEGLECT SO THAT
INVESTIGATION CAN TAKE PLACE.
HOWEVER IF A MANDATED REPORTER
FAILS TO PROTECT A CHILD BY
FAILING TO REPORT. AND WHEN YOUR
PASSES THE LAW IS NO LONGER
ENFORCEABLE. THE PROBLEM WITH
THIS IS- WITH THIS APPROACH IS
THAT SEVERAL CASES HAVE OCCURRED
WHERE A CHILD HAS BEEN THE
VICTIM OF PHYSICAL ABUSE OR
NEGLECT. AND A MANDATED REPORTER
WAS MADE AWARE OF THIS AND DID
NOT REPORT THIS ABUSE TO
AUTHORITIES. THIS LAPSE IN TIME
AND SOMETIMES MONTHS OR YEARS
CREATES A VERY DIFFICULT
PROSECUTION OF THE PERPETRATORS.
DUE TO LOST EVIDENCE AND EXPOSES
THE VULNERABLE CHILD TO AN
EGREGIOUS SITUATION OF A
BECOMING AN ONGOING VICTIM. OF
PREVENTABLE IN THE MEAT.
REITERATE THAT OF PREVENTABLE
PHYSICAL ABUSE AND NEGLECT. AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY FOUR DOES NOT
INCREASE THE PENALTY OF THE
FAILURE TO REPORT. CRIME THE
BILL MERELY EXTENDS THE STATUTE
OF LIMITATIONS TO ENSURE
MANDATED REPORTERS TAKE THIS
LEGAL RESPONSIBILITIES
SERIOUSLY. MANDATED REPORTERS
ARE AWARE OF THEIR OBLIGATIONS
BY BECAUSE THERE IS LITTLE TO NO
ENFORCEMENT MANY ORGANIZATIONS
DEVELOP A SENSE. THAT THERE ARE
NO CONSEQUENCES OR THEIR
EXISTING CULTURE WHERE IN THE
MANDATED REPORTING RULES CAN BE
BENT OR ALTERED BY THE SPECIFIC
ORGANIZATION. BY EXTENDING THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR THE
FAILURE OF A MANDATED REPORTER
TO REPORT SUSPECTED CHILD ABUSE
OR NEGLECT. TO WITHIN A ONE YEAR
OF DISCOVERY OF THE OFFENSE BUT
IN NO CASE LAW- I'M SORRY BUT IN
NO CASE LATER THAN FOUR YEARS
AFTER THE COMMISSION OF THE
OFFENSE. CALIFORNIA LAW WILL BE
STRENGTHENED TO BETTER PROTECT
VULNERABLE CHILDREN. TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT IS STEVEN MARK. ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE- AND- HE'S ON
THE PHONE THANK YOU. OKAY MISTER
MARK WHAT. I WOULD LIKE MORNING
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR FROM ME AT
THIS POINT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE TIME
THIS MORNING AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO FOR
SPONSORING THIS BILL. MY NAME'S
STEPHEN MARQUARDT I'M A DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN THE COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGO AND MUCH OF MY
CAREER HAS FOCUSED ON GIVING A
VOICE TO VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS
OF ABUSE AND THAT INCLUDES AND
THAT. INDIVIDUALS HAVE SUFFERED
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND CHILDREN
WHO HAVE SUFFERED PHYSICAL ABUSE
AND CHILDREN WHO HAVE SUFFERED
SEXUAL ABUSE. CRIMES AGAINST
CHILDREN ARE NOT ISOLATED TO THE
HOME. SADLY CHILDREN ARE ABUSED
IN MANY DIFFERENT AREAS OUTSIDE
OF THE HOME. AND FOR THIS REASON
THE LAW IDENTIFIED NEARLY FIFTY
CLASSES OF INDIVIDUALS AS
MANDATED REPORTERS WHO ARE
REQUIRED TO CONTACT THE PROPER
INVESTIGATIVE AGENCIES WHEN THEY
KNOW OR REASONABLY SUSPECTED OF
ABUSE. THIS IS INTENDED TO
ENSURE THAT CHILDREN ARE SAFE
AND EVERYTHING. WHEN CHILDREN
ARE AT SCHOOL IN A SPORTS LEAGUE
AT A DOCTOR'S OFFICE IN AN AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM. THEY CAN RELY ON
THE ADULTS AROUND THEM TO PUT
THEIR INTERESTS AT THE
FOREFRONT. HOWEVER IN MY WORK I
HAVE FOUND MANY SITUATIONS WHERE
MANDATED REPORTERS FAILED TO
COMPLY WITH THEIR LEGAL
REPORTING OBLIGATIONS. THIS
FAILURE TO COMPLY WITH THE REAL
ALREADY LEGALLY. LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS. BUT THE CHILDREN
AT INCREASED RISK. IT BECAUSE OF
THE WE GOT THE CHILDREN TO
SUFFER CONTINUED HARM OF FAILURE
TO REPORT CAN ALSO EXPOSE
ADDITIONAL CHILDREN TO FUTURE
HEART. PINE ABUSER WHO COULD
HAVE BEEN AND SHOULD HAVE BEEN
INVESTIGATED. THE FAILURE TO
REPORT SHIELD THE ABUSER AND
CANNON BALLED IN THE ABUSER TO
COMMIT ADDITIONAL HARM BECAUSE
THERE IS NO CONSEQUENCE. AND THE
FAILURE TO REPORT ALSO
CONTRIBUTES TO A GENERAL
DISTRUST IN GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
AS THE FAILURE TO REPORT BY
MANDY TO REPORT RESULTS IN A
SYSTEM WIDE FAILURE TO INTERVENE
AND PROVIDE EIGHT. CHILDREN WHO
ARE OF ABUSE AND NEGLECT
REGULARLY EXPERIENCE SHAME GUILT
AND ISOLATION. BECAUSE CHILDREN
OFTEN DO NOT REPORT BEING ABUSED
IT IS CRITICAL THAT THE MANDATED
REPORTERS MAKE THE REPORT WHEN
THEY KNOW OR SUSPECT ABUSE. BY
THE TIME OF FAILURE TO REPORT IS
DISCOVERED OFTENTIMES EVIDENCE
OF THE ORIGINAL ABUSE IS
PERMANENTLY LOST OR ADDITIONAL
ABUSE OF THE SAME CHILD OR OTHER
CHILDREN WILL HAVE TAKEN PLACE.
THE FAILURE REPORT THEREFORE IS
NOT AN ISOLATED ACT BUT IT IS A
CONTINUING FAILURE WITH ON GOING
NEGATIVE REPERCUSSIONS FAR
BEYOND THE ORIGINAL. ABUSE GIVEN
THAT CHILDREN WHO SUFFER ABUSE
COMMONLY DELAYED DISCLOSURE OF
THE REVIEW. IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT THE MANDATE REPORTER REPORT
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE AS IS
ALREADY REQUIRED BY THE LAW.
VERY OFTEN HOWEVER IT IS MORE
THAN A YEAR BEFORE AN ABUSE
VICTIM COMES FORWARD. IN THOSE
SITUATIONS BY THE TIME A CHILD
COMES FORWARD TO REPORT ABUSE
AND OFTEN TIMES I'VE SEEN
CHILDREN COMING FORWARD SAYING
THAT THEY ALREADY LET SOMEBODY
KNOW EARLY ON. BUT NOTHING WAS
DONE IN THOSE SITUATIONS IF A
YEAR HAD PASSED THAT ORIGINAL
MANDATED REPORTER WHO WITH THE
WHERE OR SUSPECTED OF THE ABUSE.
CANNOT BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAS
ALREADY RECOGNIZED THAT CHILD
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ABUSE
REGULARLY DELAY REPORTING. AND
FOR THAT REASON IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE LEGISLATURE AMENDED
PENAL CODE SECTION EIGHT A ONE
POINT SIX TO EXTEND THE STATUTE
OF LIMITATIONS FOR THE FAILURE
BY A MAN WHO THE REPORTER. TO
REPORT SUSPECTED SEXUAL ABUSE TO
FIVE YEARS. HOWEVER THE STATUTE
LIMITATIONS REMAINED ONE YEAR
FOR INCIDENT OF KNOWN OR
SUSPECTED PHYSICAL ABUSE AND
SEVERE NEGLECT. BUT THE FAILURE
TO REPORT BY MANDY REPORTER WHEN
THEY KNOW OF OR SUSPECT SEXUAL
ABUSE. IS A IS A MISDEMEANOR
CRIME UNDER THE CURRENT LAW AND
THAT SCHEDULE IMITATION THAT
FIVE YEARS HOWEVER IF ANOTHER
CHILD SUFFERED PHYSICAL ABUSE OR
SEVERE NEGLECT IN A MANDATED
REPORTER FAILED TO REPORT IT.
THE STATURE LIMITATIONS IT'S
ONLY ONE YEAR THIS BILL AIMS TO
ADDRESS THIS DISPARITY AND
PROVIDE INCREASED PROTECTION TO
ALL CHILDREN WHO ARE BEING
ABUSED OR SEVERELY NEGLECTED.
THE BILL DOES NOT INCREASE
PENALTIES IT DOES NOT
CRIMINALIZE ANY ACT OR FAILURE
THAT IS NOT ALREADY CODIFIED IT
SIMPLY GIVES GREATER PROTECTION
TO CHILDREN RECOGNIZING HOW
CHILD PSYCHOLOGY OPERATE AND
RECOGNIZING THAT CURRENTLY.
THERE ARE MANY WAYS IN WHICH
THESE CRIMES GO UNDETECTED AND
IT AIMS TO ENSURE THAT THOSE WHO
ARE ALREADY MANDATED TO REPORT.
DO SO BY PRIORITIZING THE
CHILDREN THANK YOU. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES A ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM THE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL. K. A. T. AND T. WOULD LIKE
TO HEAR FROM ANYBODY WHO WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL. YOU CAN
EXPERIENCE A PART PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE A
LINE. SEVENTY STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU I AM ONE
WE HAVE WON WITH AN OPERATOR ONE
MOMENT PLEASE.
IN NAY AS COMING FROM LINE
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS TERRY MILLER
PRESIDENT OF STOP EDUCATOR
SEXUAL ABUSE MISCONDUCT AND
EXPLICATION OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
SESAME SESAME IS IN FULL SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY FOUR-
WE SEE A LOT OF THESE CASES- OF
DELAYED. OUR DISCLOSURES AND
MANY OF THOSE FOLKS ARE ADULTS
WHEN THEY ARE COMING TO DISCLOSE
AND THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
TO HOLD THOSE WHO HAVE ENABLED
THEIR ABUSE. IN PAST-
ACCOUNTABLE SO WE WOULD LIKE TO-
PROVIDE THAT AVENUE TO JUSTICE
TO THEM- THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
AND AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION MISTER
GEORGE. WE HAVE YOU DOWN AS A OF
AS A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU- AND THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR TAKING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS WOULD GREATLY
APPRECIATE THAT AND C. P. D. A.
AT THIS TIME IS GOING TO
WITHDRAW OUR OPPOSITION. VERY
GOOD IS OR ANYONE ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
BAKER KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS WILLINGNESS TO WORK
WITH US TO ENSURE THAT THE BILL
DOES NOT FURTHER- AT RESULT IN
OVER REPORTING AS FAMILIES FOR
POVERTY RELATED REASONS AND WE
ALSO WITHDRAW OUR OPPOSITION
BASED ON IN MOMENTS TAKEN. AT&T
TO HAVE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINE TO LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION. GEREN IF YOUR POST.
I'M TERRY PRE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND. ZERO AND AT THIS TIME
THERE'S A LEARNING QUEUE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OKAY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANYBODY WISH TO- ADDRESS
THE AUTHOR YES YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR TAKING THE
AMENDMENT SIGNED PLEASE NOW TO
BE ABLE TO VOTE ON THIS THANK
YOU. MOVE THE BILL. SECOND HEY
WE HAVE A MOTION THE SECOND.
YOU'RE FREE TO CLOSE THANK YOU I
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU WE OF FIRST
AND SECOND WITH PLEASE CALL FOR
QUESTIONS. ON AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RUBIO THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED JONES SAWYER. LACKEY
LACKEY I BONTA. BONTA HI BRIAN.
BRIAN I WORK AYE QUIRK AYE
SANTIAGO. SEYARTO THEY ARE TOO
HIGH. MEASURE PASSES GARAGE
RELATIONS THANK YOU. J. GOOD.
FEELS IGHT. SOMERVILLE OF WOOD
WALL ASSEMBLY BILL. TWENTY THREE
NINETY EIGHT. YES I'LL BE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN YOU MAKE CHAIR
MEMBERS AB TWO THIRDS TWENTY
THREE NINETY EIGHT WILL HELP
WORKING FAMILIES PREVENT
UNNECESSARY VEHICLE REPAIR COSTS
DUE TO CATALYTIC CONVERTER
THEFTS. KEVORK CONVERTER CRIME
IS A GROWING PROBLEM THAT
ESPECIALLY IMPACTS MOTORISTS WHO
CAN AT LEAST WHO CAN LEAST
AFFORD THE SNIFFING IT COSTS TO
REPLACE THE DEVICE. ACCORDING TO
THE NATIONAL INSURANCE CRIME
PAROLE IN ICB STUDY THERE WERE A
HUNDRED AND EIGHT REPORTED
CATALYTIC CONVERTER THEFTS PER
MONTH. ON AVERAGE ON AVERAGE IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO AVERAGE
MONTHLY THEFTS REPORTED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND A HUNDRED
AND IN. HUNTERDON TO AVERAGE
STEPS REPORTED OF THE MONTH OF
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY AND NOTED BY
THE N. I. C. B. DURING THESE
YEARS THE TOP FIVE STATES FOR
CATHOLIC CONVERTER THEFTS WERE
CALIFORNIA TEXAS MINNESOTA-
NORTH CAROLINA ILLINOIS' EAST
BAY RECENTLY A RECENT KCRA
REPORT INDICATES THAT THE NUMBER
REPORTS A CATALYTIC CONVERTER
THEFTS HAVE INCREASED OVER.
FIFTEEN HUNDRED OVER THE LAST
THREE AND A HALF YEARS IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY ALONE WELL
CALIFORNIA HAS LAWS THAT
PROHIBIT THE DEATH OF THESE
DEVICES AS WELL AS GOVERNED
RECYCLE TREND TRANSACTIONS WITH
DETACHED CATHOLIC CONVERTERS.
THE PERSON WHO POSSESSES THE
DEVICE MAY NOT BE THE PERSON WHO
ACTUALLY COMMITTED THE THEFT AND
PROVIDING THE ELEMENT- OF THE
THEFT CAN BE. DIFFICULT SKEWS ME
. LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
PROSECUTORS AS WELL AS CRIME
VICTIMS WOULD BE BENEFITED BY
THE LAW THAT MAKES IT CLEAR THAT
POSSESSION OF THE DETACHED
CATHOLIC CONVERTER WITHOUT
AUTHORIZATION OR VALID REASON IS
UNLAWFUL. WELL THERE ARE A FEW
CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH A PERSON
WOULD WOULD HAVE A VALID REASON
TO POSSESS A DETACHED CATALYTIC
CONVERTER AB TWO THIRTY. AB
TWENTY THREE NINETY EIGHT
ACCOUNTS FOR THOSE RARE
OCCASIONS BY EXEMPTING. PERSON
WHO CAN DEMONSTRATE THAT THEY
OWN THE VEHICLE FROM WHICH THE
CATALYTIC CONVERTER CAME OR HAVE
WRITTEN OR AUTHORIZATION FROM
THE OWNER. RECYCLE INVOLVED IN
THE LAW FOR TRANSACTION PERSON
INVOLVED IN A BONAFIDE
AUTOMOTIVE INDUSTRIAL. ENGAGED
IN A LAW FOR ACTIVITY WE'RE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE
ESPECIALLY IF THERE ARE TWEAKS
THAT EXISTS THAT TRICKS TO EXIST
EXEMPTIONS THAT WOULD. WOULD
HELP MAKE THIS MORE COMPLETE
COMBAT FOR THE GROWING
POPULATION. BECAUSE LEGISLATION
COUNCIL HOUSE OP. THAT THIS
BILL. AMEND PROPOSITION FORTY
SEVEN IS APPROVED THE QUESTION
WOULD HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE
VOTERS IT SEEMS ARE.
INAPPROPRIATE TO GIVE THE PEOPLE
A CHANCE TO RE EXAMINE THIS
POLICY ELIMINATE THE CHORES WE
BLOCK THAT. WILL BELONG TO THE
VOTERS WITH ME TO TESTIFY TODAY
IS SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY SHERIFF
PAT WITHROW AND COREY CELL ZERO
ZERO ZERO. REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. JEFF YOU MAY PROCEED
THANK YOU VICE CHAIRPERSON THANK
YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- I'M
HERE TODAY. TO REALLY TRY AND
HAMMER HOME HOW IMPORTANT THIS
IS TO THE PEOPLE OF OUR
COMMUNITY THIS IS JUST EXPLODED
THROUGHOUT OUR COMMUNITY THIS
CRIME AND WHAT IT IS A LOOPHOLE.
IN OUR EXISTING LAWS THAT ALLOWS
THAT TO HAPPEN YOU KNOW WHILE
BACK CATALYTIC CONVERTERS DIDN'T
EVEN EXIST AND NOW THEY DO ON
MOST OUR CARS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND IT IS A LOOPHOLE
THAT IS INCENTIVIZING PEOPLE TO
BECOME CRIMINALS PEOPLE WHO
WOULD NORMALLY NOT GO OUT AND
COMMIT CRIMES ARE DOING THIS
BECAUSE- IT'S SO PROFITABLE TO
THEM IT'S HARD FOR THEM TO
RESIST I'VE- JUST GOT SOME
RECENT EXAMPLES WHERE WE'RE
GONNA CASE RIGHT NOW. WHERE WE
HAD ONE GUY IN OUR COUNTY THAT
WAS ACCEPTING THESE CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS FROM PEOPLE THAT
WOULD JUST GO OUT IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE NIGHT OR THE MIDDLE OF
THE DAY ROLL UNDERNEATH THE CAR
WITH A BATTERY OPERATED SAWS
ALL. CUT IT OFF A PERSON'S CAR
AND THEN TAKE IT TO THIS GUY AND
TRADED IN AND THEY GO FOR UP TO
FIFTY TO FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
DEPENDING ON THE TYPE OF VEHICLE
THEY CAME OFF OF. THE PREVIOUS
IS ARE THE MOST EXPENSIVE ONES-
THAT THEY CAN GET THE MOST
PRECIOUS METALS OUT OF THESE
CATALYTIC CONVERTERS AND- WHEN
WE- DID SURVEILLANCE AND WORK
THE BIG CASE UP ON THIS GUY
ACCEPTING ALL THESE- WE FOUND
DOCUMENTATION THE THAT HE HAD
MADE SO FAR THIS LAST YEAR. ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS JUST
THIS ONE PERSON IN DEALING IN
CATALYTIC CONVERTERS TAKING THEM
DOWN TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
SELLING THEM SO WE'RE WE PUSH
REALLY HARD FOR NEW LEGISLATION
AND OUR LOCAL DA TORY VERBAS
SALAZAR WHO'S A- MEMBER OF THE
PROSECUTOR'S ALLIANCE AND I
BELIEVE THE PUBLIC DEFENDERS OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I MEAN
THE DA'S OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THIS BECAUSE
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE TOOL SIX.
LAW LIKE- GRAND THEFT DOESN'T
EXIST ON THIS BECAUSE THE
PROBLEM IS ONCE IT'S OFF THE
VEHICLE YOU CANNOT PROVE WHICH
VEHICLE IT CAME OFF OF THEIR
ART. DEDICATED NUMBERS LIKE
SERIAL NUMBERS ON A HAND GUN OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT TO PROVE
THIS. AND WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
LITERALLY MAKE A NEW CAR A NEW
CRIME HERE A BILL OR A LOT FOR A
NEW. CRIME WE'RE TRYING TO FIX
THE LOOPHOLE THAT IS HERE. IT'S
LOW INCOME FAMILIES THAT ARE
BEING DEVASTATED BY THIS
FAMILIES THAT CAN'T AFFORD TO
TAKE A DAY OFF BECAUSE SOMEBODY
IS VICTIMIZED IN THIS WAY. THEY
CAN'T AFFORDTO NOT GET THEIR
KIDS TO SCHOOL BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE A VEHICLE TO
TRANSPORT THEM. AND BY MAKING IT
A WOBBLER IT'S GIVING THE-
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS THE JUDGES
AND THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S. TO
FIND THOSE PEOPLE WHO. AREN'T
THE HARDENED CRIMINALS THAT ARE
MAKING THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OFF OF THIS TO SOMEBODY WHO JUST
TOOK A OPPORTUNITY TO TRY AND
MAKE SOME MONEY. TO HELP HIS
FAMILY AND MAKE IT A MISDEMEANOR
GET HIM INTO COURT GET HIM SOME
TYPE OF DIVERSION- BUT STILL
REPRESENT THE FAMILIES THAT ARE
BEING VICTIMIZED BY THIS. SO IT
IS IT IS AN IMPACT IN OUR
COMMUNITY LIKE YOU CAN'T BELIEVE
AND IT'S EVERY SINGLE NIGHT LAST
NIGHT WE GOT A STOLEN VEHICLE
THAT HAD I DON'T KNOW FIVE OR
TEN OF THIS TO THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS IN IT. AND THEY GO IN
CHARGE BECAUSE THE DIEGO IS YES
OBVIOUSLY THESE ARE STOLEN OFF
OF CARS ARE CUT OFF ON EITHER
END AND YOU'RE IN POSSESSION OF
THEM. BUT BECAUSE E CANNOT
PROVE WHICH CAR IT CAME FROM AND
WHO THE VICTIM IS NO ONE IS HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THIS SO THERE IS
NO DETERRENTS. TO KEEP PEOPLE
FOR GOING INTO THIS BUSINESS OF
VICTIMIZING OUR CITIZENS
DEVASTATING THEIR LIVES BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T GET TO WORK AND
OFTENTIMES THE VEHICLE ITSELF.
ISN'T OF VALUE TO WHAT IT TAKES
TO REPAIR THE CAR SO THEY LOSE
THEIR VEHICLES. SO THIS IS YOU
KNOW IT'S IMPACTFUL BUT NOT AS
IMPACTFUL TO PEOPLE LIKE US WHO
HAVE A GOOD INSURANCE ON OUR
VEHICLES OR OR CAN GET TIME OFF
WORK IN. AND HAVE THE MONEY THE
FIFTEEN HUNDRED TO TWO THOUSAND
TO TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED IT TAKES
TO REPLACE THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTER ON A CAR. BUT FOR
SOMEBODY WHO'S WHO'S WORKING
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK LIKE MOST
THE PEOPLE IN OUR STATE. THIS IS
A DEVASTATING SO WE'RE HOPING
THIS WILL BE A HUGE DETERRENTS
WHEN WE STOP THE CAR AND YOU
HAVE A CATALYTIC CONVERTER THAT
IS. YOU CANNOT PROVE THAT IT THE
THAT YOU LEGALLY POSSESS THAT.
THEN WE CAN GET YOU INTO THE
SYSTEM AND EITHER GET YOU THE
HELP YOU NEED OR STOP YOU FROM
VICTIMIZING OUR CITIZENS- SO I
WOULD ASK THAT ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION. THAT
YOU THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SERVICE SOCIAL RESEARCHER
MEMBERS COURCELLES ALONG BEHALF
K. TWENTY. SKINNY COW. SURE
SYSTEM- THE SPOTS OF THE BILL
AND ANY. BUT THE AUTHOR- AND THE
SHERIFF I THINK OF LATE ABOUT WE
ARE- THE SIMPLY MAKING CLEAR
THAT THE POSSESSION OF THESE
DETACHED DEVICES. IS WHAT'S
UNLAWFUL- IF WE CAN PROVE THE
THEFT THEM THAT WILL BE THE CASE
WE OFTEN CAN'T- AND SO JUST
CLARIFYING THAT THE BILL HAS A
NUMBER OF EXEMPTIONS FOR
SITUATIONS IN WHICH IT MAKES
SENSE THAT A PERSON MIGHT.
POSSESS A DETACHED CATALYTIC
CONVERTER AND IF THOSE
EXEMPTIONS NEED ADDITIONAL-
TWEAKING WE ARE HAPPY TO WORK ON
THAT SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR.
THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL THAT'S IN THE ROOM. AT&T.
WE HAVE AN A. S. SUPPORTERS ARE
LIKE TO EXPRESS THAT SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO IN MY FIRST THAT
WENT SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
. THANK YOU CAN TONE DOWN
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND THERE ARE A
COUPLE WITH APPARATED TO BE JUST
A MOMENT.
I'M GOING TO LINE THE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING AMANDA CALDERON WITH
TRIPLE A IN SUPPORT THANKS.
THANK YOU ARE NOW LINE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THE ALLIANCE FOR AUTOMOTIVE
INNOVATION AND SUPPORT. AND AT
THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
THINK YOU PLEASE CONTINUE. OKAY
THANK YOU OPPOSITION IF YOU'D
LIKE TO STEP FORWARD AND-
EXPRESS YOUR TESTIMONY.
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU VICE
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU COMMITTEE
GOING BACK AS FOR THE ELEVATOR
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THE
PROPONENTS HAVE NOT PROVEN. AS
PENALTY WILL REDUCE CRIME OR
REDUCE THEFT OF CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS. THERE IS HOWEVER NOT
A CONSENSUS IN ALL RESEARCH THAT
IT'S NOT THE FEAR OF A HIGH
PENALTY BUT THE FEAR OF
APPREHENSION THAT DETERS CRIME
INCREASING THE PENALTY WILL NOT
DETER CRIME. SO ALSO NOT PROVEN
THAT PROP FORTY SEVEN IS THE
REASON THERE WAS AN INCREASE IN
CRIME. THERE HAVE BEEN INCREASES
IN PROPERTY CRIME AND VIOLENT
CRIME THROUGHOUT THE U. S. IN
THE TIME OF COLD IT. IT HAPPENED
IN JURISDICTIONS THAT WERE TOUGH
ON CRIME HAPPENED IN
JURISDICTIONS ARE MORE. I WAS
INTELLIGENT AND CAREFUL IN THEIR
APPLICATION OF INCARCERATION.
THE CURRENT PENALTY FOR THEFT OF
THIS ITEM IS SIX MONTHS IN JAIL.
A THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE AND
RESTITUTION TO THE VICTIM. WHY
ARE WE TOLD THE SIX MONTHS TO
FIND A RESTITUTION IS NOT ENOUGH
. WHY SIX MONTHS IN JAIL AND NOT
ENOUGH WHY ARE WE ALWAYS PUSHING
FOR NEW FELONIES WHITE IS THE
DA'S. INSURANCE PUSH FOR NEW
FELONIES WHY IS SIX MONTHS AWAY
FROM YOUR FAMILY NOT ENOUGH WIFE
SIX MONTHS OF YOUR LIFE NOT
ENOUGH. WE ASK THAT. LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. ENFORCE THE LAWS AS
WRITTEN. IT'S UP TO US
COLLECTIVELY. TO RESPECT THE
EVIDENCE THAT ABOUT WHAT DOES
DETER CRIME WHAT DOES PROTECT
PEOPLE. IT'S UP TO US
COLLECTIVELY TO RESPECTIVE
OWNERS MANDATE. AND RESPECT
FUNDAMENTAL HUMAN RIGHTS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MARCO GEORGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION- I WOULD ECHO MISTER
BACCHUS IS COMMENTS BUT I WOULD
ALSO SAY THAT- NOT ONLY IS- AB
TWENTY THREE NINETY EIGHT A BAD
PUBLIC POLICY BECAUSE IT TRIES
TO RETURN US TO THE BAD OLD DAYS
OF EVERY OFFENSE IS A FELONY.
BUT IT HAS A DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT ON BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES. BUT EVEN MORE
PERNICIOUS HEY IS AB TWENTY
THREE NINETY EIGHTHS METHOD
WHICH IS BASICALLY TO CREATE
ALMOST A STRICT LIABILITY
OFFENCE IF YOU HAVE A CATALYTIC
CONVERTER. IT'S NOT THAT YOU'RE
INNOCENT UNTIL PROVEN GUILTY
YOU'RE GUILTY UNTIL PROVEN
INNOCENT AND NOT ONLY DO YOU
HAVE TO PROVE THAT IT CAME FROM
THE VEHICLE YOUR VEHICLE BUT
ALSO THAT YOU KNEW AHEAD OF TIME
TO- HAVE IT INSCRIBED WITH THE
VIN NUMBER. AT LET ME GIVE YOU A
REAL LIFE EXAMPLES SO- I LIVE IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA- AS YOU MIGHT
EXPECT THERE A BUNCH OF
PREVIOUS'S- IN OAKLAND BERKELEY.
AND MY NEIGHBOR HAD- HIS
CATALYTIC CONVERTER STOLEN. NOW
IF HE HAD DECIDED TO GET IN HIS
TRUCK. HE DID HAVE ANOTHER
VEHICLE AND DRIVE AROUND THE
NEIGHBORHOOD AND FOR WHATEVER
REASON THE- THIEVES HAD DECIDED
TO TOSS HIS CATALYTIC CONVERTER
OUT ON THE STREET. IF HE HAD
PICKED IT UP AND PUT IT IN THE
BACK OF HIS TRUCK AND THEN
STOPPED FOR A TRAFFIC OFFENSE ON
THE WAY HOME. THEN HE WOULD HAVE
BEEN ARRESTED FOR A FELONY
BECAUSE HE WOULD HAVE HAD NO
WAY. TO PROVE. THAT THAT WAS HIS
CATALYTIC CONVERTER. BECAUSE HE
COULD TAKE HIM TO HIS HOUSE AND
SHOW A LOOK SEE WHAT DOES
THERE'S NO CATALYTIC CONVERTER
ON MY PREVIOUS. BUT HE DIDN'T
HAVE A VIN NUMBER INSCRIBED ON
IT- BUT YOU KNOW I WOULD JUST
ECHO- TWO THINGS ONE I THINK THE
PROPONENTS SAID THAT THEY HAD-
COME ACROSS SOMEBODY WHO HAD-
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF.CATALYTIC CONVERTERS
THIS IS THE WHO VISIBILITY SIX
TO GO AFTR THEY'RE NOT GOING
AFTER THE PEOPLE WHO ARE ON
RECYCLING AND THE TAKING THIS TO
THE FENCES BASICALLY THEY'RE
GOING AFTER THE INDIVIDUAL
PEOPLE WHO STEAL THEM AND THAT
IS A CRIME OF POVERTY. SO WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE ON A BILL TWENTY THREE
NINETY EIGHT. OKAY IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM THOUGH LIKE
TO EXPRESS OUR OPPOSITION PLEASE
. THANK YOU FRED WILLIAMS AC YOU
COLLECTION IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU THERE ARE NO OTHERS WILL GO
TO THE PHONE PHONE LINES.
OPERATOR THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHT
TWENTY THREE NINETY EIGHT WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR FROM THEM. THANK
YOU. IF YOUR POST PLEASE PRESS
AND ONE THEN ZERO.
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
PARTICIPANT THANK YOU. THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MISCALCULATE FIRST OF ALL I HAVE
A CALL LAST NIGHT. JUST LAST
NIGHT FROM SOMEONE WHO DOES
REPAIRS HE'S ALSO CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER DID HE HAS A REPAIR SHOP
AND HE TALKED TO ME ABOUT
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
POVERTY ALREADY LOSING THEIR
CATALYTIC CONVERTER AND LOSING
THEIR AUTOMOBILE. AND- POSSIBLY
ENDING UP HOMELESS BECAUSE OF IT
SO IT IS A BIG PROBLEM. HOWEVER
YOUR BILL JUST NEEDS A LOT OF
WORK AND I CAN'T VOTE FOR IT AT
THIS TIME FIRST FALL. YOU REALLY
SHOULD LEAVE. THE CURRENT- IN MY
OPINION THE CURRENT PUNISHMENT
IN PLACE- AS WAS SAID BY THE
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE ELLA
BAKER CENTER- A MISDEMEANOR
WHERE YOU'RE SIX MONTHS IN JAIL
AND GETTING FIND AT CENTER I
THINK IS A DETERRENT. THE SECOND
THING WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THIS
IS QUESTION OF ATTRIBUTION. SO
WHAT THE WHAT SHOULD WHAT THE
SHERIFF SAID WHAT YOU CAN'T TELL
WHO OWNS. THAT CATALYTIC
CONVERTER IS THAT CORRECT THAT'S
CORRECT THAT'S THE PROBLEM THAT
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEYS HAVE BEEN
CHARGING WHETHER IT'S PETTY
THEFT OR GRAND THEFT- THEY CAN'T
PROVE WHO THE VICTIM OF THE
CRIME IS EVEN THOUGH WE KNOW
IT'S BEEN TAKEN OFF THE VEHICLE.
YEAH SO SOMEONE HAS CATALYTIC
CONVERTER THEY CAN'T PROVE THAT
IT'S THERE'S EITHER. WELL THEY
COULD HAVE THE DOCUMENTATION OF
THEIR VEHICLE THAT CAME OFF OF-
WITH THEIR VIN NUMBER FROM THAT
VEHICLE- SHOWING THAT- THEY HAD
TAKEN IT OFF THEIR OWN VEHICLE
AND THAT.WOULD BE ENOUGH FOR US
TO SAY OKAY- WE CAN GO BACK AND
VERIFY THAT AND MAKE SURE THAT
IT WAS YOURS SO YEAH BUT GIVEN
THAT- YES THIS. REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE PUBLIC DEFENDER SAID.
IT DOESN'T HAVE A VIN NUMBER ON
IT SO PROVING YET THAT IT SURE
SOUNDS VERY DIFFICULT I THINK
THESE THINGS NEED TO BE
CORRECTED I THINK THAT THERE IS
A WAY TO CORRECT THEM WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT SOMEBODY HAVING FIVE
CATALYTIC CONVERTERS. WE NEED TO
MAKE THAT A CRIME- WHETHER IT'S
A MISDEMEANOR WOBBLER WE CAN
DISCUSS BUT IF IT'S FIVE OF THEM
PROBABLY IT IS ENOUGH. TO MAKE
IT A FELONY- BUT RIGHT NOW
YOU'RE MAKING IT YOU GOT TO
PROVE THAT THAT MONEY IS YOURS
AND IT'S NOT CLEAR TO ME HOW YOU
DO THAT. THESE THINGS NEED TO BE
CORRECTED IN THE BELL AND WHAT
I'D ASK THE AUTHOR TO THINK
ABOUT. OUR IS EITHER WITHDRAWING
THE BILL AT THIS POINT AND
ASKING THE COMMITTEE TO WORK ON
IT WITH HIM. OR IS IF IT IS
VOTED DOWN- THAN TO ASK FOR
RECONSIDERATION WORK WITH
COMMITTEE I JUST THINK THERE ARE
TOO MANY PROBLEMS WITH THE BILL
RIGHT NOW. BUT I THINK THEY CAN
BE CORRECTED AND THERE IS A
PROBLEM IF YOU CAN'T PROSECUTE
SOMEBODY WHO HAS FIVE. CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS THAT'S FOR SURE. SO
I'M- I DO THINK THAT THERE IS A
WAY TO FIX THIS BUT I DON'T
THINK WE CAN DO IT TODAY THANK
YOU. THIS IS YOUR QUESTION FOR-
THE SHERIFF- IN IN TRYING TO
PROSECUTE THIS CRIME ONE OF THE
ISSUES IS THEY GO UNDERNEATH.
EVEN IF THEY'RE CAUGHT IN THE
ACT UNLESS THEY'VE ACTUALLY
TAKEN THE CATALYTIC CONVERTER
OFF YOU CAN'T CHARGING FOR
BURGLARY IT'S JUST VANDALISM
THAT'S CORRECT CORRECT. SO WE'RE
REALLY WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS
A WAY ESPECIALLY FOR THIS
PARTICULAR. CRIME TO BE
PROSECUTED TO BE SOMEBODY HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR DOING IT- THIS
THIS TO ME ALSO HAS A GREATER
EFFECT ON AREAS WHERE. WE'LL
TRADITIONALLY DON'T HAVE. THEIR
CARS PROTECTED IN A GARAGE AS SO
THEY'RE LINED UP ON THE STREETS
AND A LOT OF BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE THAT WE KEEP BRINGING
UP ABOUT BEING OVERLY IMPACTED.
WELL THAT'S WHERE THEY'RE
GETTING OVERLY IMPACTED THEY'VE
THE VICTIMS THEMSELVES. ARE-
DISPROPORTIONATELY FROM BLACK
AND BROWN COMMUNITIES. ARE
BECAUSE THEY WERE AVAILABILITY
OF VEHICLES OUTSIDE AWAY FROM
WHERE THEY MIGHT RESIDE AND SO
IF THE NOISE FROM STEALING THE
CATHOLIC CONVERTER. OR THE FEAR
OF CONFRONTING SOMEBODY STEALING
ONE IS NOT- IT AB IF NOBODY'S
GONNA GO REPORT IT YOU'RE NEVER
GOING TO CATCH THESE FOLKS AND
SO THAT'S WHAT I THINK THIS BILL
IS TRYING TO DO. AND WHILE IT
DOES HAVE SOME TROUBLES I THINK
. THAT IT'S THE ONLY BILL I'VE
SEEN THAT IS TRYING TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE AND THIS ISSUE IS
GROWING IT JUST LIKE JUST LIKE
FINALLY HITS IT'S GROWING
EXPONENTIALLY AND IT'S AFFECTING
THE VERY PEOPLE THAT WE SAY
WE'RE TRYING TO PROTECT. AND SO
ONE OF THE THINGS I WOULD ASK
THIS COMMITTEE INSTEAD OF TAKING
THE APPROACH OF PULL IT IS I
WOULD LIKE TO. **** COMMITTEE TO
LET THIS BILL GO OUT AND
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
BECAUSE WE'VE DONE THAT WITH
OTHER BILLS THAT HAVE SERIOUS
MORE WAY MORE SERIOUS FLAWS IN
THIS. AND IN BETWEEN NOW AND
WHEN IT GOES TO OUR FINAL VOTE-
WE'RE ABLE TO- DISCERN WHETHER.
OUR OUR ISSUES HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED. AND SO I WOULD ASK
THE COMMITTEE TO ALLOW THIS BILL
TO GO OUT. AND BETWEEN NOW AND
WHEN WE SEE IT AGAIN- WE
DETERMINE WHETHER- BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE THAT OPTION DETERMINE
WHETHER IT EXISTS IT DID IS
SUCCESSFUL IN ADDRESSING THE
ISSUES. THAT WE HAVE BUT AND I
THINK WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO%
WORK ON THIS BILL BECAUSE
WITHOUT THIS BILL WE DON'T HAVE
ANY BILL. AND ANOTHER YEAR AND
SOME CHANGE BEFORE WE START
LOOKING AT WHAT WE DO ABOUT
THIS. AND THE SHERIFFS WHO ARE
TRYING TO ADDRESS THIS ARE LEFT.
HAND CUFFED. IN THEIR ATTEMPTS
TO TRY TO HELP PEOPLE IN THE
VERY PEOPLE THAT WE KEEP SAYING
WE'RE TRYING TO HELP SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR BILL AND I DO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S SOME WORK
MAY BE DONE ON IT- I WILL BE
VOTING YES AND HOPE. MY
COLLEAGUES WILL JOIN US IN
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW WE CAN MAKE THIS INTO
A BILL THAT WORKS FOR EVERYBODY
THANK YOU. IF I COULD IF I CAN
OUT OF THE PROJECT FOR MY HEALTH
TODAY AND- THIS. THIS BILL THAT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT YOU SEE IT.
ALL OVER SOCIAL MEDIA. IT IT'S
THE I'M STOCKTON CALIFORNIA.
OKAY SO. WE'RE TALKING PEOPLE OF
COLOR GUESS WHAT KIND OF MY
COMMUNITY. AND YOU YOU ARE WHERE
I. LIVE AND LOVE MY COMMUNITY.
BUT YOU'RE CATCHING FOLKS THAT
ARE. THE LITTLE OF THE FOLKS
THAT ARE WITH FILMING IT. OUR
OUR- MY OWN PEOPLE. AND BECAUSE
NOTHING IS BEING DONE. SO WHAT
ARE THEY DOING I'LL BE HONEST
THERE KNOCKING HIM OUT. THERE
BEATING HIM UP. BECAUSE THERE'S
NOTHING BEING PREVENTIVE OUT
THERE. I'M TALKING I HAVE I HAVE
A LADY. WHO WORKS AT AT THE
HOSPITAL IN OUR CAR'S PROBABLY
WORTH. YOU KNOW THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED BUCKS. SHE CAN'T GET TO
WORK NOW BECAUSE IT'S GONE SHE
CALLED UP THE OFFICE DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON SOUNDS LIKE A
TRACTOR. YOU KNOW IT WAS A
CATALYTIC CONVERTER SO SHE HAD
TO BORROW HER BROTHER'S CAR. TO
GET TO WORK NOW I'M TALKING
HERE'S A LADY HAS LIVING
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK. AND WE'RE
SO WE'RE WE'RE OVER HERE TALKING
ABOUT PREVENTING PUTTING MONEY
IN THE HOMELESS BEEN PUT IN
HOUSING WHEN HERE IS A LADY THAT
IS LITERALLY TRYING TO DO WHAT'S
GOOD IN OUR COMMUNITY. AND SHE'S
YEAH SHE IS YOU KNOW WOMEN OF
COLOR. AND TRYING TO DO WORK
EVERY DAY TRYING TO TAKE. IT OUT
OVER TIME. TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
THE YET WERE WORKBOOK FOR
PENALIZING FOLKS LIKE THAT. AND
SO WE'RE ACTUALLY PUSHING THEM
TO SAY YOU KNOW WHAT FORGET IT
THERE'S NOTHING I CAN DO WHY
SHOULD I GO TO WORK. RIGHT
BECAUSE- I CANNOT AFFORD IT NOW
. I CARE SHE'S TRYING TO WORKER
PROGRAM WITH THE RATHER. SHE CAN
USE A CAR SHE DOESN'T KNOW SHE
TO WORK OVERTIME BECAUSE HE'S
WORKING. SENIORS IN MY COMMUNITY
. THEY'RE ON A FIXED INCOME. ON
A FIXED INCOME AND THEY CAN'T
AFFORD THIS THEY GET THE STONE
THAT'S GUESS WHAT THEY'RE DIE.
THE RELYING ON ON RELATIVES TO
BRING THEM FOOD WERE THEY RELIED
TO GET IN THAT CAR JUST TO GO TO
THE GROCERY STORE TO HAVE A
SOCIAL HOUR. JUST TO SIT THERE
AND TALK TO THE BUTCHER OR THE
PERSON THAT'S YOU KNOW AT THE AT
THE CHECK OUT STAND JUST TO HAVE
A- A CUP OF COFFEE AND HAVE A
YOU KNOW A SOCIAL LIFE. THAT
WERE PREVENTING THAT. SO I MEAN
IT'S MORE AB WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
ADD. YOU KNOW TO GET. FOLKS MORE
ARRESTED AT ALL THAT'S- BY FAR.
I HOPE THE SHERIFF CAME ACROSS
THAT. BECAUSE WE HAVE A GREAT
CHEF HERE. HAS WORKED SO HARD.
TO WORK IN OUR COMMUNITY. AND
BELIEVES OUR COMMUNITY. AND I'M
I'M TRYING TO DO THE SAME THING
HERE. I'M TIRED OF WATCHING THIS
ON SOCIALLY I'M TIRED OF HEARING
THE PHONE CALLS AT WORK WHAT DO
YOU DOING THAT IS BEING THERE.
AND I'M- YEAH I'M A SOPHOMORE
APPEAR. I'M TRYING TO FIGHT HARD
TO MAKE SURE. I THE DOCTOR TOLD
ME WAS YOU KNOW STAMKOS YOU
SHOULD NOT BUT I WANTED TO BE
HERE TODAY. BECAUSE THIS BILL
MEANS A LOT BUT JUST FOR MY
DISTRICT. ON TOP OF FOR YOUR
DISTRICT WE'RE NOT DOING
ANYTHING. IT JUST SEEMS LIKE.
EVERY TIME A BILL LIKE THIS
BECAUSE IT'S ABOUT. WE'RE TRYING
TO FIGHT AND PUT INCARCERATED
NO. I'M TRYING TO I'M GOING
AFTER TO SUPPORTING MY
COMMUNITY. MY COLOR COMMITTEE.
SURE THAT THEY'RE WORKING THAT
I'M TRYING TO MAKE SURE THEY GET. FROM A TO B. M. THIRTEEN
THIRTY. SAFE SO I ASKED TODAY I
MEAN YOU KNOW AGAIN I'M GONNA GO
BACK. WE TALK ABOUT HOMELESS
FOLKS ALL THE TIME WE TALK ABOUT
. YOU KNOW WHAT CAN WE DO TO
MAKE CHANGES IN OUR COMMUNITY.
HERE HERE IT IS WE'RE FOR
PUTTING PEOPLE BACK TO WORK AND
THIS IS A THE MOST DIFFICULT
TIMES WHERE PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO
WORK DON'T HAVE THEY DON'T DON'T
THE LIVE PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK IN
MY DISTRICT. AND WHEN THEY GET
THE CATALYTIC CONVERTER STOLEN.
THEY'RE ALMOST THERE ALMOST
ALMOST THERE. THAT COULD BACK
OUT OF THE CONVERTERS WORTH MORE
THAN THE CAR. SO I ASKED I AM
SHE GOES SUPER I MEAN I'D BE
WILLING TO WORK WITH WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO MAKE SOME CHANGES
ON THIS ABSOLUTELY I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE DOING
SOMETHING OR TO ME THAT WE ARE
PROTECTING OUR- THOSE FOLKS THAT
YOU HEAR ABOUT. THOSE FOLKS IN
YOUR DISTRICT. RIGHT GUESTS WERE
IN QUESTION ANSWER THAT SOUNDED
MORE LIKE A CLOSE WITH. GREAT
MISTER BY. YEAH NOT. ET YOU TALK
ABOUT- DISHES WE STRUGGLE
REPRESENT CHRIS OUR DISTRICT AND
I KNOW THE CHAIR GEN I SURE
SOUTH CENTRAL LOS ANGELES- AND I
UNDERSTAND. THAT FEELING WHEN
YOU HAVE A CONSTITUENT CALL OR
SEVERAL AND THE ABILITY TO MAKE
CHANGES IS IN YOUR HANDS. ON FOR
ME TODAY THE STRUGGLE IS. WHAT'S
BEEN SAID A FEW TIMES IS THAT WE
DON'T WANT TO ADD A NEW CRIME
AND WE DON'T WANT TO ADD NEW
PENALTIES BUT THAT EFFECTIVELY
IS WHAT THIS BILL DOES WITH THE
WOBBLER AND THE CHANGING THE
DEFINITION OF THE EXISTING CRIME
AND RAISES THE PENALTY AND IT
CREATES A NEW CATEGORY BOTH
SIMULTANEOUSLY AND WE KNOW
WOBBLIES DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT. BLACK BROWN POINT
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE BECAUSE THE
DISCRETION TO GO FELONY OR
OTHERWISE OFTEN FALLS ON
IMMUTABLE CHARACTERISTICS AND
NOT ALWAYS THE CHARACTERISTICS
OF WHAT'S HAPPENED IN ADDITION
TO THE FACT THAT MISDEMEANOR THE
WHOLE SYSTEM DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTS BLACK BROWN POOR
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE AND SO I HOPE
THAT IF THIS BILL DOESN'T MAKE
IT OUT TODAY IT GOES TO THE
RECONSIDERATION PROCESS. SAID WE
CAN GET YOU OF SOMETHING YOU CAN
TAKE BACK TO THE COMMUNITY- TO
SHOW THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
PUTTING IN BECAUSE THERE ARE
VERY FEW LEGISLATORS IN THIS
BUILDING OR FIGHTING HARDER THAN
YOU ARE FOR YOUR DISTRICT AND I
SEE THAT AND I THINK THAT YOUR
CONSTITUENCY THAT TOO BUT- FOR
THE- REASONS EXPLAINED EARLIER I
CAN'T SUPPORT THIS BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM. EVERY WILL IT WORK
ACT. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER. YES
YES MR LACKEY. FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING ATTENTION
TO THIS I KNOW IT TOOK SOME GUTS
BECAUSE YOU'RE GIVEN SOME. SOME
DISCOURAGING INFORMATION ALONG
THE WAY. AND I REALLY WISH THAT
EVERYONE ON THIS COMMITTEE
UNDERSTOOD. HOW BIG OF A PROBLEM
THE SAYS AND- THE PEOPLE THE
OFFENDERS ARE ACTUALLY
EXPLOITING THE LACK OF REMEDY
THAT WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM- AND IT'S VERY VERY
TEMPTING FOR THOSE. WHO ARE
STRUGGLING. TO GAIN A LOT OF
MONEY QUICK. AND SO WE AS
POLICYMAKERS HAVE RESPONSIBILITY
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
ADDRESS PROBLEMS ARE BROUGHT TO
OUR ATTENTION AND WEEK TO
SUMMARILY DISMISS. SOLUTIONS
BECAUSE IT PUTS US IN A
COMFORTABLE SPACE. SHAME ON US
FOR NOT BEING ABLE TO STEP
OUTSIDE OF OUR COMFORT ZONE TO
DO WHAT IS RIGHT I'M TELLING YOU
FOLKS IN IN MY DISTRICT I KNOW
OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THIS
IS BEEN THE STRAW TO BREAK THE
CAMEL'S BACK. PEOPLE REALLY ARE
WE DO WE TALK ABOUT IT HERE. I
DON'T THINK ANY OF US UP HERE
LIVE PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK. BUT
WHEN YOU DO. IT'S A TERRIBLE
WORLD TO BE IN. IT CHANGES YOUR
ABILITY TO BE HAPPY AND I'M
TELLING YOU THIS PROBLEM HAS
DONE THAT TO PEOPLE. IT IS PUT
THEM IN A PLACE THAT THEY HAVE
TO GO TO A POINT OF DESPERATION
THAT IF WE HAD SOME PUBLIC
POLICY TO ADDRESS THIS. THEY MAY
NOT BE IN THAT POSITION THEY MAY
NOT HAVE TO EXPERIENCE THE STAFF
THAT'S- I MEAN BECAUSE IT'S
RIGHT IN THAT THAT JUNE WHERE.
FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS.
DEVASTATES PEOPLE. I MEAN I
DON'T KNOW I DON'T KNOW OF ANY-
FIX. FOR THIS PARTICULAR THEFT-
FOR THESE A CATALYTIC CONVERTERS
THAT IS LESS THAN FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS I THINK IT'S
WELL BEYOND THAT AND IN MANY
CASES BUT- I JUST WISH. THE
OTHERS ON THIS COMMITTEE WOULD
SEE THE IMPORTANCE AND THE
NECESSITY FOR SOME INTERVENTION
. AND AT LIKE MY COLLEAGUE
INDICATED WE AT WE HAVE- PAST
WORKS IN PROGRESS PROGRESS
BEFORE AND IF IT DOESN'T MEET
THE EXPECTATION AND WE WEREN'T
ABLE TO WORK THROUGH THIS THING
YOU VOTED DOWN WHEN IT GETS TO
THE FLOOR. IT'S THAT SIMPLE. SO
I'M CLEARLY SUPPORTING IT
BECAUSE I'M VERY THANKFUL THAT
YOU HAD THE COURAGE TO ADDRESS
IT IT MAY NOT BE WHERE IT NEEDS
TO BE. BUT WE CAN WORK ON THAT
AND I HOPE THE PEOPLE GIVEN A
CHANCE. MANY OTHER. I COULD SAY
YOU MAY CLOSE WITH THE GO AHEAD-
I JUST. I WOULD SAY THAT I'D BE
WILLING TO WORK WITH ALL OF YOU
I MEAN IT'S NOT. MY BILL IT'S
ALL IT AFFECTS ALL OF YOU IN
YOUR DISTRICT SO IT. I HOPE YOU
WOULD REALLY RECONSIDER THIS IS
NOT ABOUT. OUR DISTRICT IT'S
ABOUT ALL YOUR DISTRICTS SO
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. OKAY EDIT WHAT AT THE
IVAN AND SEVERAL MEMBERS HAVE
PERSONALLY COME TO ME-
SPECIALIST ARE NOT INCLINED TO
VOTE FOR THIS TO SAID THAT THEY
WANT TO WORK WITH YOU. ON THIS-
THERE THERE. THEIR PRE ELECTION
OR THE WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH
YOU IS REALLY IS GOOD IS
ADMIRABLE AND IT'S NOT JUST ME
IT'S SEVERAL MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE- THE REASON THEY WOULD
VOTED DOWN AND ASK FOR YOU AFTER
RECONSIDERATION IS DON'T WANNA
LET IT OUT OF JUST COMMITTEE
BECAUSE AS A FRESHMAN WE REALLY
DON'T KNOW YOU YET AND SOMETIMES
REFLECTS. SOMETHING OUT BECAUSE
OKAY WITH THE POLICY OR WHATEVER
TO MOVE FORWARD. AND WE'RE
PRETTY SURE. THAT THE AUTHOR
WILL TWEAK. ACCORDING TO WHAT
THE COMMITTEE WANTS THE MAJORITY
OF THE COMMITTEE WANTS- THE
REASON WE DON'T IS BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY WE NEED TO GET TO KNOW
YOU NEED TO GET TO KNOW YOUR
SHERIFF AND PEOPLE WERE WHO WERE
ADVOCATING FOR THIS WE KEEP WE
TRY TO KEEP IT IN THIS COMMITTEE
SO THAT WHEN IT DOES GET OUT. IF
IT GETS OUT OF IT HAS WHAT THE
COMMITTEE FEELS COMFORTABLE WITH
EVEN IF IT'S AGAINST WHAT THE
OPPOSITION WANT THAT GROUP WERE
FORMALLY- WITH THAT WE'VE HAD
SOME PEOPLE WILL REFLECT THINGS
OUT THERE NOW LOBBYING THE REST
OF THE ASSEMBLY INSTEAD OF
WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE. TO
TRY TO GET IT TO ANOTHER
COMMITTEE OR SOMEWHERE ELSE AND
SO THAT IT THAT APPREHENSION
UNFORTUNATELY IT IT IT IT'S NOT
YOU IT'S KIND OF A FEELING OF
THIS COMMITTEE- AND SO I WOULD
ASK FOR A NO VOTE BUT I'M ALSO
GOING TO ASK YOU TO ASK FOR
RECONSIDERATION AMOUNTS GOING TO
ASK YOU. THAT AND I AM GONNA
NAME NAMES OF IT MISTER BRIAN
AND MR QUIRK WHO KIND OF COME TO
ME AND SAID THEY'RE WILLING TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THAT AND I'LL
CLUED MYSELF AND IT LOOKS LIKE-
OBVIOUSLY YOU HAVE TO OTHER
MEMBERS WHO WERE GOING TO VOTE
YES ON IS THAT WOULD LOVE TO
WORK TO MAKE THIS. MAKE THIS A
REALITY- RECONSIDER MEANS. THAT
MEAN IT'S DE IT'S MEANS IT. MORE
TIME TO WORK ON IT. IN THE
CONFINES OF THIS COMMITTEE. NOT
OUTSIDERS COMMITTEE THE BEST WAY
I LOOK ILOOK AT IT. AND SO WITH
WITH THAT. UNFORTUNATELY ARE
RECOMMENDED OVER. IS THERE A
NOTICE WILL BE A MOTION SOME OF
. THANK YOU. ON AB TWENTY THREE
NINETY EIGHT BY SMR BE APPROVED
WHAT THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER NO LACKEY LACKEY I
BONTA. BRIAN. BRIAN NO QUIRK
THANKFULLY NO QUIRK KNOWS
SANTIAGO. SEYARTO I'D SAY ARE
TOO HIGH. I'M SORRY THAT MEASURE
DOESN'T PASS. YEAH AND YOU'RE
ASKING FOR RECONSIDERATION YES
I'M SORRY. RETIREMENT AYE I
WOULD ASK FOR RECONSIDERATION
AND WORK WITH THIS COMMITTEE AYE
AYE- MEMBERS ON THIS BOARD THAT
I'VE ALREADY BEEN KINDA. TALKING
JONES YOU HAVE AND I'VE NAY WISH
TO WORK WITH THEM SO THANK YOU
SIR. WITHOUT OBJECTION- LISTED
BY UNANIMOUS CONSENT. THIS IS
FOR RECONSIDERATION FOR
RECONSIDERATION YES.
OKAY WE'LL GO WITH MISS WICKS
YOUR INTIMATE OF MISS REAVIS WAS
THERE. HAVE A SEAT. BUT. OKAY SO
I'LL I'LL BE QUICK. NOTHING ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY SIX WICKS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS IT'S GOOD
TO BE BACK IN THIS COMMITTEE. I
WANT TO THANK A- THE CHAIR HERE
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
CALIFORNIA IS A NATIONAL LEADER
IN GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION AND
HAS PRIORITIZED COMBATING GUN
VIOLENCE THROUGH HISTORIC BUDGET
ALLOCATIONS POLICY REFORMS FOR
REFORMS AND MORE DESPITE THESE
EFFORTS THERE ARE STILL GAPS
THAT REMAIN THE STATE'S GUN LAWS
THAT ALLOW PEOPLE OR
CORPORATIONS TO MANUFACTURE
LARGE NUMBERS OF FIREARMS
WITHOUT COMPLYING WITH EXISTING
PUBLIC SAFETY PRECAUTIONS. AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY SIX WOULD
PROMOTE PUBLIC SAFETY BY CLOSING
THE GAPS IN CALIFORNIA'S FIRE
FIRE MANUFACTURING LICENSING
LAW. BY JANUARY BY GENERALLY
REQUIRING A STATE ISSUED
MANUFACTURING LICENSE TO
ASSEMBLE OR MANUFACTURE THREE
GUNS OR MORE PER YEAR. THIS
NUMBERS CONSISTENT WITH CURRENT
LAW UNDER THE UNSAFE HANDGUN ACT
AND IS A REASONABLE EXPECTATION
FOR INDIVIDUALS MANUFACTURING
FIREARMS THAT ARE INTENDED FOR
PERSONAL USE ONLY. ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL FURTHER CLARIFIES THE
SAME LICENSE REQUIREMENTS APPLY
TO THREE D. PRINTED GUNS. DATA
PROVIDES THAT PRIVATELY
MANUFACTURED GHOST GUNS ARE NOW
THE LEADING CONTRIBUTOR TO GUN
VIOLENCE AND MORE MORE
JURISDICTIONS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
WE NEED TO STRENGTHEN OUR LAWS
IN OAKLAND IN A SIX MONTH PERIOD
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. OAKLAND PD
ESTIMATED ABOUT 25% OR ONE IN
FOUR OF THE GUNS THAT WERE
RECOVERED WERE GHOST GUNS.
ESSENTIALLY AS- TECHNOLOGY
INNOVATES THE GUN MANUFACTURERS
ARE INNOVATING AND THE CRIMINALS
ARE INNOVATING- AND BEING ABLE
TO PRODUCE GUNS IN AN UNLICENSED
WAY AND SO OUR PUBLIC POLICIES
ALSO NEED INNOVATE TO ENSURE
THAT. WE KEEP GUNS OUT OF THE
WRONG HANDS. IN ORDER TO PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES FROM FURTHER GUN
VIOLENCE WE MUST CLOSE LOOPHOLES
AND STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S
FIRE MANUFACTURING LAWS. WITH ME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS ARLY
ARI FREE LIKE FROM DEFERRED TO
BE JOINING US BY PHONE. WE HAVE
ALREADY BY PHONE OR BY. HELLO
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY SIX. I'M A
GOOD POLICY DIRECTOR OF GIFFORDS
THE GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION
ORGANIZATION LED BY FORMER
CONGRESSWOMAN BROWN OWNER AND
GUNVALSON BIBLE GABBY GIFFORDS
ON WHAT PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL WHICH- YOU START FROM THE
BASICS SIMPLE PREMISE THAT
MANUFACTURING WEAPONS WHICH ARE
DEADLINE AND FREQUENTLY USED. TO
KILL AND MAIM HUMAN BEINGS IS A
SERIES ENTERPRISES THAT REQUIRES
TO CARE OVERSIGHT TRANSPARENCY
AND COMPLIANCE WITH RESPONSIBLE
STANDARD BUSINESS PRACTICE. OF
STATE LAWS CURRENTLY REFLECTED
IN IMPORTANT. BUT TO LIMITED
EXTENT. CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW
WOULD SOME MANUFACTURERS TO A
PANEL TO. FIREARMS FROM CAL. AND
ACCORDING THOSE LIKE AND PATRONS
. FIVE BEST. RESPONSIBLE
BUSINESS TO PROTECT HEALTH THE-
THE LICENSE PLATE. OF THE CHOIR
FOR INSTANCE TO CONDUCT. OPERATE
ONLY IN DESIGNATED BUILDINGS
THAT MEET HI TO TREAT AND
PREVENT ON PASS ON AND ALSO TO
THE TWO CLEANS PROFIT COMES FROM
OUTSIDE WERE ACTUALLY SOLD- THE
MESSENGER THAT ALL FIREARMS
RANGE OF ISSUES IN OUR
CLASSROOMS WE SHOULD BE PRODUCED
BY THE MANUFACTURER. STEP TO THE
UNIX YOU'LL NUMBER. SURE DOESN'T
TAKE THEM SO AND ALL OF TO
HANDLE FIRE PASS ANNUAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS. BY LOCAL LAW
. OF ANY KIND WILL BE. FIREARMS
IN OTHER AND LOOKING. HELLO JEAN
AND TO ENSURE THE LIE. OPERATING
AND RETAIN MANY RIGHT. THE
DEADLINE THE FARMS THAT MANY
PACKET. OBVIOUSLY IT WAS
PROVIDES OF THE NARROWER FOR
ONLINE YOU'VE BEEN TO YEAR LIVE
WHICH FROM A REALIZE COMPONENT.
HOWEVER TWO MAJOR GAP IN THE
WORLD LOVE PEOPLE CORPORATION
TOO MANY LAW AND- NUMBER OF FIRE
PER YEAR ABOUT LIKE ON THERE FOR
WITHOUT COULD WITH ANY OF THE
STATE PUBLIC BECAUSE REQUIRE OF
LIFE. MANUFACTURERS FIRST THE
LAW A PEOPLE TO PAN AM CAL.
FACTORS IF THEY ALL INTO FEDERAL
MANUFACTURE LICENSE WHILE.
INDIVIDUALS AND BUSINESSES
SCHOOL A PILOT FEDERAL LAW
ANYMORE- AFFECTED WITH OTHER
EXEMPTION BY REQUIREMENT IN ALL
BELATED POSSIBLE. THANK YOU.
CURRENT LAW ONLY REQUIRES A
CALIFORNIA FARM AND BY AND
PEOPLE BUSINESSES MANUFACTURE-
MORE FIRES PREMIER IN OUR STATE
. PEOPLE MANUFACTURE TO FORTY
NINE TO THE WEAPONS THE YEAR OUR
EXAM AGAIN THE LIKE UPON. AND
THE COMMON STANDARD PUBLIC
FIGURE PRECAUTIONS ON. FINALLY
UNLIKE MOST OTHER STATES CALLING
NOT PASS A CLEAR FROM PROVISION
PRODUCING. WITH WOULD PRINTERS
WITH A MANUFACTURING LICENCE. ON
SOME ADVOCATES ANOTHER SEPARATE
QUESTION BUT IT THAT OLD.
APPROVED IT GONE I FIND WHY THIS
YEAR AGAIN CHANGES INTO LAW IN
THE YEARS- THE DIRECT I CAN THAT
THE AWESOME COULD PUT. SHOULD BE
CLOSE POSSIBLE.
ALL UP WITH A REASONABLE
EXCEPTION TO THOSE WHO ARE
PRODUCING SMALLER NUMBERS OF
FARMS AND REGULATED COMPONENTS.
QUANTITIES INTENDED FOR PERSONAL
USE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ENERGY TO SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
THE- PORT OF A AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY SIX IN A ROW. WE'LL GO TO
THE PHONES. ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
SIX EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR. IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AT THE END ZERO. SB INTO PORK
DENNIS THEY'RE ALL. AND WE WILL
GO TO THE LINE SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE CALL HAD. THANK YOU
CHAIRED MEMBERS THIS IS NICOLE
KIANA REPRESENTING EVERY TOWN
FOR GUN SAFETY AND SUPPORT AT
TWENTY ONE FIFTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THEIR NEXT WE WILL.
LINE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD MORNING SHARON MEMBERS
REBEKAH MARKETS REPRESENTING THE
BRADY CAMPAIGN AT SUPPORT AT AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYMORE IN THE QUEUE FOR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. C. NINE IN THE
ROOM- YOU GO TO LINE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. AT&T
ARE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION HAT
WOULD BE ONE THAN THEIR OWN.
OPPOSITION ONE NINE ZERO WE DO
HAVE A FEW HERE KILLING UP IT'LL
BE JUST ONE MOMENT. BROUGH
CAROLINE AT THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS NICK HELLO
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION WE
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE
WILL BE JUST ONE SECOND HERE TO
GET THEIR NUMBER. AND WE WILL GO
TO. BRIAN NUMBER EIGHTY TWO HERE
IN JUST ONE MOMENT. R. EIGHT
LINE NUMBER EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IF YOU'RE A MEMBER OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD THE
AND READ WHAT'S YOUR REGIONAL
DIRECTOR WITH THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION ALSO YOU'RE FOR GUN
OWNERS TO CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AND WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY MORE IN QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION RESEARCHER. THANK YOU
BRING ABOUT TO COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR- COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS. MISTER CORK ARM. SO I
HAVE A NEPHEW WHO IS A HOBBYIST
WHO LIKES TO. MAKE GARDENS AND-
PROBABLY MAKES MORE THAN THREE A
YEAR HOW HARD WOULD IT BE FOR
HIM TO GET A MANUFACTURER'S
LICENSED YOU NOW OR DO ONE OF
YOUR EXPERTS NOW SAY YEAH IT'S A
DOABLE PROCESS- AND I SHOULD
ALSO CLARIFY ONE MAKE SURE I WAS
CLEAR MY REMARKS IF YOU MAKE
THREE OR UNDER PER YEAR YOU
DON'T NEED A LICENSE IF YOU MAKE
FOUR OR MORE YOU NEED A LICENSE-
BUT A LOT ARE YOU SPEAK TO. THAT
THAT QUESTION MORE DIRECTLY. THE
APPLICATION PROCESS WOULD
REQUIRE A PASSING OUT THE
BACKGROUND CHECKS TO CONTROL
BUILDING COUNTY A J. COMPLETING
AN APPLICATION IT WOULD REQUIRE
OBTAINING A FEDERAL MANUFACTURES
LICENSES WHILE- WOULD REQUIRE
ANY EMPLOYEES OF HIS TO HANDLE
FIREARMS TO PASS A BACKGROUND
CHECK- FOR THOSE WHO MANUFACTURE
FEWER THAN FIVE HUNDRED POUNDS
PER YEAR INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA
THE FEES WOULD BE CAPPED AT TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS THE
MANUFACTURING LICENSE- WE
BELIEVE IT'S DOABLE. AND
CONSISTENT WITH- NEED TO
SITUATION BURGER. MORE AND MORE
CITIES BEING A SERVER IN AND
VIOLENCE AND CRIMES PERPETRATED
USING SELF ASSEMBLED FIREARMS
THAT ARE. WE DESIGNED NOT JUST
FOR HOBBYISTS IN MIND BUT IN OUR
MARKETING MATERIALS VERY
EXPLICITLY MENTIONING THE FACT
THAT THEY ARE LESS REGULATED
ESSENTIALLY A WORKAROUND
PRODUCT. THE SALE- TO THE TO
LAWS GOVERNING THE SALE FOR
COMPLETE PARM CHAU- WE BELIEVE
IT WILL PROCESS THAT THOUSANDS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY I'VE GOT I'M
VERY EASILY I WOULD SETTLEMENT
AFTER LUNCH THANKS ARE SOME
ADDITIONAL THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED THAT WOULD BE DOABLE
AND REASONABLE. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS CONCERNS YOU MAY
CLOSE RESPECT FAST FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MOVING THE BILL. JURORS
RECOMMEND THE AYE VOTE COST
CALDERON. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE FIFTY SIX BY DECEMBER WICKS
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER HI LACKEY
LACKEY NEL BONTA. BRIAN BRIAN I
WORK AYE CORK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I SEE YOUR TOTAL
SEYARTO NOW. THIS IS A CALL
BETWEEN MARKET VIEW THANK YOU
NOW MISSED RIVAS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY TO BEGIN
A. B. TWENTY TWO TWENTY NINE
ITEM NUMBER NOT. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WANT TO
START BY THANKING TODD LEE UP
FOR HER WORK ON THIS ANALYSIS ON
AB TWO TWO TWO NINE HOLE WHERE I
THINK I SAID. AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY NINE I'LL DO THAT IS A
SIMPLE CLEAN UP MOVE THE BILL-
THANK YOU I LAST YEAR I AUTHORED
AB TEN NINETY SIX WHICH REMOVED
THE INAPPROPRIATE TERM ALIEN
FROM OUR STATE CODES OB DURING
THE FALL INTERNET CAME TO MY
STAFF'S ATTENTION THAT THE
ORIGINAL DRAFTING VERSION OF AB
TEN NINETY SIX WAS BASED ON THE
OLD VERSION OF GOVERNMENT CODE
SECTION TEN THIRTY ONE. AS SUCH-
MY BILL AND INTENTIONALLY
ELIMINATED THE BY S. REQUIREMENT
THAT AB EIGHT FORTY SIX CREATED
IN TWENTY TWENTY UP TO ENSURE
THAT THESE BIAS REQUIREMENTS GO
INTO EFFECT AND URGENT STATUTORY
FIX IS NECESSARY WHICH IS WHY AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY NINE IS BEFORE
YOU TODAY. I HAVE WITH ME TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY MEGAN POLOS
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND MY NAME IS
MEGAN WALLACE AND I AM THE
LEGISLATIVE LIAISON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING
OR MORE COMMONLY KNOWN AS POST.
AT AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY NINE OF
THE NECESSARY BILL FOR POST AND
POSTERS CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS
OF IMPLEMENTING AB EIGHT FORTY
SIX AND TWENTY TWENTY AND AS-
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN STATED OVER
THE FALL AND FROM IT CAME TO OUR
ATTENTION THAT THE BIASED
REQUIREMENT WOULD NO LONGER. IN
THE STATUTE- WE HAD A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE OTHER
TOPIC. AND IT BECAME. I PARENTS
THAT AB NINETY FROM YEAR. I
DIDN'T STRUCK OUT THAT PORTION
OF THE LAW. THAT WE UNDERSTAND
THAT IT WAS NOT THE INTENTION OF
AB TEN NINETY SIX AND HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE DOCTOR'S OFFICE
TO REMEDY THIS ISSUE. AT ITS
UNTIMELY UNNECESSARY BILL AS
OPPOSED IS AT DEVELOPING THE
BIAS REQUIREMENTS THROUGH OUR
REGULATORY PROCESS. AND THAT
SURE THE BIAS REQUIREMENTS ARE
ENACTED BY THE LEGISLATURE IN
EIGHTY EIGHT ARTISTIC. ARE
IMPLEMENTED AND URGENCY
STATUTORY. IS NECESSARY.
ACCORDINGLY THIS BILL AG
CONTAINED THE URGENCY BECAUSE TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY I THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR HER COMMITMENT TO
REENACT THIS PORTION OF THE LOT.
THAT HAD ALREADY BEEN VETTED BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED INTO
LAW. BY THE GOVERNOR AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER. ANY QUESTIONS
IF NEEDED. THANK YOU. IT'S NOT
GOING TO RUMORED ANY ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. WE'LL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT NAME OF. WE TAKE YOUR
AND SUPPORTS WE WILL WITNESS IN
A ROLE IN SUPPORTING NINE. I'M
SORRY MARCO GEORGE ON HALF THE
HALF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DISSENT VENDOR'S ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW
YOU CAN GO TO THE PHONE LINE.
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
NINE IT IS ONE ZERO. IT'S ONE
NINE ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. AND WE
DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY QUEUING UP
MR CARE. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ME WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. HEARING NONE IN ROME
WE GOT RID OF PHONE LINES INTO
WITNESSES OPPOSITION. YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY NINE ONE NINE ZERO. THE
OPPOSITION THE ONE BAND THERE ON
YOUR PHONE. THEN WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYBODY KILLING UP THE CIRCULAR
THANK YOU- BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS CONCERNS
COMMENTS MISTER BRYANT I DON'T
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR ALL OF HER
THOUGHTFUL WORK I AM VERY MUCH
LOOKING FORWARD TO SUPPORTING
THIS BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE OTHER YOU MAY CLOSE VERY
SPECTRALLY ASK FOR AND I'VE BEEN
HERE IN THE CHAIRS RECOMMENDED
I. CALL THE ROLL. ON AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY NINE BASS A MEMBER
THREE OF US THE MOTION IS TO
PASS JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER
IRAQI LACKEY HI BONTA. BRIAN
BRIAN I WORK HARD WORK I SAN
DIEGO SAN I SEYARTO. C. R.
TURNOUT VOTING. THE MEASURE
PASSES THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
I THINK WE HAVE MISTER SMITH AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY FIVE- I DO NOT
SEE IN THE ROOM. OKAY THEN. IS A
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS RIGHT
NOW. SO I.
THE BILL THE SECOND. I HAVE TO
BILL. AB TWENTY ONE NINETY FIVE
DRUG OFFENSE ALTERNATIVE PLEASE. THE BILL. YOU'RE LOOKING THE
BILL. YOU CAN READ IT FIRST.
VACANCY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY FIVE WHICH
WILL PROTECT CALIFORNIANS FROM
THE LASTING COLLATERAL
CONSEQUENCES OF DRUG CONVICTIONS
DRUG OFFENSES ACCOUNT FOR A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
CONVICTIONS AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
THESE CONVICTIONS CAN
DESTABILIZE SOMEONE'S LIFE BY
BLOCKING ACCESS TO ESSENTIAL
RESOURCES SUCH AS HOUSING
OBTAINING PROFESSIONAL LICENSES
AND COULD JEOPARDIZE PARENTAL
RIGHTS. FOR CALIFORNIA'S LARGE
UNDOCUMENTED POPULATION DRUG
CONVICTIONS CAN HAVE DEVASTATING
CONSEQUENCES THAT CAN LEAD TO
THE PERMANENT SEPARATION OF
FAMILIES LOW LEVEL CONVICTIONS
LIKE INFRACTIONS OR MISDEMEANORS
POSSESSION CAN SUBJECT
NONCITIZEN TO MANDATORY ICE
DETENTION WITH NO POSSIBILITY OF
RELEASE ON BOND THERE ARE IN A
BASIS OF FORTY PART DEPORTATION
M. BAR TO MOST FORMS OF
IMMIGRATION RELIEF AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE SUPREME COURT
OPINION AND PARADE PRETA VERSES
BILL CLINTON- WORSENED THE
SITUATION FOR IMMIGRANTS BY
ELIMINATED ALASKA GRATION
NEUTRAL PLEAT OPTION. FOR A DRUG
CHARGE IN CRIMINAL PROCEEDINGS
THIS WEEK'S NONCITIZEN
DEFENDANTS FACING POSSIBLE DRUG
CONVICTIONS WITH NO REAL
ALTERNATIVE DEFENSE IN A
CRIMINAL COURT TO AVOID
DEPORTATION PROSECUTORS HAVE NO
REALISTIC OPTIONS EVEN WHEN IN
EVEN WHEN IN THEIR OWN
PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT THEY
BELIEVE THE BEST RESULT WOULD BE
TO AVOID IMMIGRATION OR OTHER
COLLATERAL CONSEQUENCES IN A
SPECIFIC CASE AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY FIVE CREATES AN
ALTERNATIVE PLEA FOR THOSE
CHARGES WERE SPECIFIED DRUG.
OFFENSES WHILE MAINTAINING THE
SAME EXPOSURE TO CRIMINAL
PENALTIES UNDER THIS LAW
PROSECUTORS WILL HAVE DISCRETION
TO OFFERED THIS ALTERNATIVE PLEA
ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS AND ONLY
AT THE REQUEST OF THE DEFENSE
COUNSEL DESPITE AND EFFICIENT AN
APPROPRIATE MECHANISM TO VOTE.
TO PROTECT IMMIGRANTS AND OTHER
STATE. RESIDENTS FROM FACING
DRUG CONVICTIONS AND SO OFFERING
LIFELONG. THIS BILL WILL
PRESERVE COURT RESOURCES AND
KEEP COURTS RUNNING EFFICIENTLY
BY ALLOWING THE EARLY RESOLUTION
OF SPECIFIC DRUG CASES HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT R. CARLOS GOMEZ
WITH IMMIGRANT RESOURCE CENTER A
CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL. AND GET
A REMOTE BOOSTERS WHO WILL SHARE
HIS PERSONAL EXPERIENCE. THANK
YOU BASICALLY SAID WHAT I WAS
GONNA SAY- THE GOOD MORNING-
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS- MY NAME
IS CARLA GOMEZ AND I'M A SENIOR
STAFF ATTORNEY AT THE IMMIGRANT
LEGAL RESOURCE CENTER A PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
FIVE- PRIOR TO JOINING THE ILRC
I WAS A PUBLIC DEFENDER FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS- AND IN THAT
CAPACITY I ALSO SERVED AS THAT.
DEPORTATION DEFENSE ATTORNEY AND
I FOCUSED ON DETAINED WORK. SO I
REALLY HAVE SEEN FIRST HAND THE
DEVASTATING A FAX OF. CRIMINAL
CONVICTIONS EVEN MINOR DRUG
CONVICTIONS LIKE MINOR- DRUG
CONVICTIONS FOR PERSONAL USE-
HAVE ON BOTH OUR CITIZENS AND
OUR NON CITIZENS I AM. SO AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY FIVE BASICALLY
SETS OUT TO PROVIDE A SOLUTION
TO BOTH. SO AS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER ALREADY ELOQUENTLY
STATED FOR I WERE NONCITIZENS-
SORRY FOR OUR CITIZENS DRUG
CONVICTIONS CAN LEAD TO LOSS OF
HOUSING- AND EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES SO FOR EXAMPLE
MANY OF MY YOUNG CLIENTS OF
COLOR AFTER THEY SUFFERED A DRUG
CONVICTION- THEY WERE HOMELESS
THEY BECAME HOMELESS BECAUSE
THEY COULDN'T RETURN BACK TO.
THEIR FOR THEIR FAMILY THAT
LIVED IN SECTION EIGHT HOUSING
AND- FOR THOSE CLIENTS HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN ABLE TO
REHABILITATE AND YEARS LATER
WANT TO OBTAIN SOME SORT OF A
LICENSING LIKE AT A NURSING
LICENSE FOR EXAMPLE THEY'RE ABLE
TO DO SO. AND THEY CANNOT EVEN
BECOME IN HOME CARE PROVIDERS IF
THEY WANT TO TAKE CARE OF
SOMEONE LIKE A LOVED ONE IN
THEIR FAMILY. SO FOR NONCITIZENS
DAY AND THAT THE CONSEQUENCES
ARE FAR WORSE. OF FOR OUR
NONCITIZEN CLIENTS INCLUDING
INCLUDING LAWFUL PERMANENT
RESIDENTS A DRUG CONVICTION
LEADS TO MANDATORY ICE DETENTION
. SO THAT MEANS THAT A JUDGE
DOESN'T HAVE DISCRETION TO SET A
BOND. LEADS TO DEPORTATION. AND
THE INABILITY TO ADJUST TO
STATUS SO THAT MEANS THAT IF
SOMEONE IS MARRIED TO A US
CITIZEN OR HAVE US CITIZEN
CHILDREN THEY CANNOT OBTAIN A
GREEN CARD. AND IN THE NINTH
CIRCUIT WE HAD A LOT LAST KIND
OF LINE OF DEFENSE AND IF WE
DIDN'T NAME THE CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE- WE COULD AVOID THE
CONVICTION THE DRUG CONVICTION
FOR IMMIGRATION PURPOSES.
UNFORTUNATELY LAST YEAR THE
SUPREME COURT AND PRAY THAT THE
WILKINSON OVERTURNED THIS LAST
LINE OF DEFENSE. SO WE CANNOT WE
CAN'T DO THAT AND WE DON'T HAVE
MANY PTIONS ANYMORE. SO AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY FIVE PROVIDES
A REASONABLE ALTERNATIVE THAT
PROSECUTORS CAN OFFER IN LIEU OF
A OF A DRUG OFFENSE. AND THIS
BILL IS NOT A GET OUT OF JAIL
FREE CARD AT ALL. THROUGH THIS
MEASURE PROSECUTORS THE
PROSECUTORS WILL HAVE THE
DISCRETION TO EVALUATE EACH CASE
INDIVIDUALLY. TO DETERMINE
WHETHER AN ALTERNATE PLEA WOULD
SERVE THE INTERESTS OF JUSTICE.
NOW HAVING- HAVING TROUBLE LIKE
ALL THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES
AB SORRY ALL OF OUR CALIFORNIA I
ACTUALLY WOULD GO TO ALL THE
I'VE BEEN TO LIKE OVER TEN
DIFFERENT COUNTIES IN IN
CALIFORNIA TO NEGOTIATE CASES
FROM MY NONCITIZEN CLIENTS AND
WHAT I FOUND IS THAT EVEN IN THE
MOST CONSERVATIVE JURISDICTIONS
. EXECUTORS ARE OPEN AND THEY
WANT TO SERVE JUSTICE SO THEY
THEY ARE THEY DO NOT WANT AN
INDIVIDUAL- TO BE PERMANENTLY
SEPARATED FROM THEIR FAMILY-
AND- NOT YOU KNOW BE BANISHED IN
THE UNITED STATES FOR LIFE
BECAUSE OF A RELATIVELY MINOR
DRUG CONVICTION. SO THIS REALLY
IS A WIN WIN- IT WILL AVOID
COSTLY TRIALS AND DRAGGED OUT
COURT PROCEEDINGS- THE
PROSECUTOR CAN OFFER THIS PLEA-
WITHIN THE FIRST OR SECOND
CALLING ON THE CASE. AND LASTLY.
I JUST WANNA SAY THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS ALWAYS BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT. OF BOTH JUSTICE AND
IMMIGRATION REFORM WEREALLY ARE
IN A IN A CRITICAL MOMENT AND WE
NEED CALIFORNIA TO LEAD. THIS IS
AN EFFECTIVE SOLUTION TO CURTAIL
THE WORST REMNANTS OF THE WAR ON
DRUGS- I REALLY WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- JONES SAWYER
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP. AND FOR
REALIZING AND SEEING THAT THIS
IS A BROADER ISSUE THAN JUST
IMMIGRATION DRUG CONSEQUENCES-
THE COLLATERAL CONSEQUENCES OF
DRUG CONVICTIONS AFFECT ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES SO I URGE
EVERYONE HERE TO- VOTE IF I IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
FIVE. OKAY THANK YOU ANYBODY
ELSE WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. IN THE
ROOM. MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONLY C.
LEWIS ON BEHALF THE DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE A PROUD CO SPONSOR OF
THE BILL IN SUPPORT AS WELL AS
ON BEHALF OF OUR COLLEAGUES ARE
CO SPONSORS WELCOME INITIATE
JUSTICE. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
GOING BACK IS RELEVANT- CENTER
IN SUPPORT I WAS ASKED TO READ
THESE ORGANIZATION NAMES INTO
THE RECORD PLEASE. ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
SMART JUSTICE CALIFORNIA. ROUTE
REBOUND. A NEW PATH MOMS UNITED
TO END THE DRUG WAR.
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE YOUNG WOMAN'S FREEDOM
CENTER SISTER WARRIORS FREEDOM
COALITION AND CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. EIGHT I'M JAN
LEWIS ON BEHALF OF MYSELF I
SUPPORT THIS. THANK YOU. K. A.
T. AND T. OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO- WAITING ON THE PHONES
THAT WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY ONE NINETY FIVE
THAT IS ONE ZERO. IN SUPPORT.
ONE SEVEN ZERO. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY THREE. OKAY
WANAQUE HERE. ONE ERIC LINE
EIGHTY THREE. GOOD MORNING
REBEKAH INVOLVED WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JOHNNY PENA ON BEHALF OF
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS CHIRLA COLLEEN
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
ONE NINETY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. HI THIS IS GRETCHEN BURNS
BERGMAN GOOD MORNING- I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF FOUNDER OF
THE NEW PASTOR INTERDICTION
TREATMENT HEARING AND LEAD
ORGANIZER PROBLEMS UNITED AND
THE WAR ON DRUGS. IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWO ONE NINE FIVE.
YOU IT. THANK YOU AND IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY FIVE IT IS ONE NINE ZERO
. AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY
QUEUING UP FOR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. THIS I DON'T SEE ANY
. NOBODY IN THE ROOM ONE EXPRESS
THEIR OPPOSITION. AND NONE
THERE'S WELL WE'LL GO TO THE
OPERATOR ONCE AGAIN ANYBODY THAT
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY FIVE THIS IS THEIR CHANCE
. YOUR OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
ONE NINETY FIVE IT IS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE NUMBER WELL THANK.
YOU PUSHED ONE ZERO JUST A ONE
TIME OTHERWISE OKAY TO STOP BY
TO Q. FOUR ONE NINE ZERO. WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYBODY QUEUING UP AND
SEARCHING. THANK YOU. OKAY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANYWAY WOULD
LIKE TO. ADDRESS THE OTHER. YOUR
TO CLOSER I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. HEY WILL CALL FOR
REVOLUTION SOCCER. I THINK WE DO
OKAY THAT'S COUPLE QUESTIONS
PLEASE. AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
FIVE BASE A MEMBER JONES SAWYER
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SAWYER JONES SAWYER IRAQI VOTING
LACKEY NOT VOTING BONTA. BRIAN
BRIAN I WORK I WORK I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I SEYARTO SEYARTO NO.
ONE THE MEASURES ON COLLEGE ONE
THANK YOU MEG GO TO A LIVE MAY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY ONE YES SIR.
THE I THANK YOU MEMBERS ARE
PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY
ONE WITH QUITE THAT THE BRIEF
PERIOD MINERS IN JUVENILE
FACILITIES ARE ALLOWED TO BE
LOCKED IN A ROOM FOR
INSTITUTIONAL OPERATIONS IS NO
LONGER THAN ONE HOUR AS WELL AS
YOUR MINERS AND WARDS HAVE
ADEQUATE ACCESS TO TOILETS.
FIRST AND FOREMOST I WOULD LIKE
TO SET THE RECORD STRAIGHT. THIS
BILL DOES NOT CAP THE TIME LIMIT
FROM ROOM CONFINEMENT USED IN
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS OR WHEN
STAFF AND OTHER MINERS FACE
SECURITY THREATS AS EVIDENCE IN
THIS BILL RETAINING EXISTING
STATUTES. AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY
ONE MERELY SEEKS TO REMOVE
AMBIGUITY AN EXISTING STATUTE
THAT ALLOWS FOR MINORS TO BE
LEFT IN A LOCKED ROOM WHEN
NECESSARY FOR INSTITUTIONAL
OPERATIONS. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AN ATTORNEY GENERAL
INVESTIGATION OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY JUVENILE FACILITIES FOUND
INSTANCES OF MINORS BEING HELD
IN ISOLATION WITHOUT DOCUMENTED
BECAUSE FOR UPWARDS OF MULTIPLE
DAYS. UNFORTUNATELY SUBSEQUENT
REPORTS HAVE UNCOVERED SIMILAR
ABUSE. AS RECENT AS FEBRUARY
THIRD OF THIS YEAR A MINOR IN L.
A. COUNTY CENTRAL JUVENILE HALL
WAS UNNECESSARILY PLACED IN A
ROOM CONFINEMENT. FOR ELEVEN
DAYS UNDER THE PRETENSE OF
MEDICAL ISOLATION. DESPITE STAFF
BEING MADE AWARE OF THIS ERROR
THE MINOR WAS STILL LEFT LOCKED
IN A ROOM FOR NEARLY AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY TWO HOURS. TO
MAKE MATTERS WORSE A FOLLOW UP
INSPECTION MEANT TO ENSURE ABUSE
IT HAD BEEN RESOLVED FIVE NEW
CASES THAT VIOLATED THIS ROOM
CONFINEMENT STATUTE TRIGGERING
AN ADDITIONAL INSPECTION. YET L.
A. COUNTY PROBATION STAFF
ASSERTED THAT INSTANCES OF
MINORS LOCKED IN ROOMS HAD NOT
BEEN DOCUMENTED BECAUSE THEY
FELL WITHIN THE EXEMPTED BRIEF
PERIODS OF TIME. HOWEVER IN
SPITE OF THE THEIR CLAIMS WOULD
DETERMINE THAT MANY OF THESE
INSTANCES COULD NOT BE
CHARACTERIZED AS BRIEF PERIODS
OF TIME NOR IS NECESSARY FOR
INSTITUTIONAL OPERATION.
CONSEQUENTLY VIOLATING EXISTING
LAW. FURTHER WORSENING ABUSES
MINORS IN THE HALLS HAVE SHARED
HER EXPERIENCE OF HOARDING EMPTY
MILK CARTONS AND EVEN STERILE
GLOVES TO URINATE IN BECAUSE
THEY DID NOT HAVE A TOILET AND
HAD NOT BEEN ALLOWED OUT OF
THEIR ROOM. SOME MINERS EVEN
REPORTED HAVING TO USE THEIR
TOWERS TO RELIEVE THEMSELVES
WHICH IN TURN LEFT THEIR ROOM
SMELLING OF COURT ORDER. MEMBERS
REALLY LET'S BE FRANK. THERE ARE
THESE ARE SUB HUMAN UNSANITARY
AND DEMORALIZING CONDITIONS MY
BILL AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY ONE
SIX TO SAFEGUARD MINERS HEALTH
SAFETY AND DIGNITY BY ENSURING
THEY ARE NOT LOCKED IN YOUR
ROOMS FOR ON WANTED. I'M
WARRANTED PRO LONG PERIODS OF
TIME AND BY ENSURING THEY HAVE
ADEQUATE ACCESS TO USED THE
TOILET WITH ME TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND SHARE
HIS OWN LIVED EXPERIENCE ON THIS
ISSUE. IS K. ONE MAKE CABINS ON
BEHALF. OF INITIATE JUSTICE.
OKAY WITNESS YOU MAY PROCEED K.
ONE. HELLO GOOD MORNING SHERRY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS KEY WHILE MCCANN. POLICY
ADVOCATE FOR THE WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION I'M TWENTY
TWO YEARS OLD AND NOT LOOKING
CAR STRAIGHT WHEN I WAS SIXTEEN
AND THEY DO NOT DO IT TO THE FOR
PARKS WITH FIVE YEARS. OPRY
SHAPE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
AT THE PORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY ONE. WALDRON KARCHER TO
ASBURY DAY NOT OFF THE COMPOUND
FOR THREE YEARS. I WENT WITH ALL
THE TOLD AND THOUGHT TO MYSELF
WHICH WAS TRAUMATIZED. WHEN
THERE WERE SAFETY REASONS KIDS
TO BE AN EXCEL I'LL HAVE THE
YELLOW OR DO WHATEVER I COULD TO
LET THE HOUSE EVEN IF STAFF NO I
NEEDED TO USE THE PRESSURE. ON
CALIFICACIONES I REMEMBER BEING
TOLD BY THE STAFF TO DO THE
LATEX GLOVE WHICH IS SIMILAR TO
THE MILL CARNATION INDUSTRY TO
DO KNOW HALL. INSTEAD OF BEING
PROVIDE ACCESS TO A COLD. I FIND
I COULDN'T USE THE RESTROOM
BECAUSE OF THE LONG WAIT IN
LINE. ALL ON OCCASION I NEEDED
TO USE THE RATIONAL SIDE KNOCKED
ON MY CELL DOOR FOR ABOUT THIRTY
MINUTES. AFTER THIRTY MINUTES
WITH NO RESPONSE I COULDN'T HOLD
IT ANY LONGER FILE NEARLY
GRABBED A LATEX GLOVE BY CAPTAIN
THEY'LL PUT MEDICINES. I BELIEVE
MYSELF OF YOUR INSIDE OF THE
SCHOOL. A LOT OF TIME TO GLOAT
IT POP YARN SPLASHED ALL OVER MY
FILLED FLOOR. THE ONLY THING I
HAD TO USE TO CLEAN UP THIS MESS
WITH THE CLOTHES I HAD ON. ALL I
ALSO STILL GOING TO LEAVE MYSELF
ARE HAD TO GO TO SLEEP AND WAIT
UNTIL THE MORNING CRACKING.
CLEAN UP TO YOUR CURRENT THAT
WITHIN MYSELF. THE HOLLYWOOD
COMPLACENT. RIGHT YEAH SO MANY
OTHER KIDS NOW GONE THROUGH THIS
IN OUR CAR GOING THIS NOW AT
THIS MOMENT BOTH. WHEN YOU ARE
HOME AND GET A TO GO TO. PLEASE
THINK THE KIDS AND YOU KNOW HALL
CAME. PLEASE TAKE A WILL WHICH
DO IF YOU TO WAIT THIRTY MINUTES
FOR OUR JUST TO THE REST. HOW
WOULD YOU RESPOND. AS TWENTY
THREE TWENTY ONE. MORE FOR YOU
AT LEAST THE- THAT BRIEF PERIOD
OF TIME THAT MONIES CAN BE
COOPER. IN THERE WILL I KNOW
THAN ONE HOUR. AS AS THE SWORD
MONICA. AND HAVE ACCESS TO
TOILETS ALL TALK. ESPECIALLY
THOSE WITH BALLOT AND A- YOU CAN
CALL RACING THIS IS. TO
EXPERIENCE IN MOST ARE YOU ARE
BEING OFFERED CHAU IF FOR CARE
SUPPORTS REHABILITATION. THAT
WILL CREATE. WE WANT YOU TO COME
HOME BY ABOUT THE FUTURE SHOULD
TRYING TO HER COLLEAGUES FOR.
AND NOT TO BE ON THE- NOT TO BE
ON. H. FOR BOB IN THE CAR
JUSTICE SYSTEM. THERE G. MAIL
CARDS. AT TO DO THE EFFORT THAT
REASON I RICH TO FOR TODAY AB.
TWO TWENTY TWO TWENTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR ANY OTHER IN
SUPPORT. YOU MAY STEP UP AND
EXPRESSED THAT SUPPORT. MARCO
GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEFENDER SYSTEM AND
STRAW SO. IT GOING BACK HIS
FELLOW BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS IN SUPPORT. Q. AT&T
OPERATOR. MAY YOU-SOLICIT THOSE
WHO WISH TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT. FOR AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY ONE. YOUR AND SUPPORT
TICKETS ONE NINE ZERO. EDIT IN
SUPPORT ONE NINE ZERO AND WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE CONTACT. BY NUMBER EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINER OPEN. GOOD
MORNING REBECCA GONZALEZ OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE
ONE MORE QUEUING APPEAR TO BE
JUST ONE MOMENT. IN SUPPORT ONE
NINE ZERO NO WE WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
GREGORY FIDEL ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
WE DO HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. WE
WILL GO TO NINE NUMBER NINETY
THREE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN HI MY
NAME. HI MY NAME MIGUEL GARCIA
WITH ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
CALLING SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY MORE IN SUPPORT ON
THE LINE. OKAY THANK YOU DO YOU
HAVE ANY WITNESSES THAT WOULD
LIKE TO- TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL. F. FIVE MINUTES
AGO FOR- MISTER CHAIRMAN REYES
MATTHEW STYLING THAT WE HAVE THE
LOS ANGELES PROBATION OFFICERS
UNION HOSPITAL SIX EIGHTY FIVE-
KNOWLEDGE AND THANK THE AUTHOR
AND I WAS STAFF HAS BEEN
GENEROUS WITH THEIR TIME
SPEAKING WITH US HELPING CLARIFY
THE BILL. WE DO ACKNOWLEDGE.
THAT THE OUR TOOL ROOM
CONFINEMENT THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING HERE IS NOT THE TOOL
THAT WERE USED TO USING OR
DISCUSSING OR TALKING ABOUT
INCIDENTS. MORE OR ALLOWING FOR
COOLING OFF TIME ALLOWING FOR-
ORDER TO BE RESTORED- IN OUR
FACILITIES THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AND WE'RE TRYING TO
CLARIFY WITH THE AUTHOR HIS
pIS- THE AMOUNT OF TIME FOR
INSTITUTIONALIZED SHINS FOR. OUR
STAFF TO MAINTAIN ORDER WITHIN
THE FACILITIES- ON A DAILY BASIS
SO TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK. BYE BYE SUBMITTED A
LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE THAT
DETAILED ABOUT A DOZEN OR MORE
DIFFERENT TRANSITIONS THAT TAKE
PLACE THROUGHOUT THE DAY FROM
FROM WAKING TO SHOWERING TO
EATING BREAKFAST TO GOING TO
SCHOOL TO EXERCISE. I'M IN EACH
IN EACH ONE OF THESE
TRANSITIONS. ARE STOP
RESPONSIBLE AGAIN FOR- FOR
MEDIUM SIZED GROUPS OF PEOPLE
MAKING SURE THAT THEY GET FROM
POINT A TO POINT B. AND THEY CAN
SURE THAT EVERYONE IS SAFE AND
IT'S A PEACEFUL ENVIRONMENT-
ROOM CONFINEMENT IS USED DURING
THIS THESE PERIODS OF TIME
OCCASIONALLY WHEN NECESSARY- WE
KNOW THAT THE CURRENT LAW SAYS
FOR. A REASONABLE AMOUNT OF TIME
OR BRIEF AMOUNT OF TIME- THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD TO TRY TO
AMEND THAT TO ONE HOUR OUR
STAFF. AS EXPLAINS TO US THAT IN
MOST CASES IN OUR BE SUFFICIENT
BUT THERE ARE GOING TO BE TIMES
WHEN THE OUR- WON'T BE
SUFFICIENT JUST BASED ON STAFF
CHANGES. NOT SHIFT CHANGES. OR
AGAIN GENERAL TENSION BETWEEN
GROUPS THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
WE KEEP APART FROM EACH OTHER AS
AS WE'RE MOVING THROUGHOUT OUR
DAY I'M SO AS THIS BILL MOVES ON
WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
YOU MISTER CHAIR. AND YOUR STAFF
IN YOUR SPONSORS AND MAKE SURE
THAT AGAIN OUR OUR STAFF HAS THE
TOOLS THAT THEY NEED A TO
MAINTAIN ORDER AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYONE IN THE FACILITY
OKAY. I'M AND ONE MORE ISSUE AND
ALL HEAD OVER THE SURPLUS- OF.
ON. ON THE SECOND PART OF THE
BILL WHICH IS EQUALLY IMPORTANT
TO THREE. ACCESS TOY AND REST
FACILITY- THE UNION TAKEN INTO.
THEMSELVES TO APPROACH. EACH
SUBCOMMITTEE WITHIN THAT THE
STATE LEGISLATURE TO REQUEST. A
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
AUGMENTATION FOR FACILITY
UPGRADES IN THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES SPECIFICALLY. OF OUR
FACILITIES IN SOME CASES ARE
OVER A HUNDRED YEARS OLD. A WEEK
KNOWLEDGE THAT WE'RE WE'RE DOING
THE BEST WITH WHAT WE CAN BUT
THE UNION. IS DOING EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO COMMUNICATE TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE POLICY MAKERS
UP HERE. OTHER THE TIME. IS IT
HAS ARRIVED IF IT'S NOT LONG
OVERDUE. TO MAKE THOSE FACILITY
UPGRADES AND TOILETS. IN EACH
INDIVIDUAL. LIVING UNIT. IS
BASICALLY THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE
THAT WE SEE THAT. WE ARE WE HAVE
NO WORKAROUND. A WITHOUT A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN THAT.
THANK YOU. CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS WHAT
THE PLOT ON BEHALF OF ASKED ME.
SANTA CLARA PROBATION OFFICES OF
LOCAL FIFTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN. AND
WE WILL ALSO- ASSOCIATE OUR
REMARKS WITH- MY COLLIE. AND
JUST SAY THAT- WE LIKE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE ART AS
WE MOVE THE BILL FORWARD. TO
MAKE SURE WE CAN ADDRESS THE
ISSUE THAT- MATT HAS LAID OUT
AND WE THINK THAT ONE I WILL A
TO ALWAYS MAKE THE DIFFERENCE
IN. KEEPING THEIR INSTITUTIONS
SAFE THE KIDS SAFE. IN
ADDRESSING SOME OF THIS SYSTEMIC
PROBLEM THAT THE CHAIRMAN OF
LAID OUT SO WE ASK FOR YOUR-
CONCERN THAT WE CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER. THANK YOU AT THE GYM.
OKAY THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY
ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION WITHIN THE ROOM. I
SEE NINE. AT&T OPERATOR IF WE
HAVE ANYBODY ON THE PHONES OR
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
NOW IS OUR OPPORTUNITY. YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION IT IS ONE NINE
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. ONE NINE
ZERO FOUR OPPOSITION. AND WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYBODY QUEUING UP FOR
OPPOSITION. YEAH COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. LIKE YOU HAVE NO ONE
ELSE WANTS TO TALK IT'S A- THREE
TO CLOSER. IN THANK YOU AND I
AND I TO WANT TO CONTINUE TO
WORK- WITH THE UNIT BECAUSE IT
THERE THERE'S SOME CONDITIONS
WITHIN- JUVENILE FACILITIES THAT
NO CHILD SHOULD BE. SUBJECTED
TO. A DEGREE WORK IN A
COOPERATIVE MANNER WE CAN GET
THERE- THERE'S SOME REAL REAL
SERIOUS- SITUATIONS ALLEN
QUALITIES OF A STATE CHALLENGING
SITUATIONS WHICH HAVE RESULTED
IN HUMANE CONDITIONS FOR YOU.
AND WE SHOULD BE FOCUSED IN ON
THAT. IT MAKING SURE WE GET RID
OF THAT NINETY THIS IS THE FIRST
STEP IN THAT AND WHAT I'M ASKING
JUST AS A AS A AS THIS IS A
FLOOR FOR CONFINEMENT IS A WE
MEET THIS LEGISLATURE AND IN THE
PUBLIC AT LARGE NEED TO KNOW.
WHEN YOU COMBINE A YOUNG PERSON-
WOULD YOU DO THE SAME THING TO
YOUR OWN CHILDREN WOULD YOU KEEP
THEM FROM BEING ABLE TO GO TO
THE BATHROOM WOULD YOU KEEP
THEM. FROM HAVING IN HUMANE
CONDITIONS WE'LL LET HIM URINATE
ON THEMSELVES REGION COURAGEOUS
SITUATION THE ANSWER WOULD BE NO
. AND SO WHY WOULD YOU DO. DO
THESE INCARCERATED KIDS WICH
YOU WOULDN'T DOTO YOUR OWN KIDS
AND SO I THINK THAT WOULD BE. MY
FOR ALL WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO
HAPPEN- IN IN THIS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. OKAY THANK YOU TO OUR
MOTION. THE BILL. OKAY WE HAVE
MOTION SECOND PLEASE CALL FOR
QUESTIONS. ON AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY ONE BY SEVEN MEMBER JONES
SAWYER THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER IRAQI
LACKEY I BONTA. BONTA HI BRIAN.
BRIAN HI QUIRK. I WORK I
SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO ICE THEY ARE
TO THEY ARE TAUGHT BY THAT
MEASURE. THE. ONE HUNDRED. YEAH. GOOD TO HAVE A LOT. ONE BURKE
BUT LAST ITEM- ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY FIVE SMITH. A
PEACE OFFICER STOPS YOU MAY
BEGIN MISTER SMITH ABLE TO MOVE
THE MAIL FIVE. MISTER CHAIRED
MEMBERS TODAY I'M HERE IT IS
PRESENT AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
FIVE. THE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
LEGISLATION WAS PASSED THAT
REQUIRED LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO REPORT DATA ON ALL
STOPS WHERE THE PEACE OFFICERS
CONDUCTED A SEARCH OF A PERSON'S
BODY OR PROPERTY. THERE SEVEN
CATEGORIES OF DATA LOOTING THE
PERSON'S PERCEIVED RACE GENDER
AND AGE. THESE REPORTS THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS WERE
ENACTED TO AND ANALYZE WHY RICK
RACIAL PROFILING OCCURS IN ALL
ULTIMATELY TRY TO ELIMINATE THEM
. HOWEVER THESE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TAKE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF TIME OF THE OFFICERS
TIME DIMINISHING HOW MUCH TIME
THEY CAN BE SPENT INTERACTING
WITH THE COMMUNITY AND DOING
PROACTIVE POLICING. THIS BILL
WILL CLARIFY WHEN A PEACE
OFFICER IS DISPATCHED TO A CALL
FOR SERVICE OR MEDICAL
EMERGENCY. THE PEACE OFFICERS
NOT REQUIRED TO PERFORM THESE
REPORTING OBLIGATIONS. I BELIEVE
THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE ACTION
CONSIDERING THAT UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OFFICERS NOT
INITIATING TO STOP. AND
THEREFORE IS LESS LIKELY TO HAVE
A BIAS TOWARD THE SUBJECT OF THE
CALL OF SERVICE. LET'S MAKE SURE
THAT OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS TIME IS USED
EFFICIENTLY AND THEY'RE ABLE TO
BE OUT IN OURCOMMUNITY TO KEEP
THE PUBLIC SAFE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE IN I DO
HAVE SHARE OF DOCTORS AS MY
WITNESS THANK YOU. OPERATE YOUR
FERTILIZER CAN HEAR FROM THE
SHARE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. STOP THIS INITIATED
BY A DISPATCHER CALL FOR SERVICE
FOR A MEDICAL EMERGENCY BY
DEFINITION IS NOT OFFICER
INITIATED. THAT SUCH CONCERNS
ABOUT RACIAL PROFILING OR
IMPLICIT BIAS ARE NOT PARTICULAR
TO THE OFFICER ANSWERING THE
CALL. THE RECORD KEEPING
REQUIREMENTS. OF EXISTING LAW
ARE BURDENSOME RELIEVING LAW
ENFORCEMENT OF THE DUTY TO
DOCUMENT THIS INFORMATION WHEN
THE STOP WAS NOT OPTION THIS
YEAR IT MAKES SENSE AND WILL
FREE OFFICERS TO DO MORE
IMPORTANT DUTIES. IN SAMBAR DINO
COUNTY. SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
AND EIGHTY OF THESE CALLS WERE
HANDLED IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THIS EQUATES TO THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY FOUR HOURS OF LOS SERVICE.
TO OUR CITIZENS WHEN FILLING OUT
THESE REFORMS RELATED TO THESE
TYPES OF CALLS. BY REQUIRING
OFFICERS TO REPORT WHAT IS
PERCEIVED TO BE SOMEONE'S RACE
ETHNICITY GENDER SIX CETERA. AB
NINE FIFTY THREE IS ACTUALLY
ASKING COPS THE PROFILE IT IS
NOT PRUDENT THEREFORE TO MAKE
CALLS FOR SERVICE AS PART OF
RIVER REPORTING MY LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL ARE SIMPLY
RESPONDING TO A CALL FOR.
ASSISTANCE THEY ARE NOT
INITIATING IN CONTACT STOP FOR
ASSISTANCE. IN ADDITION ANY
STOPS MADE BY POLICE DURING A
CALL FOR SERVICE OUR REGULAR
PRECEDED BY DESCRIPTION GIVEN TO
DISPATCH THEREFORE ANY REPORTING
ON STOP RATES. FOR THESE TYPES
OF STOCKS IS SKEWED IN ITS
ANALYSIS OR COMPARISON. FOR
THESE REASONS. I SUPPORT AB
ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN EVERY
QUESTION I RECOMMENDATION TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE GO
TO ROOM ANY. MEMBERS OF PUBLIC.
SUPPORT AS CHAIR MEMBERS CORY
SAYS ONLY HALF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT. IF YOU'RE
INTO PORT PLEASE PRESS AND ONE
AND THEN ZERO. THERE'S NO ONE
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME. NOW GO
TO OPPOSITION. AT ADDRESSING
MARCO GEORGE MAKING HER WAY TO
THE. PROTIUM. MARCO GEORGE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE LATE
OPPOSITION WE GOT OUR LETTER IN
LATE AND I TRUST THAT THE MEMBER
GOT IT- BASICALLY IF IT'S NOT
BROKE DON'T FIX IT RIPA'S GOAL
IS TO PROMOTE EQUAL JUSTICE AND
FAIRNESS AND OUR POLICING SYSTEM
AND TO IMPROVE RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
AND THE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT IN
THE WAKE OF THE MURDER OF GEORGE
FLOYD IN MINNESOTA THE INITIAL
NON PROSECUTION OF AMMAN
HARBURY'S KILLERS AND GEORGIA.
KEDAR THESE GOALS AND CREATING A
UNIFORM SYSTEM FOR COLLECTING
AND REPORTING BASIC INFORMATION
ON HOW LAW ENFORCEMENT STOPS OF
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND THE
CONSEQUENCES OF SUCH STOPS. A
REGARDLESS OF HOW THEY WERE
INITIATED- A. B. TWO TWO EIGHT
FIVE SEEKS TO ELIMINATE EXCLUDED
CALLS EXTENDED CALLS. SO AND
EXCLUDING STOPS THAT RESULT FROM
A CALL FOR SERVICE AB TWO TWO
EIGHT FIVE WOULD UNDERMINE A
DELIBERATE DECISION BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE REP OF
BOARD TO INCLUDE THE STOPS IN
THE REGULATIONS. THE RIVER BOARD
AND ATTORNEY GENERAL MADE THE
DETERMINATION THAT SUCH A CAR
PICKUP WOULD BE INAPPROPRIATE
AND ILL ADVISED FINDING THAT
SUCH STOPS CONFORM TO THE
DEFINITION OF STOCK AS DEFINED
IN GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION.
TWELVE FIVE TWO TWO POINT FIVE.
THE REGULATION WHICH INCLUDED
EXTENDED CALLS ON WAS ACTUALLY-
WENT THROUGH THE NOTIFICATION
PROCESS IT WENT THROUGH THE
PUBLIC HEARING PROCESS AND EVERY
EVERY STAGE OF THOSE PROCEEDINGS
LAW ENFORCEMENT- A POST AT. BUT
IT WAS APPROVED AFTER THE PUBLIC
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAD THEIR
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK THE AGE SHE
HAD THEIR OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
AND THE REP OF BOARD MEMBERS
WERE ALL HEARD FROM IF THEY SO
DESIRED. THE INCLUSION OF CALLS
FOR SERVICE AND THE DATA IS
WORKING AND REVEALING. AS STATED
IN THE MOST RECENT REFERE PORT
CALLS FOR SERVICE ARE THE MOST
COMMON WAY IN WHICH LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS INITIATE
CONTACT WITH THE PUBLIC.
ANALYZING THESE INTERACTIONS CAN
THUS BE USEFUL IN UNDERSTANDING
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY
RELATIONSHIP. AND THE RIVER DATA
HAS ALREADY ON. OPEN THE DOOR ON
HARD TRUTHS THAT WERE LONG
SUSPECTED FOR EXAMPLE THE PUBLIC
POLICY OF INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA ANALYZED THE REP A
DATA ON UP TO I BELIEVE HIGH-
TWENTY TWENTY AND FOUND THAT
BLACK CALIFORNIANS ARE MORE THAN
TWICE AS LIKELY TO BE SEARCHED
AS WHITE CALIFORNIANS SEARCHES
OF BLACK CALIFORNIA'S LESS
LIKELY TO YIELD CONTRABAND OR
EVIDENCE AND SEARCHES OF WHITES
BLACK INDIVIDUALS ARE ALMOST
TWICE AS LIKELY TO BE BOOKED
INTO JAIL. AS WHITES. THE RIVER
BOARD EXAMINED THE DATA AND
NOTED IN THERE- TWENTY TWENTY
TWO REPORTED BELIEVE THAT OUR
CALLS FOR SERVICE BLACK
INDIVIDUALS WERE STOPPED. TWO
HUNDRED AND ELEVEN POINT EIGHT
PERCENT. TIMES MORE FREQUENTLY
THAN EXPECTED BASED ON THEIR
PROPORTION OF THE RESIDENTIAL
POPULATION MADE TWO HUNDRED AND
11% MORE. THAT'S WHAT THE DATA
FROM THE CALLS FOR SERVICE CHAU
RESULTED AND STOPS. YOU DON'T
HAVE TO LOOK AT A NEWSPAPER
HEADLINE TO SEE EXAMPLES OF
WHITE INDIVIDUALS CALLING THE
POLICE ON BLACK INDIVIDUALS- IN
MY HOMETOWN THERE'S BEEN A BIG
BARBECUE BECKY- AND CENTER IN
NEW YORK THERE WAS CENTRAL PARK
AMY AND CALLED THE POLICE. ON
THE BIRD WATCHER. AND THEN THERE
ARE THE EXAMPLES OF BLACK
INDIVIDUALS WHO CALLED THE
POLICE FOR SERVICES AND- WHEN I
WAS WORKING AS A PUBLIC DEFENDER
IN THE CITY OF ALAMEDA- I SAW.
ON A BLACK SAILOR WHO CAME IN IN
CUSTODY. IN HIS UNIFORM AND THE
JUDGE SAID WHAT ARE YOU DOING
HERE AND HE SAID WELL I WAS
ROBBED AND I CALLED THE POLICE
FOR HELP AND THEY ARRESTED ME
FOR TRAFFIC COURT. MY EXPERIENCE
IN ALAMEDA IS THAT A WHITE
SAILORS IN A SIMILAR. SITUATION
WHAT HAPPENED CITED. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE ON AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU UNDER
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN THE ROOM
IN OPPOSITION. WILL NOT GO TO
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR FOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. HELLO
YES WE HAVE LINE NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DILLON CALLING
FROM ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
RESPECTIVELY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO TWO EIGHT
FIVE. THANK YOU IN NINETY NINE
NINETY FIVE. HELLO THIS IS
MELANIE- CHIRLA HI THIS IS
MELANIE OSHA I AM ACTUALLY
CURRENTLY THE CO CHAIR OF THE
REPORT ALTHOUGH THE BOARD HAS
NOT YET FORMALLY TAKE A POSITION
ON THIS BILL I WANT TO VOICE MY
STRONG OPPOSITION. TO THE BILL
THANK YOU. AND AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK
YOU BRING ABOUT TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. RESPOND ON APRIL
NINETEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN
ALAMEDA MY CITY. WHERE I LIVE
AND IN A PLACE WHERE I WALK
ALMOST EVERY SINGLE DAY. A YOUNG
MAN BY THE NAME OF MONEY-
GONZALEZ. WAS KILLED AFTER
ENGAGEMENTS WITH THAT WHAT CAME
FROM A CALL FOR SERVICE- AT THE
HANDS OF POLICE. HAVING ANY KIND
OF SITUATION WHERE THE STATE.
ISN'T TRYING TO COLLECT THE DATA
. THAT ENSURES THAT WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT ALL%
SITUATIONS WHERE THERE IS
INTERACTIONS BETWEEN PUBLIC AND
PEACE OFFICERS. I WOULD BE DOING
A DISSERVICE. TWO PEOPLE TO
FAMILY MEMBERS. TO COMMUNITY
MEMBERS LOSE THEIR LIVES OR WHO
HAVE AT. NEGATIVE THE FAX WHEN
THEY COME INTO CONTACT WITH OUR
PEACE OFFICERS AND IT WOULD AND
IT ERODES OUR ABILITY AS
COMMUNITIES TO REALLY HAVE FULL
FAITH AND TRUST IN OUR PEACE
OFFICERS WHICH IS WHAT WE ALL
WANT. AND FOR THAT REASON I'M
GOING TO OPPOSE THIS. BILL. YES
I'D LIKE. O ASK A YES SIDE I
DON'T THINK THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME WE'VE HAD THIS DISCUSSION
ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR POINT I.
AND HERE'S THE REASON WHY
SUPPORT THIS IS BECAUSE THE
REASON FOR THIS DATA GATHERING
IS TO FOCUS ON LAW ENFORCEMENT'S
DISCRETION. AND WHEN YOU GET A
CALL OVER THE RADIO. YOU HAVE NO
DISCRETION. ALLOWED AND WHETHER
YOU RESPOND TO THAT CALL FOR
SERVICE. AND SO I THINK IT'S
MISLEADING. WHEN WE QUITE. SOME
OF THIS DATA THAT'S BEING
GATHERED AS DISCRETIONARY-
RESPONSE IT'S COMPLETELY
MISLEADING AND I DON'T THINK
IT'S FAIR AND FOR THAT REASON I
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR BRING IT
FORWARD. THANK YOU SIR ANY OTHER
COMMENTS MISTER CORK- I
UNDERSTAND- MR LACKEY ARE
CONCERNED. ARE ASKING THE SHARE-
IS THERE ANY WAY TO DISTINGUISH
THE SO THAT ONE CAN LOOK AT
SEPARATELY I THINK ALL OF THE
DATA SHOULD BE COLLECTED BUT
PERHAPS MR LACKEY DOES HAVE A
POINT- IN SOME CASES WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS POLICE. MAKING A
DISCRETIONARY A STOP IN ANOTHER
CASE EVEN THOUGH THERE MAY BE
RACISM EXPOSED IT'S NOT THE
POLICE OFFICERS FALL. HI MY I
THINK WHAT THE MATTER IS BEFORE
US TODAY IS NOT. I UNDERSTAND
THAT PERHAPS IF IT DOESN'T PASS-
WE COULD TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
APPROACH THE IN LAWS LIKE WITH
ANY BILL OF THE ARTICLE AFTER
RECONSIDERATION WE ARE HAPPY TO
BE DOING THAT A LOT. AND BUT IT
WOULD HAVE TO HAVE A YOU KNOW OF
ISSUE- A WILLINGNESS FOR THE
AUTHOR AND- COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
KIND OF WORK THROUGH THAT. AND
IT MAY BE SOMETHING YOU WOULD
LIKE TO WORK ON- YES I WOULD
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
YOU MAY CLOSE. JUST TO CLARIFY
IS. DIFFERENCE BETWEEN BEING
CALLED OUT FOR A CALL. I HAVE NO
IDEA LOOK LIKE WAS MENTIONED I
CAN'T SAY NOT A ONE GOAL THAT
CALL. DIFFERENCE BEING PULLED
OVER INTO UNDER REPORT TOTALLY
WHOLLY AGREE FOR IT I ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE. OKAY AND I THINK WE
NEED TO COLLECT ALL DATA BECAUSE
WE MAY FIND THERE IS RACISM EVEN
IN THOSE CALLS THAT HAVE AN
ADVERSE IMPACT OF PEOPLE OF
COLOR. ON ITS FACE IT MAKES ME
FEEL LIKE IT DOESN'T MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. BUT IT COULD MAKE A
BIG HUGE DIFFERENCE WHETHER OR
NOT YOU ASSIST WITH A YOUNG
AFRICAN LATINO WOMAN GETTING TO
THE HOSPITAL. WITH AN AYE YOU
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO
PARAMEDICS. ALL OF THAT COULD BE
. A PROBLEM BUT IF WE DON'T LOOK
AT THAT. AND TRY TO FIGURE IT
OUT. OF WE MAY FIND YOUR RIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID THAT IT HAS
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO DO WITH IT
BUT WE'RE NOT GOING TO KNOW THAT
LAST WEEK AGGREGATED
INFORMATION. THAT'S ALL FOR
TODAY HAVE BEEN ASTRONOVA. WE
HAVE. ON AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SITH THE
MOTION IS DUE PATH JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER NO LACKEY LACKEY I
BONTA BONTA KNOW BRIAN. BRIAN NO
CORK NO WORK NO SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO KNOWS THEY ARE TOO HIGH
THEY ARE TOO HIGH. THE MEASURE
DIDN'T PASS. THAT WAS THE LAST
ONE YOU WANT RECONSIDERATION
ARNOLD YES I WOULD TAKE
RECONSIDERATION I SHOULD HAVE.
IS THE OBJECTION BY. CONSENT.
NEXT WE WILL GO TO DO ANY ADD
ONS LIFTING OF CALLS IN VOTE
CHANGES BETTER STRUCTURE GO
THROUGH ALL THE MEASURES TAKEN
UP TODAY. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BRIAN. BRIAN I SANTIAGO
. SANTIAGO I. IDM ONE AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY TWO SANTIAGO. SAN
DIEGO I. THE ITEM NUMBER TWO
SIXTEEN THIRTY SEVEN WAS ON
CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX QUIRK.
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLOOR RELATING
TO CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES. YEAH.
I CORK I. ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY FIVE THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL QUIRK HIGH
COURT HI THAT MEASURE PASSES. I
DON'T NUMBER FIVE WAS ON CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB NINETEEN
FIFTY FIVE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER NO. I DON'T NUMBER EIGHT
WAS PULLED BY THE AUTHOR. ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
NINE. BY MISS REAVIS BOB BONTA
BONTA I. I DON'T NUMBER TEN AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY FOUR JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I. I DON'T NUMBER
ELEVEN WAS ON CONSENT. I DON'T
NUMBER TWELVE HAS BEEN DISPENSED
WITH. I DON'T NUMBER THIRTEEN AB
TWENTY THREE NINETY EIGHT BONTA
. BONTA NOT VOTING SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO NO. THE ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY SIX
THIS MEASURE WAS ON CALL BONTA.
BONTA HI THAT MEASURE PASSES. I
DON'T NUMBER FIFTEEN AB TWENTY
ONE NINETY FIVE THIS MEASURE WAS
ON CALL BONTA. I'VE BONTA HI
THAT MEASURE PASSES. I AM
SIXTEEN HAS BEEN DISPENSED WITH
ITEM SEVENTEEN WAS ON CONSENT
ITEM EIGHTEEN WAS ON CONSENT I
THE NINETEEN WAS ON CONSENT.
THIS INCLUDES THE BUSINESS FOR
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.